And all I can think now is, yeah, operation success
idea that Aerodite is my Gain Maxwell, which I >> What
if I told you that Steven regularly has said that Kyla or not
so Aerodite is really good at debate and does a really good job.
>> Best buddy of Queen and Jtock, Nicholas Dioro. If they
go to this thread, they're going to see that Destiny is like
linking their docs and complaining about it and reamplifying
it, right? And we're going what? Like we're demon mama. What?
What? Very dishonestly created clip. You should focus on his
white what
justice system or economic.
>> Yes. Destiny is is Hassan. Okay. Destiny is now Hassan.
Pisco is Destiny. And it's just going to be the same thing. It's
like, guys, why did we have Destiny around when we could get
the same information without anybody's consent being violated?
Okay, I might I might hold off on this. There's going to be a
lot of that Destiny stream that would be relevant to us. So,
I'm thinking about covering like the drama stuff from that stream
today. Riy says this is the starting point apparently.
I think >> is it the starting point? Maybe it is. Okay,
this is apparently the starting point for the drama. The drama
it we start from here. I don't care if I had to like lend support
to one side of this. This is the >> There I'm I'm going
to reset a little bit. There we go. >> I think Hutch, Josiah,
and Kyla so far have had their doces spammed because of the side
quote unquote that they're taking on this. Um, and then people
are actively seeking other doces for people near here. And I
don't know if people give a about getting out. Apparently, it's
just nobody cares anymore about this stuff. But this is the um
and then uh Queen and Justicle are scheming in their Discord
servers at night for how to like lend support to one side of
this. But this is the um I've talked to Queen for like I think
like 90 seconds one night in a Discord. I Dude, we talk at most
we fire up like some content and watch some content. I think
we might have watched Did we watch some maybe some Pisco content
or something the other night for like 30 minutes just commented
over that or something. It's like I don't even know scheming.
Dude, I just realized it's actually he once again Oh, it's so
sad when you see it, dude. You actually you see it so often.
Hold on. I got to fix my headphones. Hold on. I just realized
what happened here again. It's the same pattern we keep seeing
over and over again. He doesn't know what like friendship is.
He has no concept of it. So when when I like when I'm sitting
there, I finish my stream, I see Quimman's like uh like not doing
anything. I'm like, "Hey, you want to watch this piece?" I'm
like interested in this. You want to watch this? And he hops
in VC and we watch it in a channel that other people can join,
right? Destiny is like, "That's them conspiring against me."
No, Destiny, that's called like being friends with other people.
That's called like having normal, healthy social relationships.
That's like just being like and it's like are we even Oh man,
I hesitate because I don't want to put anything on that guy,
but like like are we I don't even know if he thinks we're like
that close. It's just like hey, I'm like, you know, I'm playing
a video game. Let's put something on in the background, get each
other's thoughts on something, right? And I can't remember the
last time it was Desty stuff.
It could have been it could have been recent. Probably some Pisco
stuff. Some Pisco or Hutch Lib and Learn stuff maybe.
I don't even know. But broadly, we used to do that a lot and
now for the past couple weeks, I've just been busy or he's been
busy and not as much. So,
>> um, this is like the act. >> I don't know why
I'm explaining that. I just think it's funny. I a little sad
that he doesn't understand that like friends would just hang
out and like listen to a video and play video games or something.
Just doesn't doesn't get it. It like actually doesn't click.
There's just nothing there. >> They have an ongoing campaign,
I guess, behind the scenes for for this stuff.
There's an ongoing campaign behind the scenes. Surely we'll see
evidence of this, right? >> There's an ongoing campaign
behind the
donated $3. Their couple name should be
Okay.
All right. Anyway, yeah, I don't get it. He like he like doesn't
understand friendship. And it's very funny every time he describes
it where he just doesn't get it at all. Does he just take extreme
edgy positions always because he knows he can farm it for weeks?
Yeah, I think so. He knows he has like a people a group of people
who always like rally to his side no matter what, right? Even
when they look really humiliated, maybe especially when they
look very humiliated, right? And that'll go to the zip zip conversation
we'll watch later where he totally comes in and humiliates himself
repeatedly, makes DG look horrible. I don't know if we can watch
that whole thing even, but we'll watch some of it. Okay. Anyway,
yeah. So, evidence of a cabal behind the
Like I would expect, you know, DMs, group chats, anything like
this. I had a cabal behind the scenes with Pretty Tony in August,
right? Where like they would share clips with me or be like we
would just have like arguments that But you know what I called
that? I called it a friendship. I we were friends, right? It
didn't it wasn't like a cabal of like we're shaping opinions
or something. It was like, hey, this was kind of interesting.
Hey, this is my opinion on this. But by the way, both of those
people very close to Destiny. um possibly even still. I have
no idea actually. I assume I assume August is still his editor,
right? So anyway, we'll see what evidence he posts.
Um, we'll see where Hassan weighs in on this
right-wing fascist piece of that's doing mass deportations of
migrants while simultaneously destroying the uh the the global
trade design that America actually invented that is greatly beneficial
for >> Is it uh Jin doing the doxing? Um, it never happens
in his servers directly. No, but there's >> Oh, so it's
not me doing it and it doesn't happen in my servers directly.
No. Okay,
then what? Why am I being blamed for it?
Why am I Why am I being blamed for it? Can someone explain that
to me? Also, is this what he said before? He said it was a doxing
community that spammed his docs or spammed docs from like Kiwi
Farm spam farms links. Why did he not uh
>> why is he retreating from his former
>> Do you remember when he talked to Counterpoints? Counterpoints
asked him why he did this?
Why is he retreating from all of this stuff? all of his actual
claims. No, you don't understand. It's connected to you because
you support the cabal that's doing it and they operate out of
places. Yeah. Like it's he's describing like the natural flow
of information through people. But >> there's a lot of
interflow between his community and the one that does do the
active doxing in general. Uh so there's act there's flow. Okay.
All right. You know what? Here's the thing. He claims, okay,
there's flow between his community being my community, right?
and communities that actively do doxing. Destiny is claiming
that he has evidence of this, right? He wouldn't just say it
for no reason. He has never presented this evidence to me. How
in the world I Dude, the big thing about KF, if assuming he's
talking about KF, is that it's an anonymous forum? How in the
world am I supposed to police people who apparently were on this
anonymous forum that he's aware of that apparently are also in
my Discord?
How am I supposed to police that? He says he has evidence. He's
never shared it with me. How How am I supposed to do anything
about this if he never shares it with me and I'm unaware of these
people being there? He's already admitted they don't do the behaviors
that are against my server's rules and he has evidence apparently
of their behavior in other servers. Am I supposed to be aware
of their behavior in other servers? Am I supposed to be aware
of things that are never shown to me and never reported to me?
Is that is that what the bar is for me, dude? I
like He's literally protecting doctors. He's objectively protecting
doxers, right? He's not reporting them. He's not. He's just trying
to hold cards or something for some sort of face off. I have
no idea. Apparently, he knows about doxers in my community that
don't dox in my community. Have never posted anything there,
but engage in other communities where like doc stuff gets posted.
I Okay. Yes. And you have to let him try to dox you in his own
chat as well because of the cabal. Apparently, he's the eternal
victim. his evidence that he keeps citing is the Blav account
or whatever has been targeting him for years before I was ever
against him before I probably before I ever knew who he was.
Right. So, we can go and we can uh I I have other stuff that
I kind of I like mused about this to myself. So, like we we'll
talk about some of that a little bit later. Anyway, >> uh
well, also simultaneously, >> dude, don't worry. We'll
we'll talk about it more. I don't think that's the last time
he mentioned >> allowing the Israeli genocide to
>> Do you know what ticked them off? Um yes. So the fact
that anybody if anybody mentions me and they don't mention me
as being like a or whatever um then what they do on their streams
is they constantly go over
um like conversations that constantly what does constantly mean
go over conversations that is he referring to like one conversation
I reviewed cuz somebody was like here was I think we reviewed
some Hutch thing and he said I wish I hadn't commented on it.
I was like oh what were his comments before? I thought his comments
before were good and then somebody linked me a clip of his comments
before. He can't possibly be talking about that situation, right?
And then say it's constant Erdite maybe. I When was the last
time I covered Eerite's position on uh the Pixie stuff? Months
ago. I'm not >> anybody's having and then they try to like
reset the um
they try to like reset the record on Oh, they're also trying
to dox um August as well to make sure the people they're trying
to dox August as well.
I can't even remember who he's talking about now.
But who who is this? I've seen no evidence of that other than
somebody said people should go after August in my chat once and
I nuked them immediately. I just nuke them from orbit immediately
because I think that's an insane
Right. So, I don't Yeah, I literally don't know what the he's
doing when he says this. I would love to see evidence of this.
Evidence that I'm connected to it in any way, right? But he won't
present evidence because he knows the evidence is weak. So, he
won't present it. He just wants to maliciously lie. Destiny,
present your evidence of this. Stop just maliciously lying about
me. Just present the evidence. Stop being a [__]
Stop having a fit on your stream. Present the evidence of this
actually happening so everybody can see just how schizophrenic
you are. Like knowing your a Yeah, they shouldn't. They shouldn't.
Amumu. Okay, >> I understand that. Like, hold on, guys.
You got to remember like Destiny's admitted to doing all of this
stuff and he's he's violated all these people's consent. Uh,
I had a clip on. >> He has violated Wait, he has violated
a bunch of people's consent. Molina,
uh, Abby, Cherry.
Who else is there? There's definitely other people. There's at least
one or two other people that are like on the record saying this.
What do you mean? He Yeah, that's not a crazy thing to say. What
are you talking about? Did I not say Molina, Stasia, Cherry,
Pixie? Oh, there's one more right there. H, there's one more
right there. Anyway, yes. Yes.
Was the Wasn't sure I was going to go through this. Okay, but
anyway. Yeah, multiple allegations. It's not just like any one
thing. I don't I wonder what this could be.
>> I need to start saving these better. That guy
might be a little bit worse than a Twitch streamer that believes
in >> Oh, wait. He's going to do the thing. Believes in
like what? Free healthcare and higher minimum wage. Is that speed
up a little bit? >> Being anti-stepass in his approach
to anti-war and wants better wants the American government. >> I'm
pretty sure he just meanders through like talking about this
stuff instead of talking about whatever's on his screen. >> Can
you be the president?
>> Okay. Okay. Anti-war, I guess. Okay. >> I I could.
Yes, I was born here. >> Rose. Sure. Me and Rose. Forgot
about that one. Whoever Blue Tea. Sure. Sure. >> You're
not UN enough yet. >> That's true. >> That's what
I was getting at. I wasn't talking about geography. >> I'm
34. I got one more year. I got one more year. >> Conversations.
Moot. Anyway. >> Yeah. Wait a year. Yeah, that's my message
to these perverts in general. Wait a year.
>> I'm pretty sure he does more here. >> I thought
he kept talking about this. >> I think it's really northern
line. >> Are we okay? Hope it does now. Dude, come on.
Well, Fat [__] here. Fatmoron says this. I guess
you could be a convenient ally to a Kfer who loves a good Dachshin.
There is there is like a there is a massive connection. Okay,
there's a massive connection between me and Kiwi Farms. Do you
know what it is? I don't like Destiny.
Kiwi Farms doesn't like Destiny.
But that's the connection, right? And that's actually what he's
trying to paint that connection as one that's being used to like
dox people or harass people in real life. Dude, that's it. That's
all it is. That's what he's trying to make it seem. He's trying
to paint me. He's trying to do this guilt by association thing
that he's just done to Pisco as well, right? That he's done repeatedly
to Pisco. He's trying to do this guilt by association thing so
people take me less seriously so he can like denigrate me to
his audience so he can try to like peel people off from my audience.
And it's not going to work because he's just lying, right? In
the past, he could do this. He could do this whole thing and
he wouldn't just be lying the whole time, right? But now he's
just lying. He needs to assoc associate Pisco with you, Quean,
and KF for his debate tomorrow to mitigate any damage Pisco might
do. That is another excellent point, Dead Buddha, right? He's
already he's already destroyed our reputations to his audience.
So now he has to get Pisco in closer. To be clear, I don't like
uh Pisco doesn't talk to me. I watch Pisco's stuff and just like
I agree with him because he's correct. It's not like like I think
you'll find that I've never been like a personal fan of Pisco's
argumentation style or how he treats some people who argue poorly.
And I think he's worked on those things, but like I was never
a big fan of Pisco when I was in DG, right? He's debating Pisco
tomorrow night selling a slot.
Yes, but he needs that to hit softer, right?
Yes. Pisco and Desty, I believe, are debating tomorrow. Yep.
Yep. >> Don't Don't come after my boy my goat like that.
Northern Lion would never. >> He would never. He's great.
This man is tarnishing the Hassan is worse. This whole discourse
is making me want to Oh, >> I Wow, he's reading my tweets
on stream now. Oh, okay. >> We We agree on that. I like
it. >> Dude, that tweet's been on stream for like 90 seconds.
>> Constantly on him. You suck right now. That's what one
of his mods said. >> Pick your poison. >> Oh, he's
watching Hush read my tweets. Sorry. Jesus. Three layers. Steve,
we being camps under Hassan. This is such a dumb hypothetical
poison. >> Let's see. Let's see. >> Yeah, there's
people. >> We have a lot of equipment chat message. Please
go to suck up and try and get in their good graces to make an
alliance. >> Okay. He's uh he's gone past the KF stuff
and I was going to go over just some of my thoughts on KF, right?
Like, see, Pisco said he's going full aggro in the debate tomorrow.
Oh, we'll see. We'll see how it goes. Dude, I am like kind of
sick and tired of this [__] attempting to associate
me with Kiwi Farms. I can't control if the people on Kiwi Farms
post like a a clip of me or something, right? I can't control
that. And if I get a clip from there, I don't mind using clips
like let's say uh it's a clip of Destiny, right? I don't mind
using a clip from there if somebody links it to me. It's just
archive information. But the idea that I'm like associated with
the activities in his thread, I think people just don't have
a good idea of what goes on in the thread and they don't realize
or sorry and it's like 1500 pages or something. So they don't
go and look. Yes. Who else is being actively harassed and doxed
in that thread or or trying to dox, right? It's Cherry. is literally
my girlfriend is is one of the people that they harass in that
thread. You think I'm good with them threatening to dox Cherry?
Like you all you have to do is think a tiny bit, right? Obviously,
I'm not cool with like the the [__] that goes on
there. Nobody at all. Oh, Si says she was as well at some point,
right? Nobody at all thinks that like this anonymous forum is
like beholden to some streamer. That's the entire purpose of
the forum is that it's anonymous and there are people who are
Destiny fans there who do harass like his victims directly.
Yes.
It's not like this identity of the forum is like anti- Destiny.
That's not true. It's like basically snark, right? It's basically
like snark for content creators. It's criticism, right? And sometimes
it will go beyond that. Oh, dude. audio that was secretly recorded
by this disgusting freak
of my girlfriend was maliciously posted there and then put into
a video
by Willie Mac. She had to go to YouTube legal to get that removed.
This website harasses people around me, but not because of me,
because of Destiny. It all comes back to Destiny. The ground
source of the harassment that comes from this is because of destiny.
And I'm so sick of him trying to actually like play around with
this, right? To try to like get out of this as his responsibility.
Dude, he threw a whole entire about Pixie
and her lawyers not wanting to remove videos of him from KF for
free. He threw a whole fit about it. Right. Did you even try,
Destiny, to get the audio of Cherry removed? Did you try to get
it removed from the Billy video? Would you try to get any of
that stuff removed or is it all about you? So why don't we just
look at how each person behaves with regards to Kiwi Farms, right?
I disavow doxing. I don't have a direct connection. I don't have
anything to do with like KF. They I don't I don't care that they
watch my stuff or that they post my stuff or that they archive
clips and they get linked to me. None of that matters to me.
I don't think that's wrong conduct. Okay. But what I don't do
is directly engage. What I don't do is uh go and fight with the
people in that thread. Right.
Destiny. Okay. On the other hand, all right, just imagine, dude.
Oh, I listen to this idiot speak and it's like, dude, you, Destiny,
you are the one who registered an account on Kiwi Farms, okay,
and post it. You're the person who engages directly with the
thread. You are the person who funnels people to Kiwi Farms.
You funnel people to Anna's thread. You funnel people to Lav's
thread. You funnel people to Keel's thread. You funnel people
to your thread to point out that Hutch and Josiah got doxed.
That's all you. You're the one doing that. In my communities,
you can't post KF links. You post them in your own communities.
You do Destiny. Your main anti-fan in that thread, the person
we referenced earlier, we can just say is Blav. Okay. That person,
the person who doxes the people around you, is only on Kiwi Farms
because of you linking Anavar's Kiwi Farms thread to DGers. They
were a DJer and then they found Kiwi Farms through you. you idiot.
And we all pretend like he doesn't understand. Okay, dude. He
pretends he doesn't understand like, oh, like it's not a reward
when he goes and engages directly with that. Like he's not actually
perpetuating that behavior. When he constantly links to Kiwi
Farms, when he constantly references it, right? He's pretending
he doesn't understand that. What does he say? Okay. What does
he say to everybody else when they have drama and something bad's
happening? Oh, uh, just ignore it. In 3 days, it'll all pass
and move on, right?
He'll he'll it'll all pass and it'll move on, guys. It'll be
fine. But for him, he gets to go and throw a whole entire it
and he knows exactly what he's doing. He's going to make people
even more obsessed with him, even more obsessed with this Kiwi
Farms thread. It's going to lead to more harassment. He knows
that for a fact, but he doesn't care. He doesn't care, right?
Because no matter what happens here,
he's going to he's going to uh like he's already doxed. He doesn't
care. Who gets hurt in all of this? The people around Destiny,
all of his conduct, the people get hurt are the people around
him, not him. He doesn't care. So, when he tries to paint me
as a as a KF person or like somebody who's linked to this, just
know that he has the evidence for him engaging with Kiwi Farms
and being a doxer and being a Kiwi farmer in general is 100 times
more than there's any evidence for me or Quean or anyone around
me. Okay.
>> All right. Just to make it clear. Okay. And uh because
we've got this guy here, uh the goolog, this total subhuman.
Uh bro, he shows a clip of your links pulled from a DG snarker/kf
user. You're well poisoning right now. Somebody sent me a link
of the exact thing I was talking about on stream and it was a
clip. Yes. If there's a watermark on that clip, okay, you understand
the goolog, you idiot. That if that's the bar, Destiny has violated
that bar times a thousand, right? He doesn't just use a clip
from Kiwi Farms that's got the time stamp or sorry that's got
the watermark on it, right? He literally directly links people
to his enemies Kiwis Farms. When he was when Zoe and Jacob first
rejoined my Discord, he linked and talked about in his thread.
He said, "Whoa, wait. Someone post Jacob's docs right now in
his in his DG chat."
Like, he uses this and he harasses people with it way more than
anyone else. Oh, this person doesn't understand that using a
clip that has a watermark on it is nothing like actually doxing
somebody or nothing like actually directing people to Kiwi Farms.
The goolog, you've got one chance. Explain to me how those are
equivalent.
Go ahead. Go ahead. We're waiting for you. Go on. Surely this
this guy won't, you know, spill a spaghetti. He's going to be
he's going to make a great argument here, right? Okay. Uh brainless
ran from the chat. Good luck.
Haha.
He ran. He ran running. But we know that DJers are either too
to know how dumb they sound or by nature, right? None of them
can argue any of these points. Don't worry though, Gulog. We'll
watch one of the DJers go and argue with Pisco. Totally fall
apart. Good luck,
>> I think someone can compile a bunch of streamers who
have watched watermark clips and his friends will be there, too.
Yeah, obviously
>> this kind of cowardice is totally typical of like the
DG viewer who knows that they don't have a point. They do know
they they know in the back of their minds just how embarrassing
they are, right?
But they will do things like that. They'll humiliate themselves
and they're totally comfortable doing it. Destiny and them both,
you know, they they share this this
connection, all right, where they they share this humiliation
fetish. It's uh disturbing,
but sometimes you have to engage with it to make it obvious to
everybody what's going on. >> Yes. Anyway, and they also
um just has a an account that he's put in Pierce Go's chat as
well to try to stir up as well. >> I literally watched
that. I watched the Zip Zip conversation and pointed out how
he was a spineless coward who wouldn't stand on any of his assertions,
would walk them back, and then at the end go, but that's what
people say because he's a obviously. >> Um it's like it's
like it's a whole coordinated thing. They're pretty >> Oh,
that's a good point, Salivation. So, just the whole thing where
he keeps like trying to virtue signal over the the Hutch and
Josiah doxing, right? When he gets when he gets asked about it,
what does he say? Hey, should we should we let them know? Should
we let them know? Destiny. Destiny, should we should we let them
know so they can see what they're doing? Oh, wait. Very violet.
Send it to who? Josiah and Hutch and stuff. Oh, man. They can
figure it them out themselves.
Should I let them know that this is happening because of me?
No. Should I let them know that it happened in 2024 because of
me? No. No, I don't think so. And he meticulously follows that
thread, by the way. He's meticulously followed that thread since
the Lauren Southern stuff got leaked there. That's when he started
posting there, right? He's meticulously followed that thread.
He knows that his friends get docks there and he doesn't let
them know. No, they can figure it out themselves, guys. And then
he'll go and virtue signal about it like he cares about them.
Lizard behavior. Okay.
Inhuman behavior.
crazy that after that interaction, he still defends them so hard
even on this
>> Yeah, it's it's it's just it's transparently like just
like an equation to him. It's just transactional, right? Like
he knows if I virtue signal about this person right now, it looks
good to my audience. Bro, do you remember he had to be shamed
into actually going to Mr. Mutton's wedding? Like he wasn't going
to go to Mr. Mutton's wedding and he was like, "No, I'm too busy,
guys."
This person barely fits into the the human skin suit they've
constructed. There's like zero humanity to this
>> It's all it's all just a performance. It's not real.
He is not a real person. Okay. Someone get me the clip of the
lady on the on the on the plane. Okay.
Get me the clip of the lady on the plane. That is not real. This
guy isn't real. He's not a real human with a soul. He only went
to hook up with Vi. Yeah, he did. Oh, yeah. This is this is broadly
what I believe it was, right? It was when he learned that V was
going to be there or could be there that he decided he was going
to go. Anyway, we >> They try their best.
>> Remember him saying relationships are just transactional
back then and that sure does hit harder now thinking back about
it. Yeah,
>> they try their best. >> Already he's literally
already sending people I
>> Yeah, that's right. I would be sending Hutch to the
camps, I guess.
and Pisco doesn't promote it. What is this loose association?
I've never said that Pisco promotes it. I don't think that Pisco
or them. I don't think any of them are part of this network of
people that are doing it. I'm just making you aware of the things
that are working in the background. I don't think I've even implied
that um Pisco and Econ boy would ever support that. I don't think
they support that in any way, shape, or form. So, I'm making
you aware of a network that operates in the background. Surely,
there will be evidence of a network that operates in the background
that does actual things. We all understand that he is doing the
exact Q Anon January 6 type that he has criticized conservatives
for, right? He's made this narrative and he totally tries to
build out anything he can into this narrative and what is it
the all roads lead to Rome thing where like even even counter
evidence you can actually just roll that into the same narrative.
The Jaw Queen Cabal apparently he's making us very powerful.
I like being powerful. I'm not okay. So, this is like the first
time I've gotten rolled into a cabal, and I kind of like it.
I kind of get why I feel superior sometimes. Okay, I'm getting
blamed for that I would have to be like a genius to have orchestrated,
right? I somehow went back in time and like got people to dox
Destiny's friends or something. I dude, I'm like I am like the
actual man who controls the time machine now. It's good. It's
like it doesn't feel that bad when people tell you they hate
this feeling. I'm telling you, it might not be that bad for them
if it's like this. That's a joke. I haven't faced any of the
persecutions that they have. Okay, it's just a joke. If you're
watching this, it's okay. Collab goes crazy. Dude, he By the
way, I'm just showing you evidence of the network that operates
in the background. Evidence being Quean commented in Pisco's
chat. JTO commented in Pisco's chat. They've watched the content
on stream. That's the evidence. That's the evidence. He's literally
describing the exact way that he operates that every streamer
operates, right? Hey, this guy's making some fun content. I like
this content. I'm going to go interact with that creator. He's
he's taking like the natural thing that happens in all of these
communities that happened in his community, happened in Vos's
community, happened in every community, and he's turning it into
a conspiracy.
Next, he's going to say, well, the next he's going to say, well,
this ogre boy guy, he chats in Jake's chat, and he also chats
in Lib and Learn, and he's a Hathon fan. He's got a Honhat tattoo,
actually. And uh and that proves a conspiracy. No, that proves
there's a guy who likes politics content who watches multiple
politics viewers. Like what? What? What do you think you're actually
proving?
Why not take credit though? Isn't it just a funny W at this point
if it's true? Uh well, what? Take credit for what? We do a lot
of the times or a lot of times we do. It's pretty funny >> form.
But it's just these are the people that are like working in the
background to try to like make all the drama and push everything
in a certain direction. >> Unironically,
these control the media. These they're controlling the media
by evidence. They're benefiting.
H right-wing personality latching on to identity as a target
rather than ideology is such a good point. Shek would like that.
How is physical community so powerful? Isn't it a super small
community?
How how do they control the weather precisely? Let's see the
answer. Okay, hold on. How is J's community so powerful? Isn't
a super small community?
it's like in Gaza. you could have a very tiny group that has
like authority over a bunch of people. I don't think he's going
to say that. I'm just thinking of like how could he answer this
in the most way possible that he won't answer >> It's not
really powerful. It's that if you have a group of like 10 or
15 people who are really dedicated in small edge spaces where
especially if stuff is already like in a certain direction, you
just try really really hard to control the narrative on everything.
And >> I literally have a a channel where people can go
and like debate Destiny's allegations and be as like pro Destiny
as they want.
The only people, by the way, the only people who get like banned
from the Discord, I believe, are people who are outright like
hateful,
right? Or people who come in and go like who are energy vampires
who will lose an argument, who are like the Zip Zip guy who will
lose an argument and then they will go back to to just making
the same argument the next day. Those are the only people who
get banned. Anyone who's not that kind of loser is welcome. >> And
what they do in the meantime is if you ever push back against
it or >> I have to I have to remember before the stream
tomorrow in Zane to fix kick. I don't know exactly what's making
it go back to 720p, but I will have to fix it. >> Then
they just try to like gaslight you and say like, "Oh, you're
crazy. Like we don't have anything involved in any of
>> Sorry, I missed that. >> You have a group of like
10 or 15 people who are really dedicated. >> 10 or 15 people.
>> So he has evidence of 10 or 15 people who are very dedicated.
So here's the thing. He either has to prove my connection to
them or 720p and 22. Okay, good to know. Uh, he has to prove
my connection to them or he has to prove how like I'm somehow
like allowing them to operate, right? How why am I being blamed
for them, right? It can't just be people who dislike Destiny.
That can't be the connecting factor. You can't take me disliking
Destiny and running a server that has people critical of Destiny
in it and make that an evil. That is not evil inherently, right?
He has to prove my connection or my support for these people.
And that's that's what I think he will sorry I don't think that's
what he'll consistently fail to do, right? He's always going
to fail to do that because that doesn't that didn't happen. It's
not happening. I'm literally against doxing. I'm against all
of that kind of behavior.
It's why it's banned from my server. So anyway, but he said it's
a doxing community. He said it was like a Kiwi Farms community,
right? That's what he said. Now he's falling back from that and
he's going, "Oh, it's only 10 or 15 people." by the way, give
me those 10 or 15 people with the evidence you have and I could
look at doing something, right? But you won't give me any of
that evidence. You've never reported these people. You've never
done anything. Small edge spaces where especially if stuff is
already like in a certain direction, you just try really, really,
really hard to control the narrative on everything. And then
what they do in the meantime is if you ever push back against
it or mention it, then they just try to like gaslight you and
say like, "Oh, you're crazy. Like we don't have anything involved
in any of this." Um,
>> what? Hold on. What? No. I've I've literally said you're
a [__] And probably there are a lot of people on
Kiwi Farms who also think you're a complete.
If those people are in my server because they're like, "Oh, I
there's another community of people who think you're a
then I can't police that, right? I don't know who those people
are. They're anonymous on Kiwi Farms. If you know who they are,
you could try to report them,
But it's like, dude, I'm sorry. I can't penalize people for saying
you're a because they might have said something on Kiwi Farms,
too. Unless I know about the connection. You have to show me
that. Any evidence, bro. Anything.
>> Yeah, man. That's it. That's it. I uh I am a far uh
far more interesting target than to actually like
>> I just noticed Rhox's uh his avatar. Awesome. Awesome.
very very topical avatar. Let's go >> discuss the issues
on the boundaries of policy on the boundaries of impact of policy
on what it would look like if you were to to play out a a legislative
agenda that like puts workers >> Why even mention them?
Because people like Hassan like all the way at the top are amplifying
everything that comes from these people. So I >> So Hassan
is just taking By the way, if Hassan is doing this, good job,
Hassan. We have way better advice for you than most of the people
around you. We would be way better orbiters. Okay? Although I
broadly think your political takes are I probably it probably
wouldn't end well between us. Okay. But I'm just saying if you
take like the things we say and just repeat them, you will look
a lot more intelligent than taking the things like Mike says
and repeating them. Okay? I'm just saying. Uh so Hassan's way
smarter than I thought if he's just taking the stuff from us
and repeating it. Amazing. Hassan is bad. You don't know what
Destiny is saying right now is projection, right? This is the
exact tactic Destiny goes does to anyone he's fighting with.
Well, I don't even know when he's done it in the past necessarily.
I do know it is projection now. Yes. But it's like transparently
projection.
And I'll just keep saying like, "Post your actual receipts of
the things you've said." And then I'm going to line them up cuz
he knows the second he posts the evidence he has of anything,
I'm going to go line it up with the actual assertions he made
and make him look like even more of a [__] So he
can't post his evidence. He is stuck in a bind here where he
is making claims that he doesn't have evidence for and he just
keeps looking like a to everybody who's not in the cult. Right?
You guys remember the the big the big tent for the circus, right?
And all the DJers are inside and a lot of them are like, "Oh,
we're winning, guys." Because they're in the tent. They can't
see anyone outside. But there's like a 100,000 times more people
outside who are all pointing and laughing at the freaks in the
tent. And all of the people outside of the tent can see that
you're a freak, can see that you're just making things up and
having your own conspiratorial meltdown, right? Do you know who
Sock Demon Incel is? I do. We can talk about it in a second.
So, I'm just I'm just happy that you continue to make yourself
look like a total freak to the people outside of the tent. >> I'll
just be more blatant about pointing it out from now on because
cuz when I bring up when I bring this stuff up like very sparingly,
then I just sound like um like I'm schizoposting.
But >> you are schizoposting.
He is totally skitso posting. Oh, speaking of schizoposting,
does anyone have the Odishara tweet?
Should I pull the should I pull the Odashara tweet now that he's
mentioned skits posting? Uh no, I'm going to leave it alone.
That guy's That guy's out.
No, that guy's out of his mind. I'm not going to work, you know,
like amplifiers, all the stuff. I think I kind of have to call
it out. So, I will call it out when I see it. >> Uh, but
what I will say is there's somebody Oh, here. Here's what I'll
do. Okay, here's what I'll do. I'll give it I'll give it 100%
charity right now. Okay, I'll just engage with it directly. So,
there's a Desi alleges Queen alongside Kiwi Farms are behind
the doxing of Noto Aerodite, Josiah, and Hutch and they're attempting
to dox his editor, August. So, he does allege this because he's
an insane loser, right? Totally insane loser. But Odashar comes
before this and says, "So I wasn't in belief of this at first,
but after confronting Jay talk about it, I was pretty sure it
was from the that community. A couple months ago." Wait, when
did he confront me about it? He mentioned the letter that he
got to me and I said, "Can you show me which he couldn't, but
I when is he confronted me about this?" So I was pretty sure
it was from that community. A couple months ago, cuz I'm a fan
of Destiny and the JTO server. Someone in his community sent
a letter to my home. I've moved since to my house saying, "I
defend Destiny because I want to my wife in patience." So apparently
this guy got a letter to his house that said, "Hey, I'm in the
Jtock server and also I want to I I'm going to say you defend
Destiny because you want to your wife and patience." So apparently
the person the person went and looked all that information up,
found out where he lived and handd delivered a letter, I believe.
Now, I don't have my old account, so I don't have those DMs right
now. But I believe they handd delivered a letter to Odashar's
house because there was no postmark. There was no way to check
like any any where it come from, right? And what he did, his
first reaction to this was to immediately throw the letter out
and not tell anybody. That was what he that was his first reaction.
So, apparently he got like somebody who is like psychopathic
doxing him. >> Just tip $10. >> Oh, hello, Mr. Grinch.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Hold on. Oh, there
are people like calling this out for how crazy it is, right?
Will you admit that this sounds made up? Yeah, I didn't believe
it was from his community at first. I even said as much in DM
with JOK. That's not true. That's not true at all. No, that's
not true. I don't have my old account to prove it. Oh, that's
not true. He's just lying. He's just lying. It is Kingston Hawk.
It's Dude, the bull never misses. Okay, the bull never misses.
He's here. He knows. Okay, this is the guy who Hunter
We We see it. We see it. We see you, King. You mess with as as
they say, you mess with the bull, you get the horns. Don't call
him that. No, he is. He is who he is, Jerry. We can't We can't
stop that from being true. Okay, fair enough. Just feels like
this is the type of claim you should only post if you have evidence
to go along with it. At least if you're 100% sure. Or at least
if you're 100% sure. Even if I had the letter, the next question
would be, "How can you prove that you didn't type it yourself?"
Which would also be a fair question. or do you think we should
just all all just start accepting any wild accusations without
any without asking for evidence? I just said it was my belief
it came from his community, which he said at the time. And I
told him like he was having here's the thing. He was having fights
with people in the community and then this came out of nowhere
because he was getting bullied for being a loser. He is just
broadly a loser and he was being bullied for being a loser and
then he suddenly had this letter that showed that people were
totally unhinged in the server, right? And like the other thing
is one of the times I actually talked to this guy in
>> he was like crying to me about Dan doxing him. Like
apparently Dan menaced him with like his his real name and and
like where he worked
>> and then and then like a week later when he was no longer
mad about it, he was like defending Dan trying to dox other people
as a very bizarre person. Very very bizarre person. I can't help.
>> Anyway, I said it was my belief. The more his community
gets accused of engaging in this behavior, the more I believe
it. I don't care about the this person or their community. I'm
just putting out the issue with a bunch of people saying the
the same claim with no evidence and then treating that like it's
evidence. Oh, yeah. Sure.
Okay.
>> Dan scared him into submission. He's just like a weirdo.
He's just a weirdo. But I like again, I'll actually engage with
what he's saying. He said he got a letter that was like made
him feel fear for his safety and his wife's safety. And then
he told me his his reaction to that was to take that letter and
throw it in the garbage and never talk about it again like with
the police or anything. So he took his only evidence of like
him apparently being threatened and fearing for his safety and
he threw it in the garbage.
belief is reinforced by Destiny saying that the community engages
in the behavior, but Destiny didn't say that, right? Destiny
hints at it and then he says, "No, no, no. I don't think it's
the whole community." No, no, no. Nobody's posted anything in
that server. No, no, no. JTO's not like done it. Okay. Uh, then
what? What were you talking about before?
>> Oh, one second. One second.
>> Hold on. I don't know what this is. Sherry linked me
a tweet. Uh-oh. What is this? What if I'm not Cherry? And what
if the fact that no one has heard Cherry's voice or seen her
face since before she went to Canada is because Jtock already
killed her? And what if Destiny concern trolling over Cherry
is to cover for JTock and help pretend she's alive? And I have
to have evidence against this, don't I? Has Cherry guys, has
Cherry joined any VCs?
She's joined VCs, right? She's just messing with me.
The obvious skits post will rece this obvious skitso post will
receive more thought and more focus to dismiss me than any serious
or source statement I make by the same people who pretend jokes
are okay and mental illness shouldn't be stig stigmatized. This
one is 100% not J-Tock posting on all of Sorry, it's way funnier
when she says, "Oh, it's like a it's a joke." And then she leans
into it again. I'm sorry. Uh this is 100% not Jtock posting on
all of Cher's accounts from the laptop and iPhone she brought
to Canada with her. I promise. Worth consideration. Thank you.
Uh,
okay. All right. All right.
>> I don't uh Hooligans, thank you for the gifted sub.
I believe I uh
[__]
>> I
Oh, checkmate. Checkmate. Cherry. I could totally go to the airport.
They'd have They'd have footage. Okay. They'd have footage. I'm
in the woods with cheese somewhere in Canada right now. Even
if she has been in VC, prove you don't have an AI cherry voice.
I do have an AI cherry voice changer. It's uh I do actually have
that. I do actually have it. That is true. That is true.
Bring up my last comment. Wait, what was your last comment? Bring
up my last comment. What was your last comment? I can't bring
it up on screen anymore. It's gone. It's gone. It's gone. It's
gone. It's gone. Link it if you uh if you have it somewhere.
Hold on, Ogre Boy. Wait, I have to go open your log somewhere
else. I remember someone telling me like last year in my replies
they knew who he was and that they wanted to report him for his
tweets because they thought he would hurt his patience. Oh, crazy.
Guys, Cherry is still alive. Guys, guys,
if I wanted to if I wanted to get rid of Cherry, I would need
an alibi. I would need a digital alibi. Okay? I would need a
digital history of where I was to to fool the cops. Just start
pontificating on all of the things we would need to actually
get away with a crime, right? Totally fine. I read Sorry, Ogre
Boy or I read your last comment where somebody was talking about
this guy being a danger to his patients or something. Yeah, if
you can find it, that would be
>> Okay. Okay, dude. Okay, dude. Someone is referencing
his patience. I assume it's him on an alt. He cares about the
fact that he's a nurse more than anything else. Yeah, I don't
think that many people pay attention to be honest with you. Although,
I wouldn't be shocked if when he was So, Ogre Boy said that.
I wouldn't be shocked if ogre boy had somebody say that because
he would go and fight like Odashar would go and fight with um
like Hassan community people, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. All right. Where were we here?
Okay. We were just at the part where he was pointing out the
network. He said Pisco and Hutch and those people don't don't
support any of this. Right. Let me pull it back a little. >> And
then what they do in the meantime is if you ever push back against
it or mention it, then they just try to like gaslight you and
say like, "Oh, you're crazy. like we don't have anything involved
in any of this. Um,
yeah.
>> I dude, this is this is like him saying like I showed
that Roy Moore was like he he like liked a Facebook post from
the FBI in 2004
and then when they tell you that Roy Moore didn't engage with
the FBI as like a as like an uh as an infiltrator, they tell
you you're crazy, right? Or sorry, when they they'll claim that
even though you have proof of the like, it's like, dude, you
haven't proven anything. You've given no evidence. You've You
just say it. You just try to wish it into reality. Did say that's
okay. I did say that. But
>> yeah, man. That's it. That's it. >> Technically,
no. Technically, I said he was rude. I didn't say I didn't say
I him. I said you're just rude right now. >> What I said.
I am a far uh far more interesting target than to actually like
discuss the issues on the boundaries of policy on the boundaries
of impact of policy on what it would look like if you were to
to play out a legislative agenda that like puts workers >> Why
you even to mention them because
>> at Destiny I was watching a Jtock clip on food shop
stream and he claims that you're actually the one trying to dox
Dude, this is like there are probably people like this, right?
Destiny, did you know that he's actually claiming you're trying
to dox him? Is there any truth to this? >> Like Hassan
like all the way at the top are amplifying everything that comes
from these people. So I'll just be more light about pointing
it out for now because when I bring up when I bring the stuff
up like very sparingly then I just sound like um like I'm schizop
posting. But when people like Hassan are now actively platforming
people like that and banana who are also you know like amplifiers
of all the stuff I think I kind of have to call it out. So I
will call it out when I see it. Did you see Queen's defense of
Assan's re-education camps? Yes, Queen and again are like full
on like 100% like like scheming in the background. >> Oh,
this is where I actually clipped something. I was watching at
this point. This is where I like thought it started. That's why
I thought I were on the wrong time stamp. I thought this is where
it started. Okay. Why do people do the grabler hands? What are
you doing? This is actual anti-semitism right now. Like >> hold
on. Hold on. Hold on. >> Full on like 100% like it's like
>> why are you doing grappler hands? I can't tell if he's
talking about a person right now or if Destiny just saw a 15-year-old
at an esports event. Okay. I think it's basically the same reaction
both times. >> Stir and cause drama and push people in
a certain way. I'm trying to find this clip somebody sent me
of um just feels like watching like the four of the live and
learn guys talk and he's like oh do these guys not remember that
Dusty fully admitted under testimony that he's guilty of all
the crimes. Like what what is this? Oh, I think I said that when
Josiah said he admitted he sent it non-consensually. I said he
admitted under oath. He did admit under oath or under penalty
of perjury that he sent the video. Right. that is uh that is
like not something that's contested at all. So he he did admit
that he sent it and I was you know I I said he was admitting
he sent it. I miss like technically there's a way you could uh
I'll just say I misspoke actually I misspoke. So he did admit
to sending it. He signed an affidavit saying he sent it and he
also is told straight raid that he sent it non-consensually in
like no uncertain terms. This re-education, as Hassan explains
in the leftovers clip, is referring to dradicalization programs
for violent offenders and terrorists who commit ideological crimes.
This is just objectively true. And Desty like hasn't watched
the clip yet, so he says this incredulously. This is just objectively
true, right?
Literally just objectively true. That is in the clip from Leftovers.
That is what Hassan says. Now the the actual salient criticism
of that is Hassan never says what happens with just the people
who are like advocating for capitalism. Can you let them just
advocate for capitalism right? So he doesn't say that but he
does say that like oh what I think should like re-education would
only be for people who have like committed ideological crimes
violent ideological crimes something many Euro countries already
do very dishonestly proed clip you should focus on just white
what
ex I'm sorry excuse me oh hold on what
queen just explained like uh just explained exactly how you would
criticize it right this is like a totally centered claim this
is a totally centered claim hey actually you're like kind making
up the thing he said. But he did something sort of bad there.
He sort of whitewashed. He just said, "Oh, there's a surveillance
state in Shenzhen, right? Oh, there's like some forced thing
in Shenzhen." He didn't talk about like the actual crimes being
committed there. So like that is what you could that is what
you could actually criticize. So Quintan doesn't just say, "Oh,
Hassan is good." He goes, "Actually, you're kind of like missing
the the real criticism here, which is this whitewashing of Shenzhen."
And we're going, "What? Like we're demon mama?" What?
What? >> Very dishonestly proed clip. You should focus
on his white. What?
>> I'm sorry. Excuse me. What? That's just like a 100%
true. That is just a one to one obviously true fact right there.
Right. Like there's just nothing. I say, "Are you mad?" Sure.
Are you mad? Are you mad? Are you mad? What
is your number two hate watcher? Yeah. And it's so funny, too,
because he was such like a >> I mean, I'd probably have
to give him number one hatewatcher, right? I just like I he he
started early. Okay, I'm like catching up, but he started early.
He like started hate watching from like the Keffles manifesto.
So I I don't I feel like if he put me as number one, I'd probably
have to give that up to Que. Okay, I think I think Queen would
be number one still. I can't I can't just dethrone that guy cuz
I've started hating this guy recently. Right. >> Every
time we were in a call together, he wouldn't say anything to
me at all. But I realize now why. It's because remember the >> Oh,
that's him talking about Queen. >> What? Oh, that's brutal.
>> Quinnman is your number two hate watcher. Yeah. And
it's so funny, too, because he was such like a every time we
were in a call together, he wouldn't say anything to me at all.
But I realize now why it's because remember the way that the
So, this is something that uh haters and detractors of Queenman
say. Okay, the issue is Destiny used to have, you know, his controversies
were like debatable, right? The reason Queen goes so much harder
now is because this stuff is no longer debatable, right? There's
no real debate to be had there. There's a ton of actual evidence.
you don't have to like debate it anymore. So, he might not have
wanted to say, "Oh, you Lauren Southern in summer 2023 or whatever,
right?" He might not have wanted to say that because then he
has to present a whole thing of evidence and it's not the point
of the show and it might like get him like not uh on streams
in the future or something, right? So, he doesn't want to say
that, but is it it's not appropriate to say, right? You can see
through the Destiny. You can see through the Destiny is also
a part of it. Oh, right. Why he's uh why he's upset. Sorry, I'm
reading a message. It's kind of disconnected. Wait, was there
a PFP?
Was the PFP I pulled just now? Not this one. It's the Ogre boy
PFP. Damn. All right. Anyway, so all Destiny hate watchers are
big dog little dog. That was just a totally madeup thing. We
literally watched at the beginning of the stream. Like I get
called big big dog little dog after this >> charge the
you just got >> I didn't get at all. You haven't you haven't
demonstrated anything.
>> This guy never gives his real criticism on stream. Always
did. Always do.
Good times. >> Propaganda works. It's like it can never
be directly confronted. You always have to have like your own
little environment in the background where you can say
Dude, there's no way he makes that criticism. You can't you can't
just like make these criticisms in public. You always have your
little echo chamber in the background where you make these No,
we're all on stream calling you a weird degenerate freak to your
face, saying you're a habitual consent violator to your face.
You have no actual argument back against this because it is true.
It is proven out. It is bolted on. Shut the up. You're the person
who doesn't engage with this stuff. You're the person who always
appeals to your legal case when you get asked an uncomfortable
question. Holy [__] You have to find like the weakest
people. Um you have to find like the weakest people to fight
with because
No, we want the best. Send me the best. Holy [__]
Send me the best. Dude, we're taking the only people all most
of these people are cowards.
Complete and utter cowards. They can't defend anything they say.
They just want to take a shot on Twitter and run away, right?
They're total cowards. But the 5% who do show up are, right?
That's not my fault. I can't tell if you're they're your best
or they're your worst. I think Zip Zip's one of your best. You're
the guy who brought him on stream and used him to back up your
opinion and now that looks even worse. How good does the Zip
Zip How good does the Zip Zip testimony on Destiny's court hearing
look now that you watched him go on Pisco's stream and be a total
NPC? Right? That's what Destiny's actually upset about. Destiny
doesn't have a single ally who is intelligent or compelling on
their own. There's not one left, right? They're all embarrassing
in different ways. And that's what he's confronting right now
is all of his allies are embarrassing. And I'm totally fine.
This guy, this guy can try to make up about me if he wants, but
all of his allies are embarrassing because if you have to actually
confront the insane [__] you're saying, you always
look like a >> Hutch is his best knight. I don't think
Hutch I. So, I went through and I softened my take on Hutch,
right? I went and listened to his whole thing where he talked
about being an NA and how he looks at like recovery and rehabilitation
and I was like, "Okay, that's fine. I don't think you should
really entertain that with regards to destiny before he shows
any uh contrition at all." But I understand and that's okay,
right? That was my that was my take on Hutch. So, I don't I don't
think we have to count Hutch as like a destiny ally. I think
Hutch is like trying to do his own thing and he's having a a
tough time with it because he's got very very like headstrong
people around him. Hutch will be fine. And Hutch is like after
I watch Hutch's initial reaction to the Pixie stuff, it's like
that was the reaction. He had a good reaction. I didn't like
that he said, "Oh, I've seen stuff behind the scenes or something
that kind of changes." I didn't like that as much, but like his
initial reaction that was like I don't know what more you could
ask for, right? That's like about as good as a reaction could
be.
So, I don't know. Anyway, which is why every single call that
I was ever inqued with, he never said anything to me at all.
He actually pointed out how Merkoff to Perk Cope was.
So, this is not even necessarily true, right? That was Destiny
was like, "Guys, I couldn't even I couldn't have even physically
reached Merc's like uh like her crotch. Guys, I was she's really
big and I couldn't have done that. Physically impossible." And
Queen was like, "Are you insane?" I can't remember what he said
exactly, but he's like, "Are you crazy? You out of your mind?"
Uh, I'm going through um a claim of culpability like yours. A
home owner told me about a problem they have after some work
I did on their house they're using.
I'm sorry to prove I'm 100% of all based. >> Peace code
defended the Hassan reucation >> Darius, are you uh how's
the legal case going? You going to keep your dog? We we called
that out. Okay, we disagreed. Don't let her take GMO. That was
up. Okay, we don't feel bad for you in most of the cases, but
like don't we want GMO to stay at home. We all want GMO to be
safe. Okay, how's how are the other stuff go? How's the other
stuff going? Did you find a lawyer for the uh the hearing? I'm
hoping I don't show up at any more events she hosts. Oh, that
would be a good call. Yeah, I think that would be a good call.
>> Camp clip and my callin saying it's not really what
a son said. Quoting a post put on his subreddit. Wait, zip zip
link me the link give me the time stamp it cuz that's that's
the drummer. >> Oh, he's going to go over this thread.
I was thinking about skipping this, but I might just go through
the thread. Like, why not why not just watch the cope from that
thread and see how that goes? It would be pretty funny. >> We're
doing right now. And then I'll explain I guess like the econom
boy stuff. That post was made by a snarker Hassan and Mr. Girl
poster I think. Wait link link. >> I mean dude the post
is
>> The post is just obvious isn't it? He skips the part
you are most interested in. What do you mean he skips the part
I'm most interested in? He skips the actual clips of Zip Zip
and Hassan. How does he skip the clips that all of it is uh predicated
on? >> I need drama researchers next. You shouldn't trust
EG with how to interpret Assan's ideology. Re-education camps
as an example.
>> with Donald Trump. Part one, re-education and Hassan's
ideological >> Wait, what? All three of the most hated
people in DG at Jtock. Wait, what are you saying? Hold on. I
missed I missed Ronox. I missed it. Hold on. We're going to play
this one. Yeah. >> Also, give me two seconds. I need to
grab some more water. I'll be right >> I reeducation camps
as an example. >> Cop with Donald Trump. >> Part
one, reeducation and Han's ideological beliefs. On yesterday's
stream, someone named Zip Zip called in and claimed that Assan
wants reucation camps and referred to his conversation with Ethan
Klein about them. Assan does not believe in having reeducation
camps. And this interpretation that he does is clearly bad faith
when you listen to Hassan's fleshed out thoughts. Here are the
clips >> with Donald Trump on things. >> Okay. So,
you're saying, for example, when he's against
the deportations to Sakat, it's because
he because why? be well because he doesn't like Donald Trump
and because he hates minorities or for whatever reason. But but
basically I I I know what you're getting at, but has also explicitly
said that he would be in favor of like re-education camps in
his ideal society or whatever in that one conversation with Ethan
Klein. I don't know if you've seen that clip, but there's a lot
of stuff there that if you look at
I think Kirk I think Kirk would but Kirk right now is defending
the stuff that's happening actually happening and I think Kirk
would also support reeducation camps if Trump instituted it.
So I don't >> I don't disagree >> but but I but I
I say I think that like >> like there's a difference here.
>> Oh, I see. Rehox somebody in the chat message they said
the the poster is a Hassan Mr. Girl or other something. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
Charlie Kirk, I don't think would do re-education camps on his
own. I think he'd probably support Donald Trump literally whatever
the Donald Trump did because Charlie Kirk >> Oh, Charlie
Kirk will suck will suck Trump's but Charlie Kirk himself is
not a religious fascist. Okay, he's not he wouldn't do a theocracy
or anything, guys. Charlie Kirk himself is maybe not that bad.
He's just Trump's balls are too alluring for him to get away
from.
>> Kirk is Donald Trump's number one nut hugger. But Hassan
would implement reeducation camps all on his own. But >> Kirk
would also support a bunch of other >> Okay, so you have
to pick here. Is Hassan the hyper capitalist, hyperconsumerist,
like totally morally bankrupt, without principal guy who flies
to Coachella in a private jet with a $900 shirt on. Is that who
he is? Is he that person who can't live any of his principles
in the world? Or is he the guy who would like go, "Yeah, this
culture that I've been raised in, this culture that like I actually
love, yeah, I'm going to destroy all of it." Would he really
do that?
It can't be both. It can only be one of the two, right?
>> Can only be one of the two. >> That Hassan wouldn't.
>> Well, yeah, but then Hassan would also support a bunch
of up that nobody's doing ultimate power, fat [__]
Nobody does the ultimate power thing. That's a hypothetical.
Why would you argue that? That's like Superman versus Goku. You
have to be a complete loser to care, right? Why do like unknowable,
unfalsifiable hypotheticals?
Nobody wants the ultimate power hypothetical. It's so stupid.
>> Nobody interpreted it that way. Destiny certainly didn't
interpret it that way from Pisco. >> Kirk wouldn't. Tom
I don't know what.
>> Yes, but not because of
not because of where where they came from. Like Hassan would
Hassan would support stuff that Charlie Kirk would not abide
by. >> Oh, exactly. >> And so if the and so if the
will of the people is to go back to do more of a social democracy
>> Okay. So, I just want to remind people that the claim
here is not okay.
Kingler, that was a shot at you. I'm sorry. I don't actually
think that. I think that's fun to discuss like off stream in
a random VC. It can be fun. It's like a fun, but it's like joint
storytelling more than it is like any kind of factual or exercise
and understanding. It's just like joint storytelling. It's like
fun can be fun, but it's not the same. Okay. It's like playing
pretend is what it is. Uh, okay. Oh, I just want to make it clear
here that the the issue here is with the claim Zip Zip made that
Hassan said this on leftovers, right? It's not a broad claim
that Hassan might support re-education camps. It is saying I
know Hassan supports re-education camps because of the leftovers
clip, which is wrong. If you think it because of the leftovers
clip, you are like my right. You you do not actually know what
you think. You you believe something falsely in this clip. He
does not say he supports re-education camps. He is not saying
I want re-education camps for people who support capitalism.
That's not what's going on here, right? Notice did a deep dive
rehash of all of Assan stuff, but won't do the same for Kirk.
In fact, he's already he's hardly ever gone over Kirk at any
point in time, even as he's being recruited for America, where
the whole premise where that's the whole premise. In fact, he's
glazed him more in recent times, if anything, numerous times
for his Gavin Newsome appearance. Damn.
Damn.
Is that something that a socialist country should move towards
or should there be resistance to the government to keep socialism?
>> I think the resistance should be akin to how capitalist
governments have resisted historically any kind of socialist
movement. Not to that same degree of violence, but I think that
yes,
>> so just to break down what's being said here, Ethan.
So to break down what Yeah, break it down. client is saying also
this is why I'll come down on econom boy later as well who's
I think tweets were insane but um what would happen if you had
a social democracy or whatever the social discovery you had and
there was like a political party that was coming up that was
um you know like a capitalist or liberal uh political party and
Hassan says they should be resisted the same way that capitalist
countries resist socialism when Hassan says that he's not talking
about what is actually happening today which is where people
are like oo boo socialism in his mind all of socialism is failing
because of CIA ops all over the world that is destroying socialist
governments and secretly murdering. It's like McCarthyism plus
the Cold War era CIA. That's what Hassan thinks. That could be
true that he thinks anything that capitalist society has done
to suppress communist thought is is relevant, right?
>> But then unless you're unless you're like that's just
a wash, isn't it? Isn't that just a wash? The CIA is doing now
and that's >> that could be that could be something far
more sinister. Absolutely it could be. But why not just wait
for him to elaborate on it?
Also, McCarthyism is not camps. None of that is camps. None of
that is proving the point that is originally brought up by Zip
Zip. So, we're just trying to deflect away. I'm guessing he's
pre-watched this. I'm guessing he's figured out an argument.
But again, he's totally deflected away, right? This is about
re-education camps and this is not the same point. We're totally
redirecting. We're totally pivoting to a different point that
he can maybe defend. That's what he kind of wants his socialist
government to do, although not quite as bad. He says >> there'd
be resistance in the government to keep socialism. I think the
resistance should be akin to how capitalist governments have
resisted historically any kind of socialist movement. Not to
that same degree of violence, but I think that yes, um the the
solution to that would always be education and offering more
remember like the solution to enemy political parties is education.
We have to
>> uh said no Democrat ever. The reason the Republicans
are successful is because of poor education. Has no Democrats
ever said that. Right. Has that Has that ever No, we never we
never say, "Oh, poor education leads to Republicans staying in
office." We've never said that before.
Okay.
Good faith, by the way. >> Educate them. Meaning that there
is no legitimate disagreement between socialism or liberalism/
capitalism. They It's just re-education. That's it.
>> No, it's it's that you would be uneducated. Wait, what
is the reason for like wanting a theocracy? It's because you
don't you don't have a very good education. You don't understand
that like there are systems that work better and serve more people,
right? How is that even confusing? >> With some degree
of violence, but not as bad, I guess, as the CIA was in the Cold
>> Re-education certainly. >> So, so Hassan doesn't
say re-education. Ethan says re-education. And Han says, "Well,
I'm not going to totally ditch that label because re-education
and rehabilitation seem pretty similar to me." I think they're
very similar. And he goes on his own thing, right? Re-education
has a historical meaning, does it not? It does have a historical
meaning, which is what Ethan is trying to say. And I think what
Hassan is trying to say is the goal of re-education was a noble
goal. So I don't want to abandon the concept because I'm guessing
it's a socialist like teaching or something, right? He's like,
I don't want to abandon that, but obviously I don't want to do
it like in the ways you're talking about with
>> Like Ethan even uses the kind of coded dog whistle word
or whatever like re-education, like reeducation camps. And just
owns it immediately. He knows what these are, right? He must
know the meme, right? The reeducation camp meme. Hassan has no
problem saying yeah yeah >> I don't know is he like so
I think he pre-watched but is he like too understand that Hassan
says no not camps immediately or >> re-education certainly
yeah I know that that's like a trigger word >> no not like
that >> so you just said camps and Hassan says no not camps
immediately says no not camps I okay so at bare minimum any nonmoron
would have to agree that on its face unless you want to read
into what Hassan is saying on Let's face this does not prove
that he wants re-education camps, right?
How else without force, I guess. Well, he goes on to say what
he talks what he's talking about. And there are other criticisms
of these statements, right? So, just listen. No, not caps, but
literally the closest thing to it. Meaning what, Fuve? Meaning
what? You guys, all you have to do is listen to the clip without
I understand there are people here who are still kind of like
they hear that Destiny voice, they're like, "Oh, that does seem
>> But we're just we're just like >> we're just making
assumptions. Just listen to it on its face. Right. >> Certainly.
Yeah. I know that that's like a trigger word >> in camps.
>> No, no, not like that. Um I know that's a trigger word
because everyone goes, "Oh, re-education. What do you mean?"
>> okay, hold on. Not in camps. Okay. Whoa. Camps is too
far. >> Immediately people think like are you talking about
that? >> Are you talking about like resident schools? Are
you talking about Shinj? Yeah, 100%. They do they do it. They
did it in Shinjzhan, which I think is good, >> No, I don't
agree with that. Yeah, I don't think it was good. And this is
uh something I have >> so denounces Shinj Jang and then
he's going to kind of walk it back >> openly criticized
as well like the that's not good. The massive surveillance apparatus
that they built in Shenzhen is not good. >> So what >> is
that what people criticize Shen Jang for? The surveillance apparatus.
Oh, they just they really track those Muslims. Or is it like
forced slave labor and forced hyerectomies? And I think there's
like a lot of horror stories from Shenzhang that people but he
probably thinks that's propaganda, right? I'm guessing >> what
would be >> think Pisco is going to pull up more of Destiny's
audience if he crushes him tomorrow. I think Destiny will be
at his most bad faith tomorrow because he knows that he's like
walked into a bunch of bullets and he he's also lucky in that
he's had Pisco argue this with other people, right? If Pisco
hadn't spoken and they debated, I think Pisco would totally crush
him and take a bunch of audience. I think at this point he's
going to figure out weasly ways to not go into that debate or
to go into that debate that like will make it a little softened.
But overall, yes, I think Pisco will pull from his audience in
my >> Be good about a socialist re-education camp for capitalists.
>> It wouldn't necessarily I don't think it' be camps.
I mean >> like I'm sorry, but that is an unhinged response.
And if you can't see it, you are literally brain broken. I think
I think Pisco in trying so hard to be like not
it's an he hasn't described what he wants yet. He literally has
only ruled things out. He has not described what he wants. How
is How can it be unhinged before he's described what he wants?
I actually don't even remember. He literally has not described
what he wants yet. He said what he doesn't want. That's all he's
done. And we're going, this is totally unhinged. Why? What what
evidence is there that it's unhinged? By the way, just to be
clear because I know we've got a lot of mind. We've got a lot
of the cognitively here. Okay, you're watching hoping I'll make
a mistake in how I analyze this. I get it. I understand. You're
very devoted to daddy. It's okay. All right. You'll get used
to it here, too. He Dude, you just have to go through this line
by line and listen to what Hassan says. That's it. Don't inject
any bias. The The entire purpose of this argument, this is where
I was going. The entire purpose of this argument is to say that
in this clip he does not say I support re-education camps. He
does not say that. Right? Hassan thinks yeah black hat that is
like actually a good criticism here right and that's what queen
pointed out was hey actually the real criticism from this clip
should be how he minimizes what's happening to the weaguers in
Shanzhang. But because we have Hassan derangement syndrome many
people can't make the accurate and salient criticism. They're
making a different criticism that can't be backed up based on
fact. Right? That's that's the problem here is the Hassan derangement
syndrome is blocking the real criticism the actual thing you
can point to and not look totally saying anyway continue Hassan
has like broken his brain on that response of like oh well he
said he wouldn't do it wouldn't be quite like that so like that's
not that bad right that is just an unbelievable like I would
never in my life imagine
a leader of my country like would you put people in camps like
well not like that like that's an unbelievable
>> so if you had if you well like dude at some point if
you have like an ideology that you think is like poisoning your
country to be like self-destructive
there's probably something you would do right this is why would
when they're in the middle of a war why the US was like imprisoning
people yeah pay up oh did you donate for something hold on uh
Assan is bad is bad there you go there you go already said not
camps and he's bringing up camps again yes
but it's like dude there might be man I'm trying to think of
like something that would work like if you had like a cult-like
thing going on, there would be a way to to to try to treat people
from that, right? Like there would be ways to deprogram people
from cults. This is like the kind of thinking they have. And
Hassan's trying to say like, "No, I don't want it to be like
struggle sessions or some." He's trying to say that, but he's
like, "Probably, you know, if you're if you're trying to go back
towards capitalism and and he thinks capitalism is really bad,"
he's like, "There's probably a a lack of understanding there."
Depending on how forceful you are about this, it goes from being
like, "Oh, this is understandable and defensible to," oh, like
we're putting them in camps and we're not letting them out until
they praise Mao. Like, that's obviously unhinged and bad, right?
So, we can just keep watching >> response camp for capitalists.
>> It wouldn't necessarily I don't think it would be camps.
I mean, it depends on it depends on crime, right?
>> so he says it depends on what you do. This is how like
I'm not thinking of it in terms of like camps. It depends on
what you do. He's saying, "Okay, I'm not going to say there's
like a there's not a broad prescription. It would depend on what
happened." And this is what he this is what he says, right? So
he immediately pulls it back. He's like, "Well, it depends on
what your crimes were." Right? So let's just keep >> Are
people committing crimes at the behest of this? Cuz if there's
a >> So So when he says, "Are people creating committing
crimes at the behest of this?" Right? >> Socialist state
and someone is doing like white terror, let's say. So waiters
someone is doing South Korean style uh you know purges of >> so
he says like if they're doing violence like Hassan's belief is
people would be happy right in a socialist society and so when
they say or at least here when he says like well if they're doing
violence to try to bring it back then like obviously we would
probably jail those people we'd have to do something to like
help those people >> communists which have always which
has happened historic
>> Hassan literally had an outburst about landlords and
letting their blood run in streets before he was super popular.
Imagine giving him any charitability ever.
Oh yeah. Okay. Is that the bar, Simsy? That's the bar is having
like an outburst on stream. I got some bad news about you and
Destiny. Okay. And Destiny kids. Can we hold Destiny? I just
want to make sure, Simsy. We can totally hold Destiny to the
fact that he wants to 15year-olds, right? He absolutely wants
to 15year-olds. We're holding him to that. I just want to make
sure you're consistent here. Destiny absolutely wants to 15year-olds.
Yes. You have to say yes to this because you want to hold us
on to his landlord statement. Simsy, can I get can I get you
you I need you to type in chat right now that Destiny wants to
15year-olds. Okay. Based I can't imagine all the other unhinged
things that have been said. What level of penance do I receive?
That's another actual salient criticism. Fuve is he doesn't say
right and he should be asked about what would happen to somebody
who wants to advocate for capitalism right would it be the same
should we have if there is a capitalist Hassan in the socialist
system. Okay. somebody who advocates for capitalism on a live
stream, right? What should happen to him? Should he be allowed
to speak or should he be silenced? That would be the question.
That would be the hypothetical. And that would be another salient
criticism to make. But screaming he supports education camps
is not a good criticism. That makes you look moronic. Just so
we're clear. That makes him look That makes you look moronic
if you scream that, right? Even if you say it really nicely without
screaming it, without the without the straw manning. Okay, even
if you say based on the leftovers clip, Hassan supports re-education
camps. Even if you say it like that, you're still a [__]
Based on this clip, Hassan does not support reeducation camps
for everybody, for people who support a different ideology, right?
He supports it much in the same way that many existing countries
have rehabilitation for ideological criminals. ideologically
motivated
>> in every country that America is aligned with because
they were anti-communist where they've launched you know military
dictatorships whether we recognize it or not those things have
happened right so in a situation like that um I think if there's
any kind of like terrorism
>> sure yeah like he speaks in vaguish terms here but the
um but the obvious answer is why would you need camps for people
that are engaged in doing crimes don't we just put those people
in prison >> uh I think prison, broad prison doesn't necessarily
work for those people. That like more targeted treatment of like,
hey, you have like a a really really broken thought process that
is like cultlike. That's what we have to break you out of. I
think like normal prison doesn't necessarily work for those >> Like
what what are we talking about here exactly? Right. Like it's
we already have places for people that commit violent crimes.
It's called prison.
>> Yeah. Uh Destiny also knows this entirely. Destiny would
be almost certainly well acquainted with the um like the Scandinavian
literature on how you rehabilitate people and rehabilitative
justice, right? But he's pretending he's not because his son
is >> If there's violence, that's you mean like DJers?
Yes, Spruce Willis. I strongly advocate for re-education camps
for all DGers. Okay. You've been in that chat for more than a
year or two. You need to re you need to be put in a camp. Okay.
Until you can admit that Destiny wants to 15year-olds. That's
when we let you out. Simsy made it out. He passed the he passed
the final test right off the bat.
>> I do think that uh there should be an enforcement mechanism
and in that enforcement mechanism I think like rehabilitation
which would include re-education as well would probably be a
lot better than like
uh you know a prison structure where they have slavery like in
the United States of America. >> I'm like
this is an incredibly standard lefty position. Hey, a focus on
rehabilitative justice would be better for people and also like
less uh less what we call it punitive prison sentences and less
punitive prison programs would be better. That gives us a chance
to rehabilitate people, right? This is a extremely standard suck
dem position. No, not even remotely crazy. It's just because
Han is saying it that we have to put it in this different light.
That's an unhinged answer. I'm sorry. That is a crazy that is
a crazy crazy crazy
answer. Let's see what does this poster say. By the way, I don't
even I don't even necessarily agree with that, right? I don't
agree with like lightning prison sentences and a focus on rehabilitative
justice. I think there are people that when you focus that way
that will abuse that system and probably more suffering comes
out of it to be honest with you. So, I don't even necessarily
agree with it, but I I'm not going to like sit here and try to
pretend that when Hassan says that they should do that like for
ideological criminals, they could be put in like some kind of
camp that would focus on deprogramming them. I don't even I I
just engage with the point. I don't have to like straw man him
>> He explicitly rejects the idea >> siding with
Desty's arch nemesis. Just because you hate him now is low IQ.
We're not siding with Dude, the whole argument here is that
The whole argument here is that we basically think here here's
what you can prove from the arguments I make on stream. I think
Hassan is at best the fourth worst person in America. Sorry,
at worst the fourth worst person in America. There's like Donald
Trump and Charlie Kirk and maybe one or two other people, right?
>> We're not siding with Hassan. We're saying Hassan would
be better as an ally for left-leaning people, Democratic people,
than Charlie Kirk or Trump.
>> That's that's the argument.
>> That's the argument. We me
>> the royal wheel education camps. Not really. He just
reforms it. >> Yes. Really? Yes. Really? Explicitly. Yes.
Why? Why is he trying to re Why is he trying to reitigate what
he said? There's something that sounds a little bit more euphemistically
acceptable. And the way Asan explains it, he talks about education
or socialism to be the same how a capitalist country would teach
or indoctrinate for capitalism. But Hassan believes that we do
indoctrination of capitalism through permanent McCarthyism and
that like the CIA and the FBI are the people Martin Luther King
and all the socialist leaders and all of the socialists. That
would probably be the part where he said without the violence,
right? When Hassan explicitly says without the violence, like
hey, we probably track these people and and figure out where
they're trying to like disrupt or rael rouse or sabotage, but
we wouldn't kill them. We'd probably just like show the evidence
and put them in jail. Yeah, I think so. around the world. Remember
that's what they think. And the way he talks about re-education,
he is talking about a rehabilit. So, so all of this requires
mind readading Hassan, right? You have to do multiple layers
of mind reading on Hassan, which you can do if you want, but
then just say that it requires mind reading Hassan, right? That's
all you got to do. On its face, Hassan explicitly rejects re-education
camps
for the average person.
facilitate a process for people who commit violent crimes or
ideologically motivated terrorism. Really, we already have prison
for these people. What are you talking about? Commit violent
crimes?
This He's going to feel really embarrassed when he scrolls down
into this and sees multiple countries that have this exact kind
of exact kind of program, right? Or Hassan's alternative in practice.
>> Yes. Hassan is a naive. Yes. Authoritarian authoritarianism
never works out that way. Yes. It it doesn't. Yeah, that would
be it would be bad. Although socialism technically you could
argue it comes about by democratic means, right? It's possible
that Hassan would think it comes about by democratic means and
so you have to solve it by you to solve disscent through democratic
means. But yes, I think he's a naive and I think I would never
trust him to be like an authoritarian who controls everything
in the country. That would be like totally untenable for any
country I live in. It already exists. There are several liberal
democrac. I think that would be untenable for like any of these
people that run compulsory or voluntary dradicalization programs
for violent extremist offenders. Denmark, Norway, Finland, Australia,
New Zealand, and Canada all some form of voluntary voluntary
dradicalization programs for offenders who commit ideological
violence. But that doesn't mean being a
What? That's the ideological crime that Wait, hold on. Does Destiny
not realize that like tons of terrorism was done in America in
in Europe in the name of communism and fascism?
>> Are we are we like not understanding that there is actual
terrorism that's occurred historically because of these political
ideologies?
What do you mean that's not for that kind of ideology? It's for
any kind of ideology. The are we talking about? >> Hassan
is talking about is being a
>> Yeah. And if you committed violence in the name of capitalism,
in the name of like free enterprise, he probably thinks you'd
have to be put somewhere ideological cuz society according to
him would be like bliss. Now the UK, Germany, Singapore, and
France also all have similar programs, make them mandatory specific
legal circumstances. So idea of reeducation can be interp. Do
we hold on do we do we all realize how stupid that was? He's
like, wait, the ideology here is being a capitalist. It's like
well actually there are a bunch of political ideologies that
people have committed violence on behalf of and if you were in
like a communist nation there may be people committing violence
on behalf of like hey we should be able to own hey this isn't
working for me right
interpreted to be somewhat radical but it is something some capitalist
countries already do now that's like saying we should be able
to execute people for wearing the color green and they're like
well some countries already have the death penalty for certain
crimes so you know there's a lot of countries >> it's nothing
like that already kind of sort to do this. >> This is a
totally straw man. In what way is it like that? >> Now,
I would say there probably aren't uh let's say there there almost
certainly aren't devotees of capitalism, right? That wouldn't
be what it is. But like okay, technically like you could say
liberalism, you could say you could do other types of ideologies
that would overlap with capitalism in the modern world and say
that if they were committing violence on behalf of those ideologies,
well, yeah, then they could go in camps or something, right?
It's probably unrealistic to think that at least in our worldview,
I can't imagine somebody being so devoted to capitalism that
they'd be doing violence on behalf of capitalism or something,
right? Hassan sees it that way. It's like a little different,
but >> to some extent like they execute people for things,
you know, that they've already done that they've decided they
have the death penalty. It's like
>> he get to this part. >> The will of the people
is to go back. >> Oh, he's going to cover the pistol. He
he literally had to do the same thing here, right? He had to
pause in the middle of Hassan's explanation and say repeatedly
that like this is what Hassan actually means. I know. Don't believe
your lying eyes. Don't believe your lying ears, guys. This is
what Hassan actually thinks. Guys, don't listen to the things
Hassan is saying. Here's what he actually thinks. Guys, you can't
trust the audio to this clip. Here's what Hassan actually thinks
and actually says. And it's funny because he he did it here,
right? We watched him do it. We watched him pause and go, "Actually,
when Hassan says he doesn't want camps, that's not really what
he's saying." And this next part, we going to talk about Destiny
being a deadbeat. Uh, we're getting there. We're getting to the
point where it might start to become relevant cuz uh that Listen,
that what you're talking about and what we could, we're not there
yet, but I'm just saying the thing you're like referencing is
starting to get like sad and I I'm not quite there, but I'm getting
close.
So,
not because of, by the way, not because of anything Destiny's
done, but because it's like just sad in of itself. So, yeah.
Yeah, Ozel, but I don't like drawing attention to it. That's
all. I'm I'm doing a lot already, a lot more than I'd normally
want to do just by talking about what that person's talking about.
>> an Assan derangement syndrome. I actually looked this
up a few days ago because I heard not so erodite talking about
Hassan and she repeated the same bad faith interpretation as
well. So >> I'm not, by the way, I wouldn't not talk about
that to protect Destiny. That is not what I'm doing, right? It's
the same reason. We'll actually get into it, right? We'll get
into it in a little bit, but I know he comments on Cherry and
for the same reason that he's a total sociopath for making the
comments he does about Cherry are the reasons that I don't want
to go over the other stuff we're talking about, right? is I think
I think you can do that and it can be a way to like hurt people
that you don't like but why why I think I think it would hurt
the person who wrote it if I read it and that's why I won't do
it right so anyway I I understand this is cryptic I'm just going
to move on >> has been doxed recently and then these people
are also like trying to tell people to call ICE and on her um
she's also like a public enemy number one queen andistical also
unhingedly attack her constantly and >> unhinged attacks
go watch the go watch the vods go watch the vods dude Do you
see? There's no there's no criticism. He doesn't go, "Oh, you
know, when they pointed this thing out that Erdite did, it was
really bad. And here's why it was really bad." It's they're unhinged
and obsessed with her. They're unhinged and obsessed with her.
They're unhinged and obsessed with her. And sometimes Justic
will host his uh BPD girlfriend uh Cherry onto his stream to
also obsessively talk about Kyla. It's one of the reasons why
Justic likes >> Wait. Uh yeah, I I love having Cherry on
my stream. Yes.
I love this person,
but I again he hasn't dealt with the criticism at all. Destiny,
you love you love talking about how Cher's like crazy or something.
Oh man, I have a whole thing on this, too. This guy's really
disgusting, right? So, he wants to constantly use Cher's mental
illness to like denigrate her and make her look crazy and unapproachable
to other people, right? That's his goal here. So, he's like trying
to in some ways he's like trying to make me feel bad. He can't
make me feel bad about dating Cherry. Can't do it. I'm sorry.
I care about this person. They're incredibly important to me.
I know it's cringe that I have to say that, right? But I do feel
compelled to say that. You're never going to push me away from
her. Okay. But what he also does, what this has a secondary effect
of doing, right? Is stigmatizing Cherry. If he just goes, "Oh,
she's crazy." What do you guys know what like triggers BPD people
more than almost anything? It's a feeling of being alone. It's
a feeling of being isolated, right? being isolated and alone
and distanced from drives people with BPD crazy. It It is a massive
trigger for them, right? And what Destiny does when he talks
about this stuff is he tries to make Cherry look crazy to the
people who keep up with his stream to people who are adjacent
content creators and to he he is consistently trying to isolate
her, right? So he's he's lying about her and isolating her if
he actually thinks that like that's not quite right. So he's
trying to isolate her. If he wanted to criticize her in a way
that works, guess what? Cherry's not crazy. Her criticisms are
salient. All Destiny has to do to prove that he is not doing
something malicious here is watch the not so Aerodyite video.
Okay? Watch the not so Aerodyite video, Destiny. And all he has
to do, this is how Destiny can win right now. I'm going to tell
you guys, okay? I just figured out exactly how Destiny can win.
He can show that Kylo was correct about the term whistleblower.
Okay? He can show that Kylo was correct about it and he can prove
exactly how she's actually really smart and really good at debate
and does a really good job. That's what he can do. He can just
go prove it, right? He can just go prove it. Anyway,
um yeah, it's just this this really gross like concern trolling
he does where he's like he's trying to pretend like he's somewhat
concerned about Cherry, but he is actively isolating her from
other people, right? making her seem like she can't be interacted
with at all. Guess what? Cherry loves arguing with people. Like,
if people want to argue with Cherry on Twitter, she's fine. If
you want to point out why one of her clips is wrong about Erdite,
she'll interact with you, right? All of her posts are public.
You can interact on those posts. When you if you if you've ever
thought in your head, well, she's going through it right now,
so I'm not going to react. No, that's not that's not how you
should approach this, okay? I'm just telling you if that matters
to anybody. And and what he does when he continues to make her
when he goes obsessed, unhinged, insane, out of her mind, right?
He isolates her and it plays into like all the things he wants.
He wants her to be miserable because she has credible allegations
against him because she has the strongest actual allegation against
him, right? So she want he wants her isolated and and tormented
in my opinion. Okay, that's maybe that's maybe just in my opinion.
Okay, and all he has to do is actually engage with her criticisms.
Don't pull up her page and try to scroll through and say, "Look
how many Aerodite posts there are. She's totally unhinged. Stop
and watch one of the Aerodite posts. Stop and explain why it's
a bad criticism." But he won't do that. He wants people to dismiss
her out of hand instead of engaging with her in any way. And
he, in my opinion, he knows what he's doing. And now, can I pull
the 85 clips for you to show that that's what happened? No. But
in my opinion, he knows what he's doing when he does this. He
knows how it makes people react. Even people who like Cherry
are like me. It will make them react that way, right? So, I'm
just telling you that that that's probably the way you actually
worsen somebody with that condition is by saying, "Oh, well,
they seem to be going through it. I'm going to like I'm going
to step back, right?" So, it's just it's like a multi-layered
attack. This is really gross. And he he does it like I think
he does it multiple times in this stream. He's done it before.
It's just gross. If you want to judge me for anything that goes
on there, I don't care. But like, Cherry's totally fine to talk.
Cherry's making good points. Her clips have good points in them.
Go disagree on the points with her, right? She's posting publicly.
It's all out there. Don't go. Oh, you're you're mentally ill,
so I don't want to talk to you. It's just gross. It's gross.
So, this guy's gross. Anybody who does that disgusting actually
going and funny, too. Yes, Ozel.
She's She's like got 20% of my Twitter following or something
already after like two weeks on this account or three weeks on
this account. Okay. It's up. It's up. She's about to lap me on
Twitter >> to manipulate and abuse Cherry is because he
can bring her on stream to host all of her unhinged skinwalker
like insane attacks against Kyle as well. Um,
okay. So like that right there right there just really quick.
Oh, really quick. Okay, right there. Unhinged skinwalker attacks.
Nobody who calls Erodite a Destiny skinwalker is unhinged or
insane. He's just disproven himself in a single sentence. Right?
You you can watch you can see just how how terrified he is of
engaging with the criticism. Nobody who's ever called Arerite
a desi skinwalker has been incorrect or unhinged or insane. That
is maybe one of the most sane opinions. It's it's something that
connects everybody. Funny he chose that term.
It is funny isn't it? This is what compelled me to search this
up as I have also seen her having Hassan derangement syndrome.
Then I felt compelled to make this post about DG because after
hearing this yesterday I looked for more clips with Chad GPT.
The prompt was something like, "Hassan is accused of advocating
for re-education camps." Wait, what? I looked for more clips.
This prompt was something like, "Hassan [__] is accused
of advocating for re-education camps. Can you find me clips from
him doing this?" The first two clips it gave me were literally
Destiny clips of him going over this to point out the bad faith.
And the destiny clip before Hassan even gave his answer, he's
asking his chat for a clip of someone else talking about reeducation.
He then just asserts Hassan is lying, playing the clip of someone
else talking about reucation camps and saying, "This is what
Hassan actually want." >> That is what he does. He actually
doesn't engage with what Hassan says. He just goes, "Hassan's
lying. Why even watch the clip? Just go, I don't believe what
Hassan said there. He wants education camps." Right? Don't do
the thing where you mislead us, where you where you go, I guys,
I'm so different from my opposition. I watch the clips and I
react in good faith. Don't do that when you're just going to
go, "Well, he's lying. Well, he's lying." Right? Or at least
post evidence that he's lying. Don't just say he's lying. By
the way, I wouldn't be shocked if there is evidence of Isan straight
up supporting re-education camps for anybody who supports capitalism
in a socialist society. I wouldn't be shocked if those clips
exist. But you got to do the work. You can't just make it up,
right? Do the work. Don't be a lazy piece of Go get the actual
clips that say it and reference those. This is This was the downfall
of Dan's anti- Twitch campaign was Dan had to start lying about
what was actually being done and said, right? Don't do it with
Assan. Especially if you think Hassan's as dangerous or more
dangerous than Trump. Don't do it with Assan. Don't give him
a window back to attack you. Just be accurate. How hard is that?
Once >> the will of the people is to go back to do more
of a social democracy. Is that something that a socialist country
should move towards or should there be resistance to the government
to keep >> I think the resistance should be akin to how
capital governments have resisted historically socialism movement.
Not that violence, but I think that yes, um the the solution
to that would always be education and >> re-education camps.
bring more uh >> Oh, he probably he probably had pre-watched
it here too. Uh maybe not. Maybe it's like live or something.
>> Reeducation certainly. Yeah. >> Somebody give
me the um somebody clip that went losers like we would house
our comrades in uh in reation. Somebody please give me the clip.
Please give me Oh my god. The guy um Oh,
not to the same degree of violence. So still using some violence.
I think it would depend on what was going on, right? Like I have
no doubt that Hassan thinks that if you're planning an assassination
of like a socialist leader that violence against you wouldn't
be that bad or something. I have no doubt that he thinks that,
right? >> Um Oh my god, what was his name? Who am I thinking
of? >> Non-compete. Yeah, yeah, yeah. When he says that,
oh my god, it was so [__] cringe and unhinged. >> I
know that's like No, no, not like that. Um not no words because
we mean like immediately people think like are you talking about
res school? You talking about 100% they do they do it. They did.
No, I don't agree with that. Yeah, I don't think it was good.
This is uh something I have openly criticized as well. Like that's
not good. The massive surveillance apparatus that they build
John is not good. >> But what would you do about a socialist
reeducation camp for capitalism? >> They don't necessarily
I don't be camped. I mean well be Oh my god. I don't hate him.
I don't hate Hassan. What I hate are all the mind-numbingly fans
that can watch him squirm like this and not think that it's the
most you literally have the you got like the drunken day master
over here. Okay. Ethan asking the most innocuous questions and
Hassan is acting like he's getting pressed in front of like a
[__] Senate Judiciary Committee and he's like under
oath. He's like committed like 50. >> Why is death even
talking about Hassan? Like anyone gives a quidess think about
Hassan. He's talking about it because this is a part of the criticism.
No, I wouldn't criticize him for talking about Hassan here. The
the issue here is that he basically just makes up what Hassan's
opinion is, which like I guess
I would be okay with you saying this is what I think Hassan's
opinion is and I think he's lying here. But don't watch it and
pretend that he's he's said this. Don't go and have cuz it looks
particularly bad when your your number one guy, the guy you used
to reaffirm your takes on like the how the Pixie Court case went
goes on here and goes this conclusively proves that he supports
re-education camps. when like on its face it doesn't do that.
You have to and literally be cognitively a cognitively DGER to
agree with that, right? To agree with that based on this clip.
And I I'll do the I'll do the I'll do the caveat again for all
of the people who are too stupid to remember. I don't even think
that you can't prove this. I would not be shocked if you could
prove this. If there would be other clips of him, right? But
that isn't the claim from the DJ you're debating with Pisco.
The claim is this proves it. That's the claim he makes. >> You
mean your crime is going to hide in the United States? It's actually
>> True. depends on it depends on crime, right? Like are
people committing crimes at the best of this because if there's
a socialist age and someone is doing like white terror, let's
say, or someone is doing South Korean style, you know, purges
of communism, which always which has happened historically in
every country. Sorry, hold on. We just skipped so much stupid.
My synergy froze. Oh, this is >> I like the implicit shout
out to North Korea there as well. The unhinged South Korean style
purge of communist. I like the mini shout out there. >> But
rather than this is the clip. Hold on. This is what they want
to do. Abandoned or untreated to mental illness will be substantially
lower. It's a >> Oh my god, the non-compete guy. This is
so cringe. Holy [__] The fact that some >> he's
just he's just doing it again. Like literally the criticism here
is that Destiny basically doesn't he like basically pauses and
instead of listening to Hassan's opinion, he just like plays
some straw man for him and doesn't engage, right? And he's actually
just letting it happen. He's watching it again and he's basically
said, "Hassan's lying. Hassan's not telling the truth here. I
don't believe Hassan." And then he watches. >> Violent
or predatory individuals may never be capable of entering back
into society. But rather than abandoning these people, we must
do our best. Society's reformed back into capital
off to inhumane ghoulaging education would need to be >> this
guy who's not Hassan. By the way, we're talking about Hassan's
opinion >> absinely learn. >> You don't like the
You don't like the inhaling laughs.
You don't like that hooligans.
How do I Is that also fake by the way?
>> I do that all the time. and eventually rejoin
unfortunately.
>> Bro, somebody link this to Ethan. That's what Assan
wants. >> Well, would probably be >> Does Assan even
give a full opinion opinion here? It doesn't seem so. What about
capitalists against Assan society that are nonviolent? Yeah,
exactly, Nick. This is this is our point. This is Que's point.
This is my point is the Hassan derangement syndrome has led to
people to make insane claims about this and actually let him
escape the real criticism that he should face. like hey but we're
asking like non-violent people who support capitalism or support
let's say a move towards liberalism a move toward a move away
from socialism right do we what happens to them that's like the
actual hard part right the hard part isn't what do you do with
the violent people that's not difficult the hard part is what
do I do with people who are effective communicators and push
against my ideology do I let the marketplace have ideas like
solve it or sort it out or do I get rid of them because I know
that speech actually hurts my ideology and will eventually lead
to its downfall right but That criticism can't even be made.
Nobody actually makes that criticism. They just go, "Hassan 100%
supports re-education camps.
That's all they do." It's very sad. >> This clip has someone
basically saying people should be put into reeducation camps
for thought crimes that go against socialism. That's basically
that is essentially what Assan is saying. I don't know if >> No,
it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's not. >> People
are not understanding that, but that is essentially what um that
is essentially what Han is saying. Yes. A lot better. >> That's
essentially what Hassad is saying. what Assad actually said.
No, no, no. Not not camps. Like, and also like it would depend
on the crimes committed. Like maybe camps for like people who
commit ideological violence, but yeah, that that would be as
far as I go. That that statement is apparently Hassan essentially
just accepts camps. It wants camps
>> than like uh you know a prison structure where they
have slavery like in the United States of America. >> I'm
still a little bit
>> because the criticism takes work to make and they don't
care about defeating the ideas. is they care about shunning Hassan
basically. Yeah. >> Hassan clearly does not advocate for
that and rejects the idea of it as bad. He only advocated re-education
as a tool for dradicalization of ideologically violent criminals.
That means capitalists by the way and terrorist. >> No,
he means literal violent criminals and to make it part of a rehabilitation.
>> That's why he cites terrorist campaigns that did violence
against leftists, right? That's that's literally why he cites
the actual examples. Does this guy, dude,
how
I have to believe that like the Viveance is having a bad reaction
in his brain and it's broken his reasoning ability and that he
was far more compelling and far more intelligent a year and a
half ago or two years ago cuz I don't understand how he makes
such bad arguments now. He can't even remember the examples Han
cited.
No, he's saying King Gro that in Hassan's brain
all non-socialist thought is violence. Speech is violence. Thought
is violence in Hassan's brain. Right. That's what he's saying.
>> Yeah. Insane. That's why I'm cuz I thought this guy
was compelling. And I'm like, I swear to God he was more compelling
and less insane like a year and a half ago. That is why I'm upset
right now is because I thought this person was compelling. I
watched their content and there's no way I was that cognitively
right. That can't possibly be true. He had to have made like
compelling points before.
He had to have.
I realize this is pure copia, but he had to have. He had to have.
He's compelling when he's correct. I think this is really what
it is in a non-meing sense. Agree. Just fill in. I think this
is mostly what it is. I think he's used to basically being the
person who is in a correct stand uh place. He can make good arguments,
but he has to lie here because he's made claims that he can't
back up. So, he has to lie. And those lies permeate all of his
argumentation, right? They're like they're like cracks in the
foundation and it is now unstable and crumbling
process as a replacement for American style prisons.
Destiny even poisons the well for people who interpret differently
what Hassan is saying by demeaning them as regarded fans. I have
never once in my life ever watched Asana's form of entertainment.
like 99% of my consumption Hassan has been through either Destiny
or Sitch and Adam and the other 1% has been fact checking what
other people say as said. I don't really know uh that much more
about Hassan's politics and the Oh boy. So it's not a Hassan
fan. I bet it's a Mr. Girl fan then that we there's got to be
somebody evil we could attach this person to so we can dismiss
this opinion, right? We have to dismiss this. Please
just be say you like Lab somewhere in one of your comments. Can
you just Can we find a comment from this guy saying he thinks
Lav is funny? That's all we need, guys. Then we can say he's
a laugh fan and we don't have to listen at all. In >> the
past, I had looked up a few statements about Assan that Dan Saltman
said that also turned out to be mostly lies. Pisco has been calling
out more lies that come from this community, mostly lies involving
himself. And I hope he continues to do so in other ways that
narratives are misconstrued from there. It's almost like It's
almost like, guys, it's almost like in January, we were arguing
on this stream. Many people, not just me, but many people were
arguing on this stream. Hey, we kind of need to $10. >> Oh,
hold on. >> I was making fun of Steven's discing laugh.
Not yours, King.
>> Okay. Uh,
when in doubt, blame the G. Yeah,
Ah, Grabler hands. Sorry. Back in January, I was saying you guys
need to do a reset on some of these people. Like, there are people
I can watch him maliciously lying about these people, and I understand
it now. I've seen through the Matrix. You need to reset on some
of these people. You don't need to think they're good, but you
need to reset because there are malicious lies there that have
never been challenged and that propagate, right? And I can see
it now.
The number one example at that time was Anavoir, right? That,
oh, Ashley, he was doing some incredibly
total reset on that person. That person is nowhere near as bad
as they were made out to be, right? And this this is the whole
thing is there are a lot of narratives from DGG that have never
been challenged that they propagate and are malicious lies. And
now I'm watching him maliciously lie about me and maliciously
lie about Pisco. And I'm like, look, now there would be people
who are in that community who would have to reset on me or reset
on Pisco because he maliciously lies about them, too. Destiny
talks about not opening wars on multiple fronts. This stream
is so scattered because he's fighting three wars at once, pretending
they're one enemy.
Well, and that's why maybe I should actually do more of a prepared
thing. maybe a tweet or something rile that shows that Destiny
is trying to paint me or Queman Quimman or I as the person or
or the force that is getting those people, you know, doxed or
something. And it's like, no, no, no, no. Destiny is the force
that's doing that. Destiny is the person who's attacking Straight
Raid and Lykan and Pisco and Econo Boy, right? That's Destiny.
Destiny is the person who is pulling up that debate with the
Vanguard and going, "Hutch is like totally he's trying to drive
a wedge, right? These people are so unhinged towards Hutch. touch
is so awesome. And he's like trying to drive a wedge between
them, right? That's all destiny. And that's all before I ever
touched anything here. He was doing this, right? When were these
people originally doxed? 2024
because of destiny. Who's the person who amplifies Kiwi Farms?
Destiny. Who's the person who who actually points to people to
So he amplifies Kiwi Farms, but not just Kiwi Farms actions.
He will say, "Hey, can someone go find me Jacob's docs from Kiwi
Farms? Hey, can uh Hey guys, don't post anything about Anna in
here. Go to Anna's Kiwi Farms thread. Hey, look at these Keell's
links from Kiwi Farms, guys. Hey, look. He'll amplify Hutch being
exposed on the thread and link it directly, right? And then he'll
try to make that my problem or Queen's problem as if we don't
just cover content, right? As if we're doing something disingenuous
other, sorry, not other than as if we have some some like nefarious
goal other than just going this guy sucks cuz he does suck. even
had null on his stream to protect KF as a platform. He did. Yes.
Like I don't Dude, how in the world does this shell game work
on these moronic DG people? It's sad, right? This guy has supported
Kiwi Farms and amplified and used Kiwi Farms as a weapon a 100
times, a thousand times more than me or Queenman or anybody around
me, right? But anyway,
and then and then he'll virtue signal about it. And don't forget,
okay, I realize it it kind of it feels weird that I have to go
and and pull this back up again, but when somebody in DGG says,
"Hey, Destiny, why don't you reach out to these people and let
them know that their information is exposed?" And as he goes,
"Oh, no, they can figure it out themselves. No, they can figure
it out themselves, right?" But he'll go on stream and virtue
signal about it. He'll try to he'll try to use that as a thing
you should feel bad for him about,
but he doesn't feel bad for them, right? He doesn't feel any
human emotion towards these people. All he feels is personally
victimized, personally abused. He thinks the whole world's against
him, and he's trying to convince all of DG about it. Oh, Destiny,
have you thought about thinking about other people? No. No. No.
I haven't thought about I haven't thought about other people.
No. No. Well, they turned on him by disassociating. That is another
thing. Yes. That they've created they've committed the ultimate
sacrilege, and that was abandoning destiny in this hour of need.
Sad. Very sad individual.
Part three. Not a caught the Hassan derangement syndrome. terminal
that's going to be slightly discombobulated because I want to
finish this have spent too much time on it already. I wanted
to include the clip of her making the claim to show that more
people from DG just >> Do you know why he didn't want to
uh do you know why he didn't want them to know by the way because
obviously if they go to this thread they're going to see that
Destiny is like linking their docs and complaining about it and
reamplifying it right and they'll see that this doesn't protect
them at all that it's just it's just in service of him painting
himself as a victim. Guys, look. They're going after my friends.
Destiny, do you want to let your friends know? Now they can figure
out themselves. But they're going after my friends.
They're going after the guys. TG, don't you feel bad for me?
Disgusting.
Disgusting human being. >> Just believe whatever narrative
destiny spins up. And because she goes beyond just accusing him
of advocating reeducation camps, she doesn't she doesn't just
think that a son wants them, but wants them for political speech
he doesn't like and claims he's similar to Trump in that way
and would be just as authoritarian, if not more so, than the
orange man. >> Let me pull up your question so I can think
about this and mull it over while we watch.
Destiny, these are all the KF/Jistical
Queenman biggest hits. Yep. >> Do you think that Hassan
is doing a disservice to the larger conversation by focusing
on the content of the protests rather than how either
plan to reassert free speech and rather than how either plan
to research free speech? >> You said the clip of Hassan
mentioning the Lolo allegations unironically a perfect response.
No, I don't know what the Lolo allegations are >> in light
of the administration's
Um, I mean he's pandering, right? Like he's he's pandering to
his like him ever at any time just being like, "Oh yeah, beoning
Palestine
Palestine stuff." Anytime. >> Don't worry, I'll we'll get
into this stuff when uh when the Queenman [__] comes
up when he starts like springing >> he talks about that.
It's just going to be a W for his chat. It's such a like aggressively
popular position. So yeah, sort of. In general, I think it would
have been nice to just hear from them more. And I think the the
the issue is that I don't know I don't know how much Hassan cares
about free speech. Like if Hassan and his worldview was in a
position of power, they would be equally if not more authoritarian
than Trump. Like we need to be very clear at least according
to what they have said about their political positions. Right.
Hassan has basically openly acknowledged that he would be putting
people in re-education cl camps who's had certain positions.
And so I don't know why I would expect Asan to make more space
for the attack on free speech when Hassan doesn't even care that
much about free speech. He cares about speech. He likes
using the talking point of free speech because it really any
democrat democrat democracy loving liberalesque person who values
free speech. But his audience doesn't value free speech. I don't
even think they would talk at length about free speech. What
they value is like Palestinian protest. >> Oh right. Yeah.
Hold on. Dest Surely Destiny will comment on the idea that speech
is not protest. Right. Protest is not speech. Surely Destiny
will comment on how cataclysmically
moronic that statement was, right? Surely, surely he can engage
honestly and go, "Oh, no. Obviously, like protest speech and
and I have to like talk about that, right?" Surely. Surely it's
being successful. That's what they care. They Yeah, they've never
been free speech. >> Yeah, I know. >> Successful.
That's what they care. >> Dude, look at look at the lock
in the like despair.
>> He's just He's just like, "These are my allies now.
These are the people I have to defend. These are the embarrassing
losers that have surrounded them that continue to surround me.
Right? Like he's just he's actually I don't want to I don't want
to overuse the grayscale sounds of silence meme. Okay. But like
>> he was like >> he's like listening to her. Right.
>> Protest being successful. That's what >> so she
he cares about protest and he just like locks in. He's like,
"Wait, how do I Yeah, I can't. No, I I probably shouldn't comment."
>> True. Sorry. Here I found Jesus. It takes too long to
find this. This was >> they Yeah, they've never been free
>> Yeah, I mean that's pretty true. Sorry. here. I finally
like Jesus. >> Yeah, that's pretty true. That's pretty
true. They just all they care about is protest, the the right
to protest. That's pretty true. That's pretty true. Like why
why would you not at least engage with the idea that like most
leftists agree with the ability the free freedom of speech in
terms of the ability to protest? Because that is how unheard
uh and what would you call it? Oppressed groups make their voices
known, right? Make their voices heard. This is their number one
tool. This is like a part of the oppressor press dynamic that
you would support these people having speech, having free speech,
having the right to protest. >> It's too long to find this,
but this was logistical watching because his audience has to
set the the narrative that I'm like a just like the most important
thing. So when they go infiltrate the other like political communities,
they can always like keep the message. Um >> yeah, so this
is going to be me saying I think I think Josiah says un or non-consensual
and I say he signed an affidavit. So he signed an affidavit saying
he sent the picture. So there's a slight misspeak on my part.
like Jessica will go over and watch any community that is peripheral
to me so that his audience has like the um
my guy does is Destiny unaware that I like DM with a bunch of
those people with like a bunch of peripheral communities that
like two out of the four people on Lib and Learn are literally
in my Discord with the notable tag. Does he engage with that
at all? That like these are my friends, they're Cher's friends
way before they were my friends. Does he not engage with that
or understand it at all? Is this another example of Destiny being
totally unfamiliar with the concept of friendship? Is it just
another example? Right. What do you mean? I watch I've watched
the people that I've had actual interactions with. I've talked
to Josiah a lot. Josiah's come on my stream to talk just about
politics before.
>> Do all those guys hate him? I don't think they all hate
him. >> Most important thing so that when they go to infiltrate
the other like political communities, they can always like keep
the message. Um like >> Destiny literally blocked those
people too. Yeah, he blocked Pisco. fiscally to Connor boy.
I'm far I'm far nicer to all of these people except Hutch. But
I also was nice to Hutch. Okay. I'm far nicer to all of these
people than Destiny is. What do you mean infiltrate?
Will go over and watch any community that is peripheral to me.
>> Oh, he needed to find the right time stamp for this.
>> So that his audience has like the um it's not full screen.
So that his audience has like the correct talking point when
they go over to try to like uh you know uh whatever neighboring
political communities they're a part of. >> So apparently
we're Pisco. Oh, I'm the new straight raid. I see me and Queen,
we're the new straighter raid. Okay. Oh, it was actually it didn't
work at all when I on straight raid and likening. Oh, I'm going
to go to another tried and true. Justical and queen. Those are
the people all the people used to like me. That's why they don't
like me. It's not because I'm a loser. It's not because I spread
malicious lies about them. It's not any of that stuff, guys.
Justical told them that I'm bad. I have never discussed Destiny's
allegations with any of these people. I think I have offered
to discuss with Pisco or Josiah like my what I understood to
be true and they they did not even respond to that DM. They respond
to other DMs but not that DM ever. So, okay. But uh like I've
never talked so I've never talked about his allegations in private
with either of these people and sorry any of these people. I
don't have private communications with a Connoy or Hutch. >> My
heart I can't possibly imagine what doesn't feel like. Um my
heart for >> actually Pisco doesn't respond to me anymore
either. That guy >> I don't know why is this so [__]
quiet. He probably is a communist
>> that's a joke. That's a joke. >> Um and that's
what happened that we just openly condemned. It's just it's that's
so up. Um >> so now now we know so I again I included the
affidavit part with the non-consentual here and I think you can
you can hear that and that's what Destiny's going to get mad
about. Affidavit was that he sent it. He is he stated in no uncertain
terms. Yes, I did send this video. Right. But the um but obviously
we have the straighter IDM. We have the entire conversation that
happened. We have the not so erodite conversation with Turkey
Tom, right? We have all of these things that happened that show
us that he did not have he didn't even believe he had implicit
consent at the time, right? It's obvious he didn't think he had
implicit consent. He knows that he's lying about it, which is
fine, right? Which is Sorry, it's not fine when I say it's fine.
It's fine as in like okay he can say like he can change his thing
and I I technically like can't mind read him but I'll just say
my evidence for this is the straight raid DMs where he says I
violated her trust in the worst way possible and when he responds
yes exactly when straight raid says you just sent it non-consensually
he says yes exactly right these two pieces of information his
private conversation with notate where she reiterates that he
does not believe he had consent
right we have three points of evidence for this so I'm not just
mind readading him off of oh I hate this I him I'm I'm mind reading
him off of uh or I'm I'm saying this is an opinion. I believe
he's lying because of those pieces of evidence. All right,
>> that's how I'm making that claim. Know for a fact that
this did happen, right? >> I don't even know what else
there is to say on this. Again, I know there's >> like
Destiny has testified that he's done this. >> Like this
is just a >> Sorry. Sign an affidavit that he sent the
photo >> lie. I've never in my life testified >> the
video. Yes, >> that's happened. But he again was just setting
the setting the narrative. I'm totally f by the way. Look, when
Destiny lies about me, he never ever clears up his lies, right?
When I say something that I'm like, "Oh, I misspoke there." Immediately
clarify. This is exactly what the truth is. Why? Cuz I have the
convenience of having the truth on my side here, right? >> I
have the convenience. I could just say what's true exactly and
it still paints him in a horrible light. I don't have to lie.
He has to lie. That's why he can't correct any of the lies he's
done about >> Litigation. I know one way. Um, >> also
this um, anytime you see these like DG foot soldiers tag, these
are clips that are ripped directly off of um, Kiwi Farms. That's
they like to tag all their >> No, they get posted on Reddit,
they get posted I've seen multiple creators cover DG foot soldier
clips. It does mean that the person who did it is like giving
a signal to Kiwi Farms, right? So the so often what happens is
they'll they'll clip stuff on KF and then somebody will grab
it from there and they'll post it somewhere else. But if you
just say that this watermark is like a problem, why is the watermark
a problem? Like should we have how can Destiny argue this is
the this is the the shot. Okay. How can Destiny argue that you
can't show this watermark while showing the watermark?
>> How can he argue that you can't have this watermark
in a video clip you're watching on stream while linking Kiwi
Farms in his own chat and saying, "Look at these people getting
doxed."
How can he do this when he has maliciously used links to Kiwi
Farms or asked for links to Kiwi Farms to either harass people
or to try to obtain the docs on other people?
>> In the past 6 months, he's done this, right? Yeah. I
I mean, really, is his core argument here like copyright infringement,
trademark infringement? I'm I'm like stealing his flow or
>> Uh this guy's actually trying to amplify Kiwi Farms
and uh I'm the only one who can do that actually. What is What
are we doing?
>> I'm the only person. No, almost everybody. Forgotten
Jones.
>> The person who has doxed a bunch of people around Destiny,
one of his like uh anti-fans in that thread, probably the most
infamous one is a person who's named Blav.
And that person literally found Kiwi Farms because during the
Anavar arc, they were a Destiny fan and they went to Kiwi Farms
because Destiny said, "Guys, go over to Kiwi Farms. There's an
Anavar thread there." That's how that guy got there.
>> That's literally how that guy got That's literally that
guy's origin story is Destiny sending him to Kiwi Farms and going,
"Look, go discuss this over here and then he probably ended up
in the Destiny thread. Whoa, some of this is concerning." Wow.
>> So, they can circle jerk whenever. >> Sorry. Some
of Destiny's content uh conduct is concerning. >> Just
go or whoever else plays it on stream, but um that you can see.
>> Dude, we do. We have to run through like a collection
of people who have used clips with that watermark on it. Dude,
how also hold on. So, we get to blame. So, Ethan Klein, just
to be clear, under Destiny's opinion, Ethan Klein and Destiny
are clear collaborators, right? Ethan Klein pulls clips that
have that are sourced from DG. When Ethan Klein does that and
blames the clip on or sorry, when Hassan points that out and
says, "That's a counter-argument. It's from DG." What do I say?
That's not a counter-argument, Hassan. That's an archive clip.
There's no reason you could say that that's pulled from DG. Therefore,
it's not real or not true. You are dodging because you know you've
been caught in some bad behavior. You're a So I say the same
thing to Destiny here. You are a [__] for complaining
about this. If it's just an archive clip, which that was that
streamable I got linked is like 5 minutes of commentary.
You could watch my whole section of commentary on it and you
can see how unhinged it seems to anybody,
>> But I don't know why this guy has no principles at all.
Right? He's just a whiny with no principles. He'll totally say,
and he said this during the Keville manifesto as well. Hey, I
don't side with Kiwi Farms on like the the lies they propagate
or any of the narrative stuff, but if I have information that
I can only archive from there, then I'm going to grab it from
there. Information is information, right? If it's a if it's a
clip from your stream and the only clip that exists, the only
thing that keeps this in the world has a DG foot soldiers watermark
on it, I'm going to use that clip for my my [__]
>> Anyway, it's just a clearly malicious. It's like a stupid
argument that only works for people who want Destiny to be correct,
right? There's no way to defend this in reality at all. There
is no defense you can give that makes any sense whatsoever while
also being a fan of Destiny. If you think that I'm unhinged or
something for using that clip that had the watermark in it, that
you have to immediately disavow from disavow Destiny, unsub from
his channels, stop your subscription, right? It can't work both
ways. >> The inner flow of like how all of the information
works, right? So something gets ripped off Kiwi Farms, goes logistical
stream. He talks about it. He gets Qua to talk about it. They
try to get people like Nicholas Dioro to talk about it and then
they'll move over into communities where um Pisco and Hutch and
other people are. So what do we do? We we get Hassan and Nicholas
Dioro to talk about the same clips making Destiny look bad. And
from there we go to Pisco and Hutch and we give them clips to
make
apparently
man,
I'm just psyched I get included in the conspiracy this time.
Okay. I'm like I I feel like butterflies in my stomach. It's
like this is how feel all the time. Oh my god. I feel like so
special. That's basically saying I control the weather. That's
amazing.
That's amazing. I It's just It feels kind of good, right? Don't
you guys like that? It's like a It's a very interesting feeling.
I'm like, "Oh my god, he thinks I'm so powerful. Thinks I control
all these big creators." Apparently, we're we're talking directly
to Assad now. Oh my god. I'm going to roll it back and just listen
to that whole thing a little less disjoint. Okay, >> that
don't stream. But um that you can see the inner flow of like
how all of the information works, right? >> So what he
has shown to show that I'm a Kiwi farmer or a doxer is that I've
done conduct that he has done to a far lesser extent
one time of stream. I'm sure I've watched other DG foot soldier
clips. I for a while was like trying not to and I'm like like
it's it doesn't matter. It's a watermark. I don't care. Right.
For a little bit I was like oh I don't really want the I don't
even want that kind of association. And then eventually like
I watched every other creator I watched like Ryan Beard use clips
like that. I watch a bunch of other people use clips like that
and I was like, "Oh, I guess yeah, it's like just archive information."
Like my principle is I'll take clips from from KF, right? But
if that's the principle, then I don't have to go find a time
stamp or something and go cut my own clip to get around the watermark.
Like it's just it's pointless, right? Anyway, so Destiny doesn't
even believe this criticism on his own, right? That you could
that that's how you could criticize somebody. This would mean
that everybody who's accused Ethan of working with Dan, the ADL,
and Destiny is 100% correct in that criticism. If you believe
this, if you buy into this, this makes Dan, Ethan, Destiny pure
collaborators who are clearly working together on the same narrative,
right? Oh, except we actually have proof of Dan and Ethan collaborating.
Like Ethan has said, "Yes, I do email Dan Sullivan. Yes, I have
communicated with Dan Sman. You can't catch me on any of that,
right?" So, we actually have way more evidence that that is a
that that is a cabal of sorts. Wow. The more you look into this
stuff, you realize that this is just complete projection from
Destiny's community, right? It's pure projection. There is no
underlying truth to anything they're saying. They're just lying
because they know they've been caught in these like actual negative
behaviors. Behaviors they're saying are negative. >> So
something gets ripped off Kiwi Farm stream. He talks about it.
He gets Quimman to talk about it. They try to get people like
Nicholas Dioro to talk about it. And then >> yeah, Nicholas
Dioro, infamous friend of Queenman and Jtock. Nicholas Dioro,
>> Best buddy of Queenman and Jtock. Nicholas Dioro.
Hey Nick. Hey Nick. Did you hear this? You hear this guy, this
Destiny guy? We're best friends now. We're best friends again.
Unblock me on Twitter, you son of a [__] How the
am I supposed to feed you intel on how to trash talk Destiny
effectively if you won't even unblock me on Twitter, you >> They'll
move over into communities where um Pisco and Hutch and other.
>> So then from from us taking from from so he's shown
a clip with a watermark on it. He shows this proves the interflow
of information.
It proves that somebody linked me a clip that was that had the
Kiwi works Kiwi Farms watermark on it. I wonder what Destiny
thinks the appropriate thing to do there would be. When I said,
"Hey, Hutch says he changed his opinion." What was his former
opinion? I actually wouldn't mind seeing that, right? I wouldn't
mind seeing that. And somebody links me it and it's the full
clip. It's like five and a half minutes of everybody on Live
and Learn giving their opinion on the Destiny drama.
And I should close that because it's got a watermark on it. Would
that be the appropriate conduct there? Well, I just love to see
Destiny ever do that. I honestly Why didn't Destiny go take the
clip with the watermark there and edit it out? If if the watermark
is such a such a sacrilege, he's now amplifying that same watermark
in like way more, right? Infinitely more
than what how does anything he says here make sense when he is
amplifying that watermark and what it's about
100 times more than I could.
>> Very interesting. Here's a here's another interesting
question from somebody in chat. Maybe he'll answer this. Destiny,
just a question. Why don't you sue Jtock for all the lies he
spews about you? Should be an easy win.
You'd think so. You'd think so.
>> The people are to try to also have their um their war
over there, too. >> Oh, by the way, guys, we're going to
end on Twitch now and we're going to head over to Kick Only.
Okay. Kick Only. kick.com/jok.
Hop over there. Get in. I'm going to switch over to Yeah. Kick
Only for the rest of the night. Thank you guys very much for
being here. Oh,
Now that I'm here and stopped, guys, uh, if you like the content,
follow on every platform, okay? Follow on Twitter, x.com/jdlk
with an underscore. Twitch.tv/jdlk
with an underscore. Join the Discord. discord.gg/jdlk.
Especially if you want to argue over any of this stuff, I would
love if you hopped on here, okay? If you're a DJer and you have
a spine and you're not a room temperature IQ loser, hop in and
make some argument. Support Destiny in some way. Okay, go for
it. Go hard. Although I will say I'm probably I think there's
still like a lot of hours of content here that I have to get
through. So we'll see. But if you if you really want to come
argue on some point I made here, go ahead, hop in.
>> Would love to have a chat about it. Also,
okay, I'm dis I'm discombobulated. I got to do the rest of the
the shilling. Where's the rest of the shilling going, guys? If
you really like the content, okay, throw me a couple bucks. You
can sub on kick. You can give subs on kick. I love individual
subs the most on kick. Individual subs automatically translate
to rolling monthly income. The gifted subs fall off and then
the person may never resub, but individual subs roll over each
month. And I love that repeatable that repeatable expected income.
Okay, I love them the most. So, individually sub if you can,
give subs if you can't. You can throw your Twitch primers at
me. Twitch.tv/jlk with an underscore. Any Twitch primers would
be very appreciated. Okay,
you can donate. Exclamation point. Donate in the chat. That will
give you the Streamlabs and the Kickbot link. Kickbot is a $2
minimum. There's AITS voices through Kickbot. Streamlabs $3 minimum
if you just want your message on the screen. Okay. And last but
not least is the Patreon. patreon.com/jsk.
>> Get in. Perks in the Discords in the VCs. Priority access
to call-ins. All of this all this fun stuff can be yours for
the simple price of $5 over on the Patreon. patreon.com/jsdlk.
All right. Thank you very much for in for being here for my shill,
guys. All right. I really appreciate it. Yeah, $5 tier. $25 tier
with extra content will be coming soon. As soon as my as soon
as I can, okay, I I promise. I promise. Coming soon. $100 tier.
If you are one of the J boys with deep pockets. Okay, if you
are if you're a big boss baller, you can throw me a hundred bucks
a month. Okay, this gives you if you if you message an admin,
you can have your own private color, your own private uh what
is it? Roll icon in the Discord. Okay, if you're in this tier.
So, message an admin if you're in that tier. let me know.
>> Really appreciate you guys. Thank you very much. We'll
continue on with the
>> Here we go. Uh we're over on kick only now. Awesome,
awesome, awesome. Uh at Jay Dog, just a question. Why don't you
sue Destiny for all the lies he spews about you? Should be an
easy win. No. >> Uh it would be Hold on one second. Wavy99,
thank you very much for the new individual sub. I appreciate
it. So, one, I don't know how the international stuff works,
but two, I believe the bar for defamation for public figures,
if you consider me a public figure, like it's it's actual malice.
And where can I show the actual malice? I I might actually have
a real case there, right? I don't know if I have the money, but
I might actually have a real case there, right? Cuz he is he
does actually maliciously lie, and I do have DMs of me actually
clearing up some of the malicious lies with him, and he continues
to spew them. I might have a real case there.
But in any case, I'll just have to settle for actually showing
that he's lying on stream or, you know, asking him >> She
also thinks Asmin Gold is better than a son as a content creator
for young men. Not really. >> Uh, I mean, you said he got
or he said you got someone to perjure themselves. Should be a
slam dunk, right? That's pretty nuts. So, it again, it would
be knowing, right? Actual malice there. So, he might believe
that and he is clearly like losing his mind. So, I do believe
that he's actually that he actually does like believe that, right?
I do believe that he thinks that like someone perjured themselves
and he thinks it's all a persecution. Not that he didn't do it,
by the way. That like the only reason these people would go after
him is because they're all coordinating. It's a conspiracy against
him. I believe he's narcissistic enough to believe that. So,
I don't know if that is uh actual defamation there. Oh, but it
is. Hold on. It's It might be defamation per se. Yeah, but then
if I go to if I go to write a CN D, he's just going to retract
the defamation per se that specific one. Just annoying. >> Really
important. But maybe maybe it's worth it. >> My post but
shows the terminal nature of Hassan derangement syndrome as well.
Um >> I don't even know why we're I don't even know why
this post is including Kyla. >> I was just making fun of
Dusty's chatter. Oh, I was just like actually trying to engage
latigious gamer cuz for me I think it's I don't really have the
money. I like I don't have the money to go and do that and chase
down uh defamation. Defamation is something you sue for if you're
rich and can afford lawyers and you're just trying to like like
even if you lose, you're fine with >> Love it. Okay. >> I'd
be like I'd be like in trouble if I lost. I won't keep you because
it sound like you're short for time. Just one last thing I was
going to mention too. >> Extreme dad defamation per se
is not when you represent yourself.
>> Is um a lot of times with young men, it's kind of like
that episode of The Office where Michael Scott's on the date.
And at first when he doesn't know he's on a date, he's acting
normal, he's doing great, but as soon as he figures out he's
on a blind date, he kind of like tanks it and stuff. Uh sometimes
if like they if the young men figure you're >> Why was
it so easy for all your orbiters to get so Is that just part
for the course of stream? Oh, wait. Who asked that? Nulch, why
was it so easy for all of your orbiters get so Is that just part
of the course with streamers?
>> Why was it so easy for all of your orbiters to get so
Is that just part for the course of streamers? Well, one I mean
like Pixie's initial like Pixie's initial substack looked really
bad and Pixie has a reputation for being like an innocent little
angel. Like people don't realize that she's also kind of really
bad. And Pixie has a reputation for being like an innocent little
angel. like people don't realize that she's also kind of like
a like a demon or whatever in the background. >> Oh, see
this is why it was so easy for a lot of his orbiters to turn
against him, right? Who's operating in the background that is
that would be unaware of this? If that were true, just on its
base level, if that were true, a whole bunch of orbiters would
have gone, "Oh, we don't really believe Pixie, right?" But the
opposite happened. That's like demonstrably false on its base.
Just for dude, why didn't any orbiter come out and say that,
dude? Hey, he's actually he's actually just falling back to the
insane horror argument every single time. He's so gross, dude.
H he's such a disgusting piece of God. Most people weren't aware
that actually she was like a mentally ill and uh yeah, as long
as you're aware of that, guys.
Okay. Wait, is it not illegal to non-consensually send of mentally
ill people? Dude, is there a per is there a provision in Cardi
I'm unaware of that says actually if these people have a diagnosed
personality disorder? You go nuts, fam. You just spam their all
over the internet, bro. You got it, bruh.
Is that how it works or crazy? This guy, dude, this is this is
the most powerful legal mind outside of the law profession right
here. Um, so like the initial thing that came out from Pixie
looked really extreme. My ability to respond to it was like pretty
hamstrung initially because with an No, it wasn't >> coming
lawsuit. I don't know what I should say or shouldn't say online.
So, I have to be careful with what I say. Um, and then I also
uh I think I'm probably I needed to stop caring about this. I
am. I'm like this is part of me stopping to care about this.
Um, guys, guys, I was really holding myself back before and I
shouldn't hold myself back, guys. When I totally sucked Ben Shapiro's
for career opportunities, I really regret that and I should never
have held back like that. Did Ben Shapiro tell me that to to
suck his No, I just sucked that circumcised beautiful thing cuz
I, you know, I really had to. I just had to, guys. Oh, did he
uh did he stop associating with me cuz I went hard on one of
his friends or him? No, he didn't do that either. But I totally
need to make up that he would have. I need to tell you that he
would have cuz like uh Candace Owens didn't like when I was mean
to her. So Ben would have, you know, Ben would have left me eventually.
Yeah. Yeah. I try to be, I think, like excessively careful about
not trying to influence people's opinions about things or not
trying. Guys, I'm excessively careful to make sure I'm not influencing
people or influencing things,
you know? I'm not like I'm not like JTock. I would never I would
never try to influence somebody who's mentally ill, guys. I'm
not like JTock. I would never do that. I would never do that,
guys. I'm not like I'm not like JTock or Queen. I never influence
these people at all. It's so embarrassing.
By the way, it's embarrassing for us because we show evidence
of this, right? We show evidence very consistently. How can you
say this with a straight face? I have no
>> to
like feel like I'm like a manipulator, controlling person. But
I realize like all these people call me a manipulator or a controller
anyways. Like despite the fact, for instance, that just is like
dating a woman that he just had committed for attempted two months
ago and is still weaponizing her on stream to post about me and
Kyle is insane. after he so again mo mostly this isn't even an
attack on me because he knows guys do you think he thinks his
audience cares about Cherry do you think his audience cares about
Cherry is going to go like oh yeah we hate Jay's dog now because
he's abusing Cherry this is just an attack on Cherry that's all
it is he is trying to isolate her trying to make anybody who
watches this think she's like crazy right just like when he talks
about Pixie he's never going to refer to like me or anybody it's
like it's all Pixie this is him going after Cherry purely so
don't worry about me on He's not attacking me because probably
if anything the people in his audience would go, "Whoa, Jayto's
like abusing a mentally ill woman. I might have to throw a sub.
I might have to throw a sub, guys. I might I don't know about
you guys, but I might have to throw a sub." Right? That's how
they hear with regards to me.
But it's it's just to isolate Cherry. It's try to make her try
to make her feel alone. Try to like denigrate anybody who engages
with her possibly on social media. Oh, don't you know this woman's
mentally ill? So that they don't ever engage with her actual
points. And all Destiny has to do to disprove this is watch the
Notso Aerodite documentary that Cherry produced in full and explain
to us how not so aerodite actually was right about the word whistleblower.
Go ahead, just engage critically with any of this stuff. Right.
Cherry's so crazy. She's not making real criticisms, guys. She's
just she's just obsessed. She's just obsessed, guys. She's just
obsessed.
Okay, just go point out how the obsession like ruined the criticism
maybe or not. You know,
he should be willing to do that, right? Isn't Aerodite really
smart? Isn't she really good at debate? Doesn't she do a really
good job? Can you not Can you not do that? Can you not defend
Arerodite at all? Go and defend Arerodite. I just I want Destiny
to watch this clip on stream and defend it. Okay. Oh, not this
one. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where is it? Where
is it? Where is it? Where is Oh, hold on. Actually, uh, hold
on. Good debater. Good at debate. Yes. Yes.
Oh, what the hell? No. Good debate. Right here. I want Desessie
to fire up this clip and defend. >> Kind of based. We're
trying to recruit >> Based in what? I haven't said anything.
>> Just defend. Just defend. >> You said that Steven
was intelligent. That is lowkey based. >> I just want Desty
to watch this on stream and not cringe. >> He is. You don't
You don't debate and not have like a high level of intelligence
or like an understanding of how those types of conversations
work.
>> What if I told you >> his job literally requires
his intelligence? I wouldn't deny that. What if I told you that
Steven regularly has said that Kyla or not so arerodite is really
good at debate and does a really good job. >> Oh my god.
No way. >> How would you feel about that?
I like actually my like stomach drops just hearing it. My stomach
drops
listening to it. Okay. It's just like
and she thinks by the way she thinks that's effective. She thinks
that's going to work. Is he God? I I don't Is he God? Like I
don't like Okay. What? I don't care.
>> Oh boy. That's rough. That's Yeah, that's a yikesy one.
That's a yikesy one. So, just all he's got to do is watch that
clip. Okay. Show that you're not just being malicious. You're
not just trying to drive a wedge between Cherry and anybody who
would interact with her on in public or or like on streams or
anything. Show us, Stephanie, that you actually have a problem
with her criticism, right? That this this is something you're
not just spinning away. You're not just trying to say, "Oh, she's
mentally ill." to to dismiss her and denigrate her, right? Stigmatize
her mental illness. By the way, I just wonder how does Eerite
handle that, right? Is Erdite cool with being defended by somebody
stigmatizing mental illness? Erdite probably is cool with it.
Erdite is literally hiding behind this. Right? Erid will do the
same thing. She'll go, "Oh, I know this person has this person
has BPD. I can't engage with them." Right? She knows exactly
what she's doing. If it's all crazy and none of it makes sense,
then go watch. Go watch.
All you got to do. He told her that he would be her Dr. K. Um,
that's just a >> Oh, that did happen. >> Wild. Like,
I can't believe that anybody would take anything seriously that
comes from this guy after that set of arrangements. Like, that's
wild. That's just how untrustworthy Destiny is, right? Holy I
just checked it. Oh, yeah. Yeah. No, no, no, no, no, no. That's
Yeah. Sorry, chat. GB chat BBD. I started reading your [__]
and I cannot. Yeah, it was. Trust me, it was it was weird. It
was a weird moment. Okay. But, by the way, that nothing to do
with being a Just to be clear. Um, just being friends.
You see these not soite tweet chains, by the way. I don't know.
Are they the bad empanada ones? I'm probably not gonna go over
those right now. Oh, they're not, dude. Okay. Uh,
oh, it does go crazy.
Sorry. I was going to say, wait, does he say more about me? >> oh,
like how do people take me seriously? I just have evidence, right?
I just have like literally evidence for the things I'm saying,
and that's compelling to people. That's all it is. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. karaoke coat. Yes, it was. It was wild to say that. Yes,
I agree. You can uh you can criticize for that. What is this?
Ozel just says he linked the wrong one. Are you serious, bro?
Kala also deals. Well, well, I just sta I just wonder how you
can be a psycho magician, psychometrician, whatever the somebody
with some understanding and background and watch destiny explicitly
weaponize somebody's mental illness against them. For me personally,
I would imagine if I had been in that field, it would feel really
disgusting to watch Destiny consistently weaponize people people's
mental illness against them, right? Like that that would probably
feel gross to me, but it apparently it doesn't feel gross to
Kylo at all, which is just interesting.
I, you know, I'm just a noticer. I just notice things sometimes.
It's very interesting. So, this hypothetical punches at core
question within the left. If we assume Hassan will be politically
ineffective, obviously Hassan, but that's because the ineffective
modification to because of the ineffective modification to the
hypothetical. And the question between an effect of Hassan or
an effect of Kirk, who would be worse for America? I would say
obviously Hassan because his ideology is so vehemently anti-America.
And in America today, who matters more to oppose right now? Kirk
because of how deeply effective he is with TPUSA. Okay, it's
just like what do you think if we assume Hassan will be ineffective?
Wait, do you think he'll be effective or not?
This is really not. So, people took this hypothetical way too
seriously, including me, but it's it's like a somewhat interesting
hypothetical, I suppose. It's really just about like does it
make sense to cut Hassan out of things or not? Is a good strategy
to say actually anybody who associates with Hassan, Hassan himself,
these people are toxic to our movement. We need to cut them out.
We should not talk to them anymore. We should not platform their
ideas. We should cut them out. We should do an embargo on the
Cuba that is
the far-left in American media. Okay? Is that the choice? Is
that the choice Democrats should make? That's what the argument
is, right? And the whole point is Pisco saying, "Yeah, Hassan
kind of sucks." But is Hassan worse than Charlie Kirk? And there
are a lot of people, including the people actually protesting
Charlie Kirk, who going, "Yeah, Hassan is worse than Charlie
Kirk. Yeah, I do like Charlie Kirk's vision for America more
than Hassan's." Sad, sad, sad, sad. So then she says, "I see
bad empanada stanzer here. Just so it's clear, anyone who delights
in calling CPS on a content creator over internet beef is absolutely
someone I do not want to be affiliated."
Okay. Uh, I would say
if that's what they did, if they were like, I really hate Ethan
Klein, so I'm going to call CPS right now. That would be disgusting.
Be insane.
You're literally associating with Destiny who makes death threats
and doc share with without consent. Assault a girl on stream.
Stop acting like if you stop acting like if you have standard
in this lau, not the greatest English, but a punchy comment nonetheless.
That is all obviously correct, right? I would say technically
we haven't done an examination of the Molina consent violation,
the Stasia consent violation, the Cherry consent. We haven't
done all of these with the help of court documents, right? We
haven't done all of those things, but I mean once you have five,
six, seven people all in the at the same time saying, "Yeah,
he shared these videos of me non-conensually." I tend to believe
it, right? Sorry, I It's the Cosby thing, right? I didn't have
to know about all of Cosmy's Cosby's crimes. I went, "Oh, 17
women or something. Jesus. Jesus. That's crazy." Anyway, please
touch grass. I'm begging you. This is an amazing response. Hey,
you actually don't is someone I do not want to be affiliated
with. Bro, who are you actually actively affiliated with? That's
actually the only point here, right? Someone who who like call
CPS. Oh my god. I just would not want to be affiliated with them.
Uh,
okay. All right. I'd say probably in totality Destiny's actions
over encompass that. And I don't think calling CPS is any small
matter, but hey, we all got to make our bag, Arerodite, we all
got to make our bag. I see you. I see you. Sorry, the literal
reading of this is also funny. Oh, you've pointed out my hypocrisy.
You've pointed out how much how full of I am. Please stop engaging
on the internet. This is like Jeb, please c uh please clap levels
of engagement. Please stop talking.
Hey, what about all these hypocrisies that you're displaying?
Could you not point that out? Could you maybe go get a real life
instead of pointing out my hypocrisy?
Thank you. What color is the snark look? The snark look isn't
your color. What? Who's this? My DMs are open for apologies.
Yes, queens. And other any other capitulation to my intellectual
supremacy. Wait, is
Hold on.
Uh, yes. You managed to give somebody who absolutely tacitly
supports Assan and gives massive amplification to Asthma Gold
a bridge to another community. Yes, you did do that. Well done.
I'm starting to notice a pattern. Pikachu files police report
abuse allegations. The snark look isn't your color.
Absolutely destroyed.
Oh boy. Pikachu files police report amid techone abuse allegations.
Yeah. What what is wrong with this comment? This comment is just
true. Bringing. Yeah, we have the actual fest coalition building
up. Okay. Asminold's in there. Notaku's
in there. Okay. Techone. We're getting all these guys together.
Okay. All right. All right. All right. All right. All right.
All right. All right. We should continue. Right. We should continue.
But I I think rather than trying to um So Destiny was just telling
us how he doesn't like forming narratives. He doesn't like controlling
narratives. How he doesn't like being seen as a manipulator.
That's actually what he's told us just now. Hey, I don't like
I don't like it when people see me this way, guys. I don't like
this.
>> you missed the TAM clip. Wait, was was there a clip?
Oh, any DMs from Destiny of Apologies or Yes, Queen.
Wait, what what is it? What is this? I'm not sure what this tweet
is supposed to mean. My DMs are open for apologies. Yes, queens
and any other capitulation. intellectual. Uh I'm pretty sure
I bullied the out of this guy and tweeted horrendously mean and
then he eventually reached out like I thought everybody's whole
point was you need to be nicer and he's responding to a tweet
where I said MAGA will never accept the fact that Trump is a
kitty because they'd be too depressed that Trump didn't their
own kid.
I thought Wait, are you saying she's not doing a good job? I
thought she was a good job. I thought she was do a good job.
What happened to a good job?
99% sure that she would say that's a really bad tweet that you
shouldn't be making. But seems like it worked. By the way, that
was actually him being really bad faith to Arrodite, but I don't
care anymore. I'm not going to point that out. Okay. Actually,
that'll be really bad faith to Ardite. Just saying. But I don't
I literally don't care. It's funny that he thinks so lowly of
her that he'll just like on her and know that she'll just like
open her mouth and take it, right? That's funny to me. Unfortunately,
that's an incredibly from him, right? That that was not her point.
And she feels like she built the bridge there and he just [__]
on her for that. For She's literally trying her hardest. Oh.
Uh oh. She's literally trying her hardest to like build bridges
for this guy and he is actually on her for it. That's It's sad.
It's just It's sad. It's just sad. But Arid's a loser, too. So,
you know, it is. >> Rather than being so concerned about
being perceived that way, I think I should just like actively
cover it and go over it cuz these people all call me manipulators
and everything anyway. So, like like I'm not I'm not even manipulating.
I should just like give my opinion on it more. But generally
I like I'll refrain from saying anything like hey listen you
know what if you want to think whatever you want to think go
for it or talk to people or verify. But that's she's crashing
it again by the way this is like the eighth time he said this
right? Do you guys do you guys remember when uh what was it during
the Molina thing? Oh I'm not going to let people form narratives
by talking about me behind the scenes anymore. I'm going to be
really upfront about everything and I just I'm like way too nice.
I like let people form their own opinions and and all of that
and and and I can't do that anymore. I won't ever do that again.
Someone go get the clip. It's so sad. How do you use the same
excuse? He's just showed up for for school on the sixth day without
his homework and gone, "Yeah, my dog ate my homework again, teach.
My dog ate my homework again." And Erdite is the teacher and
all the other DJ years are class classmates. And they're like,
"Yeah, he sure. I bet he did. We totally believe you for no reason.
We're clearly being lied to. We're clearly being but we believe
you uncritically."
Okay, we love >> By the way, she just privated her Twitter.
Uh not surprising at all. Uh Jessica in that community I feel
like probably has the highest chance of pushing her to actually
kill herself probably than any community she's been involved
in. It's actually funny. I remember before in the past probably
>> I Dude, you don't Hold on. I just have to point out
this is the person who non-consensually recorded audio of Cherry
non-consensually distributed that audio to multiple people. And
he is pretending that he gives one tiny shred of a about her
well-being. I actually ho
I have to chill because like uh
dude this is psychotic.
This is actually
Like we we all understand this, right?
>> Having to I wonder it's actually funny. I remember before
in the past probably like a year ago having to I wonder if I
actually kind of her up a little bit. Maybe I shouldn't have
said anything cuz she would come to me for advice asking um do
you feel like just to go in and his community are all of these
people just manipulating me? And when I would look at stuff,
I would say, "No, I don't think so. I think you're probably just
in your head. I don't think that people are actively like trying
to manipulate or do crazy." I think you because she does cuz
Cherry does like not hallucinate, but reads into stuff. >> So,
it sounds like Okay, hold on. Let me Let me see if I get this
right. It sounds like she trusted Destiny to help her make that
evaluation and then was confronted with some information maybe
in the neighborhood of like January
that confirmed that hey somebody was who she was trusting was
totally lying to her was totally breaking her trust in the worst
way possible and that might have further harmed that ability
to trust people. No, like hey your actions.
So he's describing oh this person trusted me. They asked like,
"Oh, are people around this community like messing with me somehow?"
Right? And his response was like, "No, no, no. I don't think
so." And all the while, he knew that he'd done this. He knew
that he'd recorded her,
recorded encounters with her, and distributed those without her
consent, right? And he's like, "No, no, no. Here's how you should
like eval." Dude, how does that not with your ability to trust
people in the future? Of course, it's hard for her to trust people.
the person she trusted abused that trust and used it against
her. Oh man, it's I'm trying not to soy out about this
too much sometimes. >> I have to like move forward. It's
uh it's it's just he's just like one of the most transparently
reptilian disgusting people I've ever encountered in my life.
>> Um but I maybe they were actually in the past. I'm not
sure. Maybe I should have looked more closely at it. I don't
know. >> Oh, and then he's going to try to seed that, right?
As if she would trust something coming from him now. as if she
hasn't identified him as the least trustworthy person in the
world. Right,
>> dude? It's just all It's all just him trying to make
it so people feel uneasy or un unsafe engaging with Cherry. There's
Dude, I don't know how to say this to people. I care about Cherry.
Cherry doesn't lie. She doesn't make things up. You don't have
anything to worry about engaging with her, right? Go talk to
her on Twitter. go say, "Hey, no, I actually don't like I don't
I don't think this airite clip hits the the way it should."
Like, there's no reason you can't engage with her publicly at
all. Right? And and all he wants to do is further foster and
ferment that exact concept of like, "Oh, no, I can't I can't
talk to her. No, I Right. He's trying to isolate her and he's
going to keep trying to do it and it's not going to work cuz
this community actually does love her." Okay, we do. And this
this weirdo's attempts to like isolate her or foster distrust,
as disgusting as they are, they're gonna fail completely. >> Trying
to go for their vote, they'll kind of, >> by the way, like
this is exactly why I I have a hard time watching this guy now.
He's like reptilian. >> Lose respect for you. folks trying
to uh handle this subject without even mentioning voting or getting
them to jump to your side, but just coming from a genuine place
of their concerns and you know what impacts them and how you
can help probably would would help out a lot too. >> Uh
yeah, I mean I pro probably broadly agree. Um to be honest, I
don't give a he calls it a baseless me too against Mr. Girl when
he agreed at the time that Max's pants were too low. Oh yeah,
he totally did. Yeah. Yes, he totally did do that. H how young
men vote. I I hate the Democrats at this point so much. I don't
think they've ever earned anyone's vote. And I don't think anyone
should vote for people who don't care about them. So, I agree
that a lot of Democrats are approaching it, how do we get their
vote? And if it came across in the video, like that's what I
care about. >> They're implicating not so erodite cuz that's
part of the KF narrative. It's important to not so to keep that
narrative going. Oh, that is true actually because part of the
narrative that um Pixie kind of sort of pushed this as well because
she's um an actual child who's being manipulated by Lauren and
who the >> wasn't she a demon?
Wait, is she a child or a demon? Destiny, can we get this straight?
Demon. Childlike demon.
Are we building Destiny's ideal partner here?
Childlike demon. This is like Destiny's ideal mate. Stop fantasies.
Stop fantasizing on stream, bro. Disgusting. >> Else knows,
whatever. um tries to push this idea that Arerodite is my Gain
Maxwell, which I I don't even know where this come >> that
probably came from like the commentary people, right? They were
literally calling her Kyla Maxwell. That probably comes from
your former friends, Turkey Tom, Nicholas Doro, these people
all called her Kyla Maxwell. No, >> from um Kyla and Aaron.
Um Aaron who's escaped literally all culpability and responsibility
for this for whatever reason, whatever. But um um Aaron, I don't
even know where this comes from. Um, Kyla and Aaron. Um, Aaron
who's escaped literally all culpability, responsibility for this
for whatever.
>> Nope.
Aaron gets harassed about this all the time by tons of people.
She's not escaped all culpability or anything like that. Nope.
Nope. [__] reason. Whatever. But um Kyle and Aaron
were my two go-betweens for Pixie because Pixie removed me from
Discord um after she started crashing out because I wouldn't
say, you know, I guess give her a million dollars or whatever
the she removed me from Discord and I just you and I'm uncomfortable
talking to somebody who constantly um and Pixieated to like 15
different people over the past, you know, few months to get whatever
she wants on things. And I just used Kyla. Wait, I thought she
was being Hold on. Is she baiting or is she a child who's being
manipulated by people? I don't are all of these things. He just
has so many different like he's he's used so many different caricatures
to attack these people, right? Like they don't even make sense.
They don't like mesh together
basically as a go-between for talking, but like Kyla is sending
her messages to Pixie and me and and Aaron has them. Like it's
not like any of this was private. Um the the weird obsession
with trying to make her like a Gillian Maxwell is just like really
weird and it doesn't even make any sense. It kind of makes I'm
sorry Erd if she doesn't understand how getting drunk with those
like those people from Tik Tok and like trying to constantly
talk about how awesome you are and like you should come join
us. Don't you respect Destiny? Don't you really like Destiny?
Like I'm sorry I wasn't making that comparison before, but that
was some weird. No, wasn't that weird? That was weird. It's like
leaning directly into that. Like if you wanted to create a situation
where people could make that argument, it's like you tried as
hard as you could. That's not my fault.
That's I didn't do that. >> Like do like like it just doesn't
make any sense at all. Like why like do I even if I was like
let's assume that I'm a person that do I need somebody to like
get women for like it's just super cringe and >> about
that's unfortunate and I'll be more cautious about that. I don't
give a how young men vote. I care about how they think. That's
all I care about and I think young men are thinking really really
poorly.
>> I agree. Well, thank you very much. Did we do I guess
we skipped over the part where do we skip over the part where
she does the oh I don't need them to don't vote for anybody who
doesn't care about you. Did I miss that? Hold on. Ah it surely
he called that out right that is essentially Hassan's position.
Don't vote for people who don't care about >> The last
clip is to say if she doesn't care who young men vote for and
she doesn't think you should vote for somebody if you personally
believe that then it's odd that because I don't even know why
this person was
it's so transparent, right? It's so transparent that that
this is why Yeah, he is such a This is why you don't deserve
to be respected, right? Like, you don't deserve any respect.
All of your opinions are spite based. You don't deserve respect.
They're not based on any principle. You're a whiny loser.
Like literally, you've been sewing the out about Hassan and how
he like ruined the Democratic party and you find out Erd has
the same opinion and you don't engage with it at all. You just
move on. >> Um a counter example and final thoughts. >> Yeah,
he's just
the only logger clip I can find advocate for education. Okay,
don't care. So, somebody said this guy is a cross poster in all
these other communities. Is that actually true? Um posts.
>> Oh, through the post. >> Nice. Okay.
Oh, we found the link. We found how we could dismiss them, guys.
We found the We found the link, guys. All of those things we
just read, you can actually dismiss all of them immediately because
this guy doesn't like Destiny. Uh-oh, it's Snark.
Oh my god. That means everything said here is wrong.
Does it matter that it's all sighting clips and it's a totally
consistent, logical, like sound argument? Nope. That doesn't
matter cuz snark cuz it's snark. Oh, DG. Oh, we can throw this
one out. Believes his victims are have conspired against him
using alt accounts. His evidence, they use a lot of ellipsies.
This is not a troll. Yeah, that's true. That is he genuinely
believes this. Yes. How the can he cry about snarkers when his
own subreddit exists? Dude, he himself engages in far worse behaviors
than H3 Snark does. What are we talking about? He himself engages
in far worse behaviors, let alone his
It's not us trying to hold him culpable for the actions of his
community. It is his actions. >> So Pisco and then DGG
snark poster. DG snark. DG snark RPCO. RPCO. Me at work listening
to Pisco eviscerate every Hassan hater who challenges him. The
funny thing is is like these people,
>> dude. He's going to engage with that like it's true.
Like like Pisco is a massive Hassan fan, right? Literally the
only thing that makes Pisco capable of like quote unquote defending
Hassan is that people are going so insane about Hassan, they're
going so unhinged about Hassan
that Pisco can go, "Oh, like here's reality." And they like they
literally foam at the mouth, right? Pisco could argue that Hassan's
the fifth worst person in America and they go, "Why are you defending
Hassan? Why are you He's only the fifth. He's at least the third.
Maybe the first." He was mad on his stream tonight. Pisco or
someone else, Destiny? I have no idea. >> People are the
type the um sorry just getting down are the type of people that
would hate Hassan uh in any other circumstance but because of
like where the um the battle lines are drawn in these online
communities they're like roped into being the biggest Hassan
stands in the world which is
no
I just explained it understands this as well that Pisco is standing
firmly planted in reality and when somebody goes insane on Hassan
says something that's like not coherent not uh not what we call
like not real. Okay. They say something that's totally fake that
can't be proven.
Pisco goes whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa. And that's made people lose
it. He is not a Hassan defender. He does not like believe Hassan's
dude. Pisco would have every criticism in the world. And all
you have to do destiny to show that he's an insane Hassan stand
is show the place, show the critique, show the position where
Pisco's shifted towards Hassan since your allegations. Show me
where he's shifted towards Assan. I remember Pisco coming on
my stream and arguing with Dan about why Dan's campaign against
Twitch was unhinged.
I remember Pisco going and defending he he defends every like
he defends free speech. He defends all of these principles from
a principal position. I understand that can look very disconcerting
to people with no principles who flow uh here and there or float
here and there on the wind, right? That their positions are entirely
determined by spite. Pisco can appear to take other people's
sides randomly, but he just follows the principles, right? That's
it.
Pisco's broad political approach is like he's trying to build
like a strategy. Now, there are things you could criticize Pisco
for. He can be an sometimes, although he's worked on that. I
watched him be very patient with callers. Pisco, dude, if Rage
Pope, if Rage Pope called into his stream, a bunch of the people
who've subbed to him in the past 3 months would have no idea
what Pisco just appeared. There would be a demon that would be
summoned from the depths of hell and would just be like, "Get
the out of here, you loser. You don't you can't even follow this
conversation." Except without the cursing. Pisco doesn't curse.
But he was super rude to Rage Pope, which is kind of funny a
little bit. Pisco was hesitant from the jump. NYSE has a roundt
video from D's uh from D's where Dan was highlighting a new Hassan
site and Pisco was cringing constantly. Well, yeah. And no, they
argued on my stream. Like Dan and Pisco argued on my stream.
Pisco was like, "This is unhinged." And it was funny because
Dan was like not able to make any arguments, right? Wasn't able
to make any arguments at all. And and Dan was like, "Jay, can
you can you say I'm like, okay." And Pisco started arguing back
with me. I'm like, "Hold on." I'm like, "I'm I'm actually on
your side, Pisco. Like, am I on your side of this issue?" So,
like, I'm trying to figure out how to steal Mandan's position
for him.
Oh, that was a good night. That was when I used like Twisted
Metal as my I think it was like Twisted Metal as my background
video game. >> Hilarious for me. Oh, we've got Loner Box
posting
>> dude boy.
>> Oh. Oh my god, it's so blatant. Holy sh Queen glazes
up Pisco says he appreciates that he is principled and he should
be more people lol because um probably because of the public
statements to distance themselves from me. Remember, anytime
somebody makes a public bad statement about me, anything related
to Dude, I will say uh Quinn, I have openly conspired on stream
about how how like fragile Destiny's ego is and how we could
say like little positive things about Pisco that would make him
lose his mind. And all I can think now is yeah, operation success.
Like, do you remember when I was talking about how like we just
have to point out how full and like luscious Pisco's beard is
and Destiny will start losing his mind? Yeah.
Download complete. Okay. We know this guy. We know this guy's
thought process. He's owned. He's completely owned. All right.
He's got no idea what's going on. What was the other one? Oh,
talking about just how much smarter Pisco is than Destiny, right?
Just as little things just like, dude, Pisco is so much smarter
than Destiny. And the best part is they're true. It's all true,
right? You just say these things that are true and Destiny is
so insecure
that he loses it.
He loses it. I wouldn't be shocked if he saw the beard comments
from me or Quimman, right? He says funny stuff about the beard
later. Well, it'd be funny if he saw those comments and like
that's basically where he decided he's going to try to drive
a wedge between Hutch and the rest of Lib and Learn because he
is that petty. He is that small. He is that insecure. Okay, it's
good. to that will >> this guy this guy
physically spiritually metaphorically
in every sense okay all three realms he's destroyed >> the
side and then if it's the opposite then you're going to get people
you know like just to go watching that one VOD of trying to say
well hold on we all know that he's like a right I didn't say
he was a I said you sent the the videos of Pixie consensually
bro all we have to do is go look at those allegations and like
it's bolted on it's literally that's decided how is he how is
he even trying to rewrite this Unless he has to argue that like
six different women have all accused him of this and they are
not connected, right? Or sorry, and they're connected. They all
decided to conspire and and accuse him of this. Like multiple
women have accused you of doing this without their consent. One
I could see being like a thing where you could discredit that.
Say, "Oh, well, it's just my word versus theirs." But like six,
six is too much. I'm sorry, >> dude. Econ boy will never
Econo is never going to hit. Okay. This guy's never going to
be awesome. This guy could could never go crazy. Pondering politics
like I'm sure his David Pacmanes review videos are fine. Pisco
could be epic. Pisco could actually be epic, but he just for
some reason he is not >> I've seen this one. >> There's
no fire in him at the moment. Do you know what I mean? Like this
guy should be out there people and not like just going on Tim
and being like a >> Oh, I can't believe I can't believe
Quan didn't just slide in there really quickly and not in the
Destiny sense. Okay, that would have been very funny. Not that
we actually believe that Destiny has somebody physically. Okay,
but he should have he should have Oh, he was it was there. It
was there. >> He should be out there.
>> Um, they love hiding a piece of me out. >> Oh,
hold on, hold on, hold on. >> He should be out.
>> Uh, I have no idea who Quan is, and I don't intend to
find out. >> Out there. >> We need to nuke Bongerland.
>> Um, they love >> Hold on. There was There was
somebody who asked >> me out there. >> How old is
this awful person? uh for a while. I don't remember how many
months ago this was, but I know that >> the UK government
also wants to know >> um Blav is my number one obsessive
guy on TV who post about me. It was like hyping up Pisco is like
because Pisco distanced himself from me, he hyped up Pisco is
basically being like the better version of me in any way. Dude,
dude, it's all insecurity. It's all insecurity. It's all been
insecurity the whole time.
Oh, I did not want I didn't get to watch this far. I didn't know
he actually did it.
Oh my god. It's all
Pisco is here's the funny thing. The best part about it is Pisco
is just smarter, right? Pisco is just smarter. He is just better
in every way. He has principles. He's just destiny with
shape, or form. So that became like the obsession. Now that's
not to say that there aren't legitimate reasons to like Pisco.
Like I think still think he's like one of the most fun people
to debate and he's incredibly knowledgeable when it comes to
law and even if he gives dumb political takes that I super disagree
with sometimes. I don't think >> he's a way better debater
than you. I think he's like an actual >> as far as we know
respects women's consent. That's a huge W for Hassan and Pisco
over Destiny. >> I think Pisco is a really smart dude.
I think he does have the potential to be like a huge streamer
and everything. Um, so I'm not trying to say that like the only
reason anybody watches him is cuz they hate watching him. That's
not true. But he became like the kind of like the icon for uh
Kiwi Farms and everything to be like juxtaposed to me. >> He
go lost to me in a debate. So not that smart. No. That's like
one of my favorite clips. No,
>> To show that like, oh, um, I could find
I was >> Dude, it's awesome having somebody who's really
good, who can humiliate conservatives and doesn't and still respects
women's consent, has like a loving relationship, right? It's
awesome. Did I say to him in that debate? You did. Yes.
Somebody's got that clip somewhere. It's probably on my >> Never
ever ever going to comment on any of this stuff, so I don't have
like these posts saved. I don't know how many months back you'd
have to go, but um Blav was like super obsessively hyping up
Pisco for a while at being like my successor now that I'm like
a or whatever. Um if anybody who DMs me the from K Farms has
a link to it. >> Wait, hold on.
People DM him from Kiwi Farms. So like there's a media ecosystem.
There's like a flow of information that comes from Kiwi Farms
directly to Destiny's DMs. And he's like explaining KF lore that
I don't even know. Bro, how much of this? The entire stream was
just projection. It's just sad.
How, dude? Nobody Nobody actually pays attention. Nobody watches.
Nobody actually watches or pays attention to what he says, they
only watch or pay attention when he's actually debating people.
And for like the clip moments, nobody's actually listening to
what he says most of the time. He just said, "Oh yeah, people,
all the people who DM me clips from Kiwi Farms, could you uh
could you DM me those clips?" He's literally explaining how he
gets clips from Kiwi Farms into his DMs and then he wants to
show them on stream. I thought this was like an evil thing. I
thought this made you a part of the Cabal. Is Destiny I don't
want to be in the Cabal. Destiny in the Cabal.
Uh-h which do I speak to to get this fixed? Which one? It's not
Queen. I know it's not cuz he would have told me. Which which
man do I have to speak to to get this cabal fixed? He can't be
in it. Destiny Destiny's out. He He's got to be kicked out. Get
him out. >> Then you should shoot that to me. But people,
okay, literally
like he should be out he should absolutely be picking more fights.
It's so clear that this guy has um a way more principled and
intelligent position on so many topics. He's actually seething.
He's actually seething. He's actually so
Dude, I've never Dude, I don't I grow plants, but the plants
are like growing over time and you never know. This is like that
I've been like watering a seed for like weeks and months and
just seeing it suddenly it's like flowering one morning when
I wake up that like this this like thing where we're like, "Oh,
he's really insecure. It' be really funny to like talk about
Pisco's beard or how much smarter Pisco is." That like we just
keep saying it and now Desty's like actually openly seething
about it on stream. It's so good. It's the Casey Trron clip full
circle at Jtock, but Pisco is now Destiny and Destiny is Hassan
and Queman is Casey Tron. What? What is this, dude? This is fantastic
>> Meaningful demonstrations of racism. So, for instance,
like the criminal justice system or economic
>> Yes. Destiny is is Hassan. Okay. Destiny is now Hassan.
Pisco is Destiny. And it's just going to be the same thing. It's
like, guys, why do we have Destiny around when we could get the
same information without anybody's consent being violated? Why
do we even have Why do we even have Destiny here? We could get
all this information from somebody who doesn't violate women's
consent. That's crazy. >> Disadvantages, right? And the
>> H. So true.
Wow. Hutch look. Wait, Hutch was in this
>> That's not Hutch. That's That's method Josh.
Yeah. No, that's not Hutch.
>> First Amendment stuff. the glaze, >> the Hassan
stuff, the Palestine stuff, >> anything that he could.
Yeah, big disagreements coming on. Good job. Yes, >> How
is he sorting or how is he like sourcing basically the things
that you do think Destiny's disingenuous on? Like he is saying
Queen is saying Destiny's disingenuous on these topics, right?
He's saying Destiny's disingenuous on these topics and these
are the reasons I like Pisco cuz Pisco is not disingenuous on
these topics and he's like, "Yeah, anywhere he disagrees with
me." Yeah, obviously.
obviously the all these topics he's got such good takes on and
there are so many
out there he's a lawyer he's a smart guy he's um it feels like
he's motivated in the right direction
you know like he's he's principled
if so if there is a principle he believes in that he feels like
his you know side are abandoning or something he he fights for
that which is you know I appreciate that and he uh you know
destiny on several What do I hate? >> No, it's direct call
out. Okay, >> hold on just real quick. Hold on. Can this
go? Hello. Hello. I need my clip. I need my clip. I need my clip.
What? How did this get deleted? What? Why is this deleted? E.
Oh well. Oh, Salivation deleted his account or something. I need
the clip. God damn it. Okay, this was posted on May 30th, 2025.
>> Let's see it. Let's see it. Show me. Also, give me a
second. I'll be right back. Excuse the bathroom. Hold on. I'll
I'll actually pull this back just a little bit so I don't miss
anything. It's going to be him. I'll be right >> This was
posted on May 30th, 2025.
And then this is uh June 3rd. This is a Blav post. Um just part
of it. This guy skips post about me so much. Um so 4 days I guess
after this clip was posted on the subreddit. I don't know how
long until after it happened. I didn't post about it, but Pisco
actually entertained a chatter who was on him for platforming/cleaning
Aeradise image. However, the fact that he entertained that kind
of argument makes me think that he knows Arodite is a piece of
therefore thinks Destiny is completely guilty. This is just to
say that despite everything Destiny's claiming that the case
is Wait, are we just full on like Blab posting now? We just get
to read Blab's post directly from Kiwi Farms.
Is that a thing?
Is that Is that a thing?
I Dude, how the did this How is he saying I'm the Kiwi farmer?
How is he saying this? How is he saying this?
Mother >> is going to get dismissed and his old orbiters
are wanting to come back. That doesn't seem to be the case. Pisco,
although probably believes Destiny's audience is a powerful tool
to weaponize, doesn't seem to be buying any of Destiny's regarding
his case at all. Yeah. So, there's like a ton of posters around
this time that this is when when did me and Quan start saying
that like Pisco, you could totally build another movement around
Pisco. I feel like I've been saying for as long as I've been
like covering Pisco at all that Pisco has principles. He works
harder. He is smarter. He is a far better political force than
Destiny. I've rep I've presented him as the replacement for Destiny
for like as long as I can remember right now. Like he is just
way better, right? Why is he reading old posts about Pisco and
Arerodite? I have no idea. I honestly have no idea why he's doing
this. But I'm just trying to argue that I feel like Blav stole
this from me. Okay. I feel like this guy that the post he's reading
May 30th. Oh, I was definitely on the Pisco train way before
that. I was definitely saying because it's it's so easy, right?
Pisco's principles.
Pisco is a good debater. All he has to do is get a maybe a little
more entertaining and I think he has I think he's worked on this
stuff and he's he's done a really good job, right? Like I think
Pisco is absolutely a replacement. He's just way better. I don't
get where works harder part where it comes from. Bro studied
Israel Palestine for a half year straight.
Uh, wait. Why do you Hold on. You understand that Pisco started
his streaming stuff while working full-time at a massive law
firm like that almost nobody can get into working at, right?
That he was doing all of his streaming stuff, all of his argumentation,
all of his Twitter posting while also being a full-time lawyer
or full-time student in a prestigious law school. He unequivocally
destiny on work ethic. And me too, a lot of people, right? He
works incredibly
people who like would disagree with you. You'd have to be a complete
[__] to disagree at that point. He basically all
streamers in work ethic. It's not close. Yeah, it's it's like
not close. It's so it's transparent. Now that he's like streaming
only, he's doing content constantly. He's streaming constantly.
He streams multiple times a day. Yeah, he streams multiple times
a day. Yeah, it's not close.
>> Pisco talked about Destiny with a teary eye for a minute
before ending today.
See, housekeeping about tomorrow. I'm super displeased
with the DGG coverage and Destiny coverage of the Live and Learn
stuff.
I essentially think that there's a campaign that is almost specifically
intended to misconrue arguments, to make conclusions that we're
not making, um, and essentially to lie about our positions. And
so, I'm not happy at all.
And so that will inform the approach I take tomorrow. Um I you
you know I'm going to be pressing hard for disagreements,
pressing hard for prescriptions and yeah so that definitely will
be happening happening. Um
don't expect it to be like a very like happy conversation. I'm
not happy. I'm very displeased and I it's not just for me. It's
also for accountable. I think he's being unfairly
>> I actually don't know the stuff that happened to a Connor
boy to tell you the truth. Is he crying? People are saying that
he uh he was a little like breaking up. Like realistically, I
think he felt like Destiny was a true friend. He felt like Destiny
and him were building a political movement and like that this
wasn't a thing. I I have a feeling that if Pisco had some kind
of idea about the Pixie stuff, right, he probably had some kind
of idea, but I'm guessing he didn't he didn't know quite how
deep it went. I would assume and he probably feels like betrayed
and that like he went his own way and this other person is like
trying to him in the back now that he went his own way. Like
he didn't comment. He actually let it go, right? He let it go
and Destiny is like like just totally maliciously stabbing him
in the back for no reason. Connor boy tweeted out it said he
was misrepresenting. Yeah, I don't I would be interested to see
how Destiny could possibly paint this as me, right? Oh, I will
say one more thing just in case uh Pisco missed this. Do I have
this here? Did I save this here? I had to have saved this here.
No, hold on. There's one thing that I that I went and looked
up and now just so Destiny's tried to web Pisco into straight
raid and stuff like that. But I think what probably Pisco might
not have realized, but I realized because I figured he did it
because he did it to Lykan was that Destiny likes to take like
relationships between people and use them and weaponize them
as well, right? Weaponizes my relationship with Cherry, weaponizes
Lykan's relationship with Straight Raid. He loves to do like
this es when he's been like hurt by people, right? When he when
he feels like he's been wronged. And I I assumed he did it about
Joanne and he did, right?
So it's like uh this Jay Barton person says Pisco's actual argument
on stream today there are two there were two historical inifatas
so we inififadas so we can't know which historical event it is
in reference to so the best inference we can make is what they're
talking about uh the Arabic word for resistance. If you can't
point to the specific historic event a person is referencing
when they say that phrase then you can't say it's anti-semitic
or promoting violence. Yeah, that sounds like one of his arguments.
And Destiny says, "Oh, what Jay Barton?" This guy says, "Watch
the last 30 minutes of his stream." And sorry, do we have another
Destiny? We don't. So then this Damon guy comes in and says,
"Sounds like some commies got in his ear and got him on that
pro Himas fast track Pepe ear." Is there another Destiny message
here or is it in the next one? It is in the next one, right?
Damn it. How many good men are we going to lose to socialist
GFs?
Guys, how many good men are we going to lose to socialist GFs?
So, it's just the straight raid liking. Oh, now Joanna's Pisco
totally changing his opinions, right? Like, it's it's just sad
cuz here's the thing. Destiny likes Joanne. Destiny has been
nice about her. He's said nice things about her on stream. And
now, as soon as you know, Pisco is saying something he disagrees
with, he's going to go to the like mind controlling thing immediately.
Yeah. And he suggested the straighter raid thing as well, right?
Well, no, the DJers do the straighter raid one more often. And
I meme'd me multiple times. is like, "Dude, at least if you're
going to do the mind control thing, can you at least do it with
his girlfriend who's like super into politics, who he probably
argues with all the time. Like, you're kind of giving straight
raid laurels for stuff that Joanna should get." Wait, Pisco is
dating the silly serious. Yes, they've been dating for quite
a while. I years at this point, I think he repeated the exact
same thing about Joanna today. Okay. Yeah, he's just can't actually
it's he can't he can't deal with the arguments on the merits
anymore. So, this is what he's doing, right? This is the kind
of thing he's going to do. when he was having Lykan on stream
to argue, he kept telling everyone that she didn't make Lykan
go commi, but now the tune has changed. Yep. Yep. All it took
was basically
like a couple comments or a couple retweets of I think it was
like a couple retweets of people's like substacks or something,
maybe their GoFundMes. And it was like, oh, actually Lykan was
by Straight Reid the whole time. Never mind. Whoops. Very sad.
Very sad individual. Very sad twisted individual. Anyway, >> it's
like been their their fascination for the last few months. Um,
this is one of like of hundreds of posts that people make. It's
actually so unhinged. I don't >> Essie versus Pisco group
watch or what. I mean, I might stream it live. We'll see. We'll
see how we're going to do it. >> Know why this guy wouldn't
make an um
>> Oh, nice. DG snark. Pixie's legal team issue scathing
reply. >> Why do you have to go look through their
>> You know, you know what it says when you have to go
look through their history, right? When you can't just address
the argument. Why not just address the thread? Oh, no. I have
to go look up all of their history and see if there's anything
I can use to totally dismiss them. Stop. This is why Pisco totally
owns him, by the way. Uh,
go to Gigachad who works hard and and grounds his opinions in
reality and facts. Lazy come vampire who just sits here and like
tries to make up. He's just become Bosch, right? What he said
Bosch was in that same way, right? He's just become Bosch. He's
just like, "Oh, I'm not going to watch this stuff. I'm not going
to I'm not going to source clips. I'm just going to make up and
get my audience to believe me." Alipcia, come vampire. Damn.
>> Why? And another victim comes forward. The right to
>> But he has to I'll just I'll reiterate this just in
case people aren't following. Oh, also guys, uh we are we got
20 bucks from donations. 15 35. We'll call it 40. We're four
subs away from another hour on the stream. Sorry, two more hours
on the stream. Let's hit our first donor goal. We always get
the standard six. Four more subs. We get two more hours in the
stream. I need those subs now. Go, go, go, go, go, go. It's up
to you. 20 bucks away, guys. Okay. Also, he's clearly just trying
to poison the well against Pisco, right? So, he knows he's going
to go into that debate tomorrow. He knows it's like inarguable
that he has been bad faith to Pisco, that he has been talking
[__] about Pisco, that he's been making up about
him. He knows it's inarguable.
And so, he has to go, oh, well, actually, Pisco is like associating
with this these people, and he's probably going to call for like
denouncements of this stuff, right? And it's all going to be
a smokeokc screen. What? Regardless of what Pisco says, Pisco
could say, "Oh, no. Totally. Quinnman and Jtock. I don't like
those guys. I don't talk about those guys. I don't talk to those
guys, right? He could say all of that. Doesn't matter because
I think he'll also point out that that is just a smokeokc screen
to get away from the actual material conversation they're supposed
to have. How old is Pisco? Uh, I don't know. I have no idea.
Listen, does the sounder have a legal case against redact.dev?
Jesus. This guy admitted on stream multiple times that he talks
directly to Hassan in DMs. If that's true, that's
>> dude.
The DJGers left are just like the lowest IQ, most embarrassing
people. You got like this is this is why I was saying well, we'll
save it for later when he starts talking about Queen cuz like
now now I do want to start leaning into the Cabal stuff, right?
I do actually want to start leaning into the Cabal. Kathy typed
that I think. No way. What? Oh, is it in his YouTube chat? >> The
Squeaming guy admitted on stream multiple times that he talks
directly to Hassan in DMs. That's true. That's pretty That's
pretty funny. >> Wow. Wow. Kathy trolling. God damn it,
Desty. It's so blatant how mindbroken Jiz Cord and Jiz himself
are over anything involving you. They all hated Pisco and hated
his yes or no questioning style. What? I I mock the yes or no
questioning style because it worked. Like I literally do it.
I literally do it when I'm having contentious debates. Right.
You need to extract a contra an you need to extract not contract.
You need to extract a concession because otherwise the the debate
can't move forward. I I always mock it because it's effective
and it's funny, right? So because you hate his debate style,
you also hate everything he stands for. I don't even hate the
debate style. I respect how like effective it is. I respect how
effective it is. It's so distinctive. It was so distinctive to
me all the time that it was like it's immediately obvious when
I say you have to do the Pisco move. Yes or no? Yes or no? Do
you admit? Do Do you admit? Can you admit now that this is the
case? Yes or no? Yes or no? Do admit it now. Do admit it now.
That's Yeah, it's funny. It's so funny and it works because he
refused to move on until you give him his concession. Right.
It is funny. I'm sorry. You know what? You know what? I'm not
sorry. I'm not sorry. It's just funny. Okay. It is funny. Also,
that person's welcome to come on stream and say, "Where the where's
the Discord mindbroken?" Jeez, >> it's so blatant how mindbroken
Jiscord and just himself are over anything involving you. They
all hated Pisco and hated his yes or no questioning style before
any of his most recent happened. Now it's totally flipped. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I agree with that.
It's very funny. Yeah. I I think Pisco is funny. I've always
said he's like really good at arguing. I've always said like
I'm not going to argue with him on the line. Yeah. I don't know.
I don't know where this rewrite came from. I said he was mean.
I said he was like an [__] to people. That was my
criticism. Hey, he's an to people like Rage Pope. He's a And
it seems like he worked on that.
>> he tolerated that Zip Zip guy with the most call-in
yesterday for so long. >> It is what it is. >> Oh,
now they're like trying to paint it as though I did the uh what
do you call it? As if I ever did the Glain Maxwell with Ardite.
I like never leaned into that ever. Dude, it doesn't even matter.
It doesn't matter if you're good faith. This is why
this is why so much of this is stupid, right? It doesn't matter
if you're like good faith or you don't lean into something. It
doesn't matter. I guarantee you within six months, book it here.
Within six months, I will be blamed for like talking about Destiny
because of his son or talking about his son or something. Even
though that's been a hard line, everybody knows that's been a
hard line for me. Every other hard line I've like drawn in the
sand to say like, "I don't do that criticism because I don't
think it's valid."
Every single one of those, they just say I do, right? They just
say I do. And nobody provides a clip. Nobody provides evidence.
Within like six months, somebody will say I like talk about his
kid or use weaponize his kid against him or something.
>> 100%. Book it. Guys, three subs away from the next two
hours on the stream. Okay, you need to donate now. You need to
donate now. Now.
>> Donate, donate, donate. Do it. Do it. Do it. Do it.
>> I don't have anything else for this right now. >> What
are we doing? >> Understand the other stuff that drives
>> Hold on. I'm going to grab some food real quick. >> I
don't understand the incentives for just to turn on you like
this. Wouldn't he have more money/s by staying as your leech?
I think there's other stuff that drives people more than that.
Um I don't know in particular for him though given that he quit
his software engineering job and everything. I I I can't say
but I used to think that remember I thought that for like lab
and Mr. Girl. I never thought that they would like >> uh
there probably would be a lot of money in being like just a leop
of this community. Some things aren't worth selling your soul
for. I'm certainly dude I don't violate people's consent. So,
I'm certainly not going to, you know, take it. I'm not gonna
not gonna like sweep for somebody else doing it, you know. It
was the the cherry thing that really like broke me for different
reasons. Um, she was a friend and and stuff like that. It's uh
yeah, it just it wasn't like it there's it stopped being a financial
thing at all. Like before I thought there was a chance he was
misunderstood or I thought he was misunderstood. I like believed
in this guy unironically. I believed in this guy more than a
friend. No, definitely not at that point. The embed on DG is
probably worth what? Like 2K. Yeah, if you're top embed on DGG,
that's worth um Yeah, that's probably it's worth a lot of money.
I Let me do quick math. Quick math. Quick math. Quick math. Uh
it might be worth more than that, Zen Cali, if you're top in
bed consistently. Yes. >> Like nuke their entire their
entire online presence for whatever weird obsessive thing they
had against me. Oh, I think this is about to get outed. Um whatever.
I don't care. So, I think they're watching my stream now in just
Discord because I'm literally the most entertaining thing they
have to talk about. Seven. Okay, so this is basically now you're
sitting here lying about a bunch of stuff. Hold on. >> Oh.
Oh, I did totally clip this.
This is the Grabler hands. Hold on.
>> Am I muted? I'm not. Hold on. This is this clip. Wait,
where's my Where's my clip? What? Hold on. This was I just laughed
at the Grappler hands.
Hold on. Where is this? Here. This is the clip I made. There's
lots to the grappler hands. >> Did you see Queman's defense
of Asan's re-education camps? Yes. Queen and again are like full
on like 100% like
like scheming in the background trying to like stir and cause
drama. Grabber. Grabber. We're greedy grabblers, right? So anyway,
I I clipped that. I thought it was really funny.
I don't know if you know this. When Chad Logic references Queenman,
he does grappler hands, too. Everybody is like in implicitly
understanding that Queenman is all the time. They always do the
grappler hands.
It's weird.
I don't know what that means either. I really don't. I have no
idea. >> Do we finish the Pisco thing?
>> Hit him aligned
>> for no good reason. I even caught some of his review
of of my conversations from yesterday today. I thought that was
dishonest.
completely warped and dishonest
and I think it has nothing really to do with the merits of the
issue and so we'll be discussing that but yeah not happy at all
and I'm sure that'll show tomorrow but on that you guys should
watch it anyway here is >> as the moderator >> let's
go cool all right we're going to go through some totally unhinged
Discord logs guys totally Kiwi Farms level Discord logs
uh oh I posted a clip >> okay so this is basically now
Why do you do the hand movements?
>> I must have missed this recruitment drive you've been
doing to push things in a certain way. These are people in Justicle's
Discord server. Is that what you do when you argue with on stream
about a topic that has nothing to do with Destiny? I don't know
if it still exists in their server, but somebody told me that
a month ago created a dedicated room in his Discord server to
argue with people called Defense Squad. Yep. Some of the DJers,
they're way too they like they like try to be really disgusting
towards Destiny's victims in the gen chat. So, we just tag them
with the defense thing and they go in that channel. But mostly
it's like just totally normal conversation about Destiny's case
or different stuff around it. Argued with some people from Pisco's
Discord in there about uh about what about um oh, the Hassan
hypothetical. Yeah, it's like mostly chill people, but Oh. Oh.
It was created in response to Destiny raiding the Discord. Actually,
Destiny saying, "You guys should all join just Discord, right?
And we had a bunch of people who would come in and like either
denigrate victims or what else was there? I don't know. Just
be overall, right? You you literally tried to hate raid the Discord.
You did it openly on YouTube.
So, we created a we created a room for your people." Yes. The
defense >> about my court case, by the way. So, he's going
to bring Quan on then, right? He's such a He will bring him on,
right? Lol. Oh, the shell boner person is also like an obsessed
person who talks about me constantly like for months in these
discords. It's insane. >> Shell can be unhinged. I agree.
>> I love it that Destiny acts like just doing some background
when he's just on stream having a different opinion than him.
And he stated most of his opinions before Destiny even said anything.
Like this is ignoring all of the weird side Discord servers,
the obsessive talking in that spicy chat discord server that
he's agreed. I don't engage in the side chat. Like I I engaged
in spicy chat with Dan Saltman way before this, right? Dan Sultman
and I both engaged in spicy chat like a month ago. What? Um that
I think I think Chudlo Logic just privated it or made it so new
people can't join. H Oh, also I just saw that Chud just said
that he banned somebody for doxing in the Spicy Chad Discord.
Finally. H saying that he'd warned this guy for like a
finally.
What?
What do you mean finally? Literally, you pointed out that this
guy docks and tried to win, "Oh, that guy like post posted docs
to somebody. I'm going to ban him." What do you mean finally
the second you drew it to somebody's attention, the person got
banned? What is this disgusting
misrepresentation of events? What an insane misrepresentation
of events. Was it Dan? It was not Dan. Oh, true. Actually, that's
a that's a great
Dan probably was the most likely suspect. Actually, Dan left.
I think Dan got kicked out of Spicy Chat because I can't remember.
Bug Swander kicked him out. There's logs about that somewhere.
I'll go find out at some point. >> A week. Um, and he had
to finally ban him for it. >> No. What? No. He the guy
got timed out for a week because apparently the picture he posted
was there for like a couple seconds before it got deleted. And
the guy was sorry. And so they banned him for a week, right?
I think he just he wasn't thinking about like where the stuff
had come from. And he's like, "Oh, it's on Twitter." And he posted
it and he was like, "Oh." and he deleted it and then I think
they're going to move on and Chud came in and said, "No, I'm
banning that guy." Right? Doxing by Dan is okay. Doxing by someone
else bad apparently. But yeah, this this guy was like uh just
a Chud YouTube viewer who posted this and I think he realized
that it was bad. I don't think he's like happy he did it, right?
He wasn't like I don't think he was doing it like super maliciously.
Um,
anyway, so what from what I understand, the guy got banned for
a week or timed out for a week. >> Still donated $40.
Communism wins. >> Communism does win, Sophia. Thank you
very much for the 40. Gives us two more hours on the stream.
You love to see it. I'm going to add the 20 from
that puts us over the stream.
Hold on. Stream hours plus one. That puts us over the goal. I'm
gonna include the 20 bucks we got from Kickbot over on the donation
now and we'll reset the meters and add two hours to the stream.
Thank you very much, Sophia. Awesome. Okay. Yeah. So, anyway,
the guy got timed out for a week and then Destiny posted about
it and I think that was moderation's decision was time him out
for a week cuz he wasn't going to do it, right? Or he he didn't
realize it was like as bad as it was until he was informed and
then I think Chud said, "No, no, no, we got to ban him now."
I think that's what he said. So,
as soon as Chud was made aware of this though, he banned the
guy immediately, which is the bar for everybody. Don't forget
when Destiny when Keles was saying, "Oh, Destiny hate rated my
stream. Destiny hate rated my stream." What did Destiny say?
You get anybody in my community who's making comments in yours,
forward their name to me and I will ban them. You get anybody
in your chat making fun of you and they're like DJ, you get anybody
in your Twitter brigading you and like on you and being transphobic,
forward their name to my moderation and I will handle it. But
outside of that, I can't be omnipresent. I'm not everywhere.
I don't I'm not God. I don't know some of the things that happen
in my own Discord. If you are aware of violations and you're
hiding them to try to use later to as like a play yourself, you're
loser, right? So, report it or stop whining. As soon as was it
was as soon as it was reported, it was handled. That is all you
can expect from other creators. And Chud's met that bar entirely
as far as I can tell.
Um I don't have I don't say this. I wasn't I just decided yesterday
I was going to talk about this. >> Should have dude where
is the where's
what what is being proved here. Can somebody explain to me what
he's trying to show? We don't with you. We don't with you. We
don't like you.
We don't like you. If you're trying to prove that we don't like
you, then yes. But you don't have to prove that with Discord
logs. You just say, "Hey, does uh does JTO's Discord like me?"
No, we don't with you. We hate you. We don't with
How is that hard to understand?
>> By the way,
>> I will say when Destiny could try to use somebody he
was uh having a relationship with at the time or somebody he
was casually having with at the time or casually trading stuff
with at the time, Zoe, when he could weaponize Zoe in my Discord
to try to get people to hate Lav, he jumped at that opportunity.
He was totally like, "Yeah, you should need to post more pictures."
So Lav kills herself. Yes. And he farmed hate against Lav the
whole time. He's totally fine with this Discord hating people.
Just not him. He participated in this exact culture. He was a
part of it. He directed people here. He just doesn't like that
one of the people we don't like now is him. That's all he hates.
Okay. He was totally fine participating being a part of it, typing
in the chat, doing a bunch of Now it's like turn against him
and now it's like, "Oh, this is totally wrong." Same with Kiwi
Farms. Not related to me, but same with Kiwi Farms. When Kiwi
Farms was going against Keeles or going against Anna, right,
he was totally on their side. Now they're they're he doesn't
like what they're doing to him. Oh well, Kiwi Farms is evil.
Actually, >> it's in my DM somewhere. I'm just prepared
it. Also, he said all this about how he's a victim being gang
begged by Queen and everyone that breathes around him and gave
zero clips, logged, or any proof. Lao, he makes skitso associations.
>> That's just true. Yeah. Where's Where's the proof? The
proof was JC watched a clip with the watermark from KF on it
one time.
>> Yeah, he's just he's literally taking things that are
true. He might as well pull up like a multiplication table. Okay.
He's going to pull up a times table and he's go 9* 9 * 9 is 81.
Sure, buddy.
Sure, buddy. 11* 11.
I actually just forgot. 11* 11 one
Hold on. 121.
Oh, wait. Hold on. Yeah, 121. Jesus. I was like I was like, "Oh
god, do I not know my time tables?" I was like, "Oh,
121 was what came to my mind."
Whoops. I I almost that up. That was almost very embarrassing.
Cuz if you take too long, then it's like, "Oh, I would have known
it anyway." Right. Jesus.
>> Yeah. That But that's essentially what he's doing right
now is he's he's looking at things that are just factually correct
and then he laughs and goes, "Sure, good one." >> How far
does Gary Farms hate go back? Were they a part of the campaign
trying to get your sponsors pulled from like Optica? No. The
Kiwi Farm stuff became unhinged. I think around the time I in
like at the end of like 2023, early 2024 when I started to not
do. >> Wow. So like before I even streamed
>> kind of drama content anymore, I think those people
started to get really weird or obsessive. Yeah. And then obviously
the whole um solo pixie thing, by the way. Oh, and that leaker
guy, the guy who um leaked all of my that guy was a member of
Queensman's community as well. Crazy how that works, huh?
>> I don't think that's true. I don't think that person
participated in Queens community actively until that leak.
>> So, he's he's either purposely lying or misunderstanding
that this guy dropped the logs in Queid server or sorry, he dropped
the first previews of the logs in Queid server. He didn't drop
any like or anything and he asked Quimman to cover it and Quimman
said no I'm not going to be a part of like leaking this story
or leaking this information and then Sunday messaged him and
was like I will let's go and so Sunday leaked the original Lauren
Southern stuff right but the solo guy didn't leak any of the
sucking videos or any of the the non-conensually sent stuff he
didn't leak any of that originally right so also got banned I
see so he's probably referring to that so he's either he's either
dumb
or he Yeah, I don't know. He's like totally like misrepresenting
it here. I don't know when they joined, by the way. I'm just
saying that I I do not believe they were an active member of
Queen's community or anything, but they were in like a lot of
Discords. I think they were the whole time they were in the DG
Discord, weren't they? >> Literally, all Destiny saying
a response. Um, that's unhinged. Crazy. This is how he looks
while he's taking pictures with a fan. It seems like a >> Hey,
Kathy. W Kathy. Oh, that's funny. Where's the Where's the totally
unhinged anti-fan [__] where like they share revenge
porn where they dox people? This is just people talking. I don't
know if you know this, Destiny. You can open up any social media
platform on Earth that's been invented and there are going to
be people there who hate you cuz you're a piece of and you suck.
Like I'm That's just how it is, dude. Like he's not reading the
comments cuz they're literally like, "Hey dude, could you uh
could you like give some evidence?" All Desi does is allude to
him perceiving an angle and then not playing on it. Elude, scheming,
conniving. Just watch something and point to it. We know you
watch everyone else's stream.
This is a conspiracy. They're even worse than me. No, you they're
crazy. Destiny handbook. Why is he not okay? Like
it's Oh, Jacob. Very bad. Very bad. Not good. Obey the rules.
See, for me personally, that's like a line for me. I don't think
Destiny even really understands what that comment was, right?
Like Destiny has no concern for the person referenced here. There's
just no understanding what that comment was at all. He's just
like, "Oh, I'll just move on." >> He surpassed Keles's
talking about Nathan. Nice. Good. Good stuff. >> Not allowed.
Jacob bad. Very bad.
No, Jacob knows the rule. Jacob knows the >> Destiny log
2our. I don't know how there's nothing going on also in any of
these people's lives. Also, like I'm doing this now. I have like
dozens of Imager albums that people send me. Again, these people
have like Yeah. Are they as compelling as this where they're
just laughing at you for being a schizophrenic [__]
Like, like literally, you are just they're all laughing at you
for being a schizophrenic loser who can't provide evidence of
anything, right? It doesn't matter how many logs you post of
people just mocking you for being a gross weird freak. Doesn't
matter how many of those people post these logs, right? or it
doesn't matter how many albums you have of people laughing at
you. It's still just going to be people laughing at you. It's
still just going to be people calling you a weird freak. That's
it. So, post as many logs as you want to of people calling you
a weird freak. It's not going to be proof of anything. Nothing
bad, dude.
>> How many people speak positively of me in DG chat?
>> I used to watch Destiny. We all have our different trials
in life. Okay, Donzinger. I suggest Pisco. Okay. Full beard,
actual principles, doesn't violate women's consent. Better arguer.
I suggest Pithkco. He's smarter. He's better. He's better in
every way. Will never risk your movement because he was doing
some kind of weird discretion violating some woman's consent.
It's way better. Trust me, you'll see it eventually. These people
have obsessively talked about me for months. It's It's insane.
Notice how the only time he's defending Kylo on his stream is
when he's using >> I just want to make it clear. Destiny
is literally talking about this community. That's the stream
that they are commenting on, right? Destiny is literally commenting
on the community that is commenting back on him. Why does he
think that he gets to make these comments and then they won't
talk about him?
Can anyone explain that to me? Why would that make sense? He's
literally crying about this community talking about him while
he is talking about them. I'm not talking about now. This is
a separate time he's talking about my community. I'm saying at
the beginning of the stream he was talking about a conspiracy
that involved the Discords and stuff, right? And he said, "Oh,
there's 10 to 15 people who he won't point out to anybody." So
even if there were 10 to 15 people who were unaware of, he admitted
fully that they don't do any of this conduct in my Discord, right?
But I have no idea who they are. I have no idea what they've
done. They're 10 mysterious people that they could have done
bad things. I would have no way of knowing. And he's acting like
I'm at fault for this
as a weapon against.
Remember, the only reason I'm even talking about Kyla is because
this guy literally included her in his post. I don't even know
why the >> Yeah, I Okay, notice how the only time he's
defending Kyla on his stream is when he's using her as a weapon
against
>> Oh, sure. Well, that's actually true, though. Hold on.
He's not saying it's unhinged you're talking about her, Destiny.
He's saying that if you're not if you're not using her as a weapon
against other people, you're broadly just being like, "Look at
how this person is."
Oh, that's rough, dude. Crazy how he never back up any of his
crazy claims with something. This is most of the comments are,
"Wow, Destiny schizophrenically like ranting on his stream again.
Just total mania. No facts, no nothing. Just that's what most
of the comments are." And he's using her as a bro, how I'm going
to actually lose my mind. How do people watch this? How could
people hear this and see it and take this person seriously? Isn't
this the same compulsion that Anavore had? The constant urge
to correct the record? Does he recognize this compulsion?
Almost certainly not. Bro, you should watch me Ethan Klein and
see the my Discord says about me. Okay. Is he actually actual
anti fandom? >> Remember the only reason I'm even talking
about Kyle is because this guy
why she's in here and because she just got doed by Karm because
they're saying to call Ice on Earth. >> I believe she got
doxed again in 2024 >> for like the 50th time >> before
any of us did anything. So So that's still doxing. But I'm saying
that like to act like it's a response to us. It's not. It's a
response to Kyla. It's a response to just to be clear again,
the people who actually
interact with Kiwi Farms are Destiny. Destiny is the person who
registered account. Destiny is the person who sent Blav, his
most notorious anti-fan in ALOG, to Kiwi Farms. Destiny is the
one who's constantly tried to taunt this Blab person until Blav
started doxing all of his friends. Destiny is the person who
has to win when somebody challenges him. And so, he keeps going
back to to Kiwi Farms. He keeps referencing them, right? and
he's he's done it to the point where all of his friends are at
risk and he knows that he's already like docks or whatever. He
doesn't care. So the only people that can get hurt now for his
weird obsession with kiwi farms are the people around him and
he will keep making it happen because he doesn't care about those
people. Doesn't care about them at all. >> And who the
[__] is calling ice on her? Definitely on this many
bruh we didn't even allow Kelly to his GF too much. I don't even
know what that's in reference to. Although I think Kelly has
split over the cherry stuff. No one should use not so arerodite
as a blunt weapon. She has enough CTE as
that's a horrible joke, Neorak. That's a terrible joke. Laughing
at somebody who is kicked in the head by a horse. That is unbelievable.
I totally disavow. That is disgusting just for Destiny being
like
that's a joke. I don't disavow that. I think it's funny. You'll
notice how that's very different from my response around like
your kid or around anything to do with like doxing or something.
It's a totally different response. That's satire. That's a joke.
That's sarcasm. That's how you do humor. Just so you know. Just
so you know. >> Is so one of the jokes that they make on
Kiwi Farms all the time is that Kyla got kicked in the head.
>> Okay. This guy cannot just take all of our jokes and
give them to Kiwi Farms.
That's our joke. Well, that's Queen. I think Queim said that
joke first. Okay, dude. Quimman made that joke happen over like
months. What the?
You cannot just give that joke to Kiwi Farms. That's up >> by
a horse and so she or whatever. That's like a huge talking point
from So that's like a KF. But these people also >> she
does actually have CTE though. She she literally has CT from
falling off a horse as a kid. This is like a joke and it's funny
because >> they cross from KF like here. But then >> dude,
that's our joke. What the This is so up dude. This is actually
up. Obviously, you'll have um obviously you'll have um them denying
that they, you know, do any of that or talk about any of that,
but like it's it's very obvious if you're like familiar with
the communities. It's always like the plausible deniability.
No, we made that joke up. That's our joke. What? Hold on. Somebody
said this. What? Cuz I know he watches my stream all the time.
And Quinn was like, "Yes, we Yes, we will do that from now on."
Yeah, this is us conspiring to with you uh openly on stream.
By the way, I I said, did we talk about this off stream or on
stream? cuz I don't even remember actually. And everybody's like,
"No, no, no. This was on stream." This is us. This is our back
room cabal is us just openly talking about it on stream. It was
live. Okay. Destiny. >> Wait, hold on. >> Remember
if it was live on stream or if it was, it should be clear.
Us joking about stuff like this and laughing about how badly
it would with him, that's not actually a conspiracy. There's
nothing hidden. We don't mind talking about it. We just laugh
at you because you're a loser. We laugh at how insecure you are.
That's all we do. Sometimes I'll sit in an open channel that
other like streamers can call into and we'll [__]
talk you there.
We don't we don't need to keep this private. We make it very
clear we don't like you. We make it very clear it's funny to
laugh at you. What's the problem in a private call? I think it
was live on stream. My point he [__] but yes we listen
to >> Who would you rather have as US president? Charlie
Kirk or Som by more than two to one. It's a song. Get out of
here. Stop agreeing with pisco. I, by the way, my my number one
piece of advice for Destiny yesterday was to basically say you
were wrong and never engage with Pisco again because every time
you engage with Pisco, he's going to own you because he works
harder than you. He's smarter than you, he's more handsome than
you, he's better than you in every way, and he will continue
to own you and take your audience from you. >> It's just
crazy how like blatant the anti-fitting. It's just like, but
it's it's so >> Oh,
it's literally just I think Pisco's That is all true. What do
you What do you mean? Where's the anti betting?
That's just all true. And yeah, you are going to get totally
owned. This guy, dude, what do you mean anti-fanning? This guy's
trying to dox me and calling for me to be How the am I anti-fanning?
How is that anti-fanning, bro? Was Stalin a anti-fan? Is that
like these people have like People are trying to kill each other?
They're at war. Are they anti-fans?
Why are you just using this word with no context attached to
it? Funny because if you watch the Kiwi Farm stuff, like they'll
praise they've praised Abby, the like mentally um the mentally
ill girl that is just non-stop posting about crazy server, but
he doesn't want to ban her because he likes the anti-fanning
farming that he could do for me. Um they >> I don't know
what he's talking about. So I don't know what he's talking about.
Like why would I ban Abby? I just don't know if I don't know
if Abby has somewhere else to go. Like I I don't know. I I feel
like she's just like not in a good place. But is banning her
like helping her? If if I felt banning her was helping her, I
would ban. But I I did not do that like calculation. So Abby
just most of the time to be honest. Yeah. Like if I felt like
I needed to ban Abby to help her, but I I don't I didn't feel
like that. I didn't see that. If that was something that was
required, then I would do that. But I just don't see why it would
be. Anyway, continue. >> Pixie, they stand Cherry. They
stand Hassan now. No, actually most of the Discord is still very
vehemently against Hassan.
Actually, the whole Discord disagrees with me on on like even
the amount of defending of Assan I do like the whole Discord
disagrees with me. And I don't I see here's the here's the crazy
thing. Okay, here's the crazy thing. When they when they disagree
with me, I do something insane, Destiny. All right, I
only ban them like 15% of the time,
>> I I just like sometimes they can just disagree with
me and that's okay. You know, sometimes sometimes sometimes >> they
[__] on Ethan Klein like it's the partisanness of
>> they [__] on Ethan Klein. What?
>> Dude, I make a post in my own Discord [__]
on Ethan Klein and I get downloaded into oblivion by my own
>> My Discord is filled with people who love H3H3. They
love Ethan.
>> That's like all the people in my Discord love Ethan
Klein.
I'm not even joking.
>> They get so mad when I talk Ethan.
>> He's just lying.
>> He's just lying right now.
>> Dan Hassan now. Um they on Ethan client like it's the
partisness of all of it is just so funny to me. Um, I don't think
we watched this on stream, but like I think two or three weeks
ago, Jessica had like a one-hour science segment with Kelly Jean
where Kelly tried to educate the audience on what the periodic
table of elements was. It was like the funniest thing. The one
where she proved that you were like wrong and you totally seethed
about and covered for hours on your stream. That one.
>> That one you totally totally seized about it and had
to try to respond and still got owned by Kelly. >> Unfortunate.
Unlucky.
Oh my goodness. >> He spent so much time covering that.
That's so funny.
>> By the way, the whole time I'm like, listen, I don't
actually care about this. I don't want to know anything. I'm
not listening even. Okay, you talk about it. You guys talk, but
like I I just kept saying I know that Destiny will see about
this because he's an insecure
and he will constantly like have to respond. I know that for
a fact. So that's what makes this funny. That is my only interest
in covering this or letting you cover it is I know Destiny will
see. So that's funny to me, but I don't care about the chemistry.
I'm not going to learn anything about chemistry. I don't give
a [__] >> It was just hilarious. >> And
then he paused and see constantly and watched the full segment
when I consistently said, "Destiny is too insecure. He's too
much of a [__] to just let this go and walk away.
He's a millionaire. He could do whatever he wants with his life,
but instead he's going to actually respond to this cuz he's a
loser." And he had to listen to me say that while he streamed.
It was >> Show us that. I I don't know. I showed one thing,
but then I think when I made a response on it the next stream,
they did another response. They had like science art with Kelly
J. I don't remember if I did the if I showed that one or not.
>> He's going to own you because he works harder than you.
He's smarter than you. He's more handsome than you. He's better
than you in every way. And he will continue to own you and take
your audience from you. If you continue to engage with him, you
will be left penniles on the street. Now, I would love that,
but I'm just saying from a pragmatic point of view, stop engage
with Pisco. He owns you. Okay, that's all. That's all. Grows
a beard better, too. I've been saying this, my in fact my my
point. >> Oh, and then um Jacob
the guy who is super mad at me because I his girlfriend before
they started dating. Um, Jacob and the rest of them also like,
>> didn't he know that before they started dating? It wasn't
like he Oh, he's going to do the thing. He tried to do loner
box as well, which is try to make it seem like, oh, Jacob found
out about this and he's really mad. I'm pretty sure Jacob knew
before they ever dated that Destiny and Zoe had a relationship.
That was kind of public if you don't know that from the Discord.
It was like a whole public thing that everybody knew Zoe and
Destiny had a thing. And then Jacob met her and then they had
got in a relationship. Pretty sure he 100% knew about that. Zoe
versus Lab was before they even talked. Yeah, that's not shocking,
dude. I It's like actually crazy that he could just make these
things up and people believed them. Well, no, it's not really
crazy. These people are totally cognitively sad. >> Obsessively
talk about because I have um a condition called alipcia arietta,
which an autoimmune >> actually my really gross beard is
because I have a condition. I have a condition, guys.
Can you This is a disability. It's really ableist for you to
make fun of my beard. Actually, guys, can you please stop? Can
you please stop? Can you please stop? Jacob, for old times sake,
hit me with a beard picture. Okay, I realize you've got you don't
have your Discord. I don't have your Discord. Okay, hit me with
a beard picture. Where's a beer? For all time's sake, let's pull
up a beard picture. Okay. Honestly, to me, it seems so petty
and small to do this sometimes. I don't really do it that often,
but it actually upsets him. All of these petty small things upset
him more than anything tangible. If he was found guilty in the
Pixie case, he would not be angry. He would be angry about me
showing a picture of his ugly beard on stream. I don't even think
he cares about the pixie case like at all tangibly like how it
goes other than public narrative. He He would actually be mad
if I show his ugly beard picture on stream. It's I don't really
I don't really empathize with it. I don't understand it, but
it is the thing that upsets him more than >> New disease
that attacks your hair. So, when my beard was missing this huge
like chunk, apparently Keep From thinks I just draw it in now
and none of it's growing back, I guess. Um, but they like >> do
a close-up.
Wait, hold on. Where was the close-up? Didn't Kathy post >> bring
that up as much as possible, too? Cuz apparently it super really
bothers >> It does. It actually does, dude. This is maybe
the only >> I also I don't know who started this. I don't
think Hassan gets credit for this, but like the fake the super
fake
like the ultra fake laughing on every single talking point. Go
a beer better
I've been saying this my that is in fact my my point. This is
maybe the only I can't remember if it was live on stream or if
it was in a private call. I think it was live on stream, but
me and Qu were sitting here. I I caught up this point. I'm like,
dude, I'm just going to start saying how much better Pisco's
beard is than Destiny cuz I know he watches my stream all the
time. And then the really funny thing about this was when Kelly
revealed that it was actually Chad um Justic who was feeling
bad for being fat and apparently Kelly and Cherry I guess were
trying to console him because he was like super overweight >> What?
Okay, cool. >> Because he stopped going out or doing anything
and is depressed and is crazy or whatever depending on how much
you believe from Kelly. So I guess that's where the >> huh
Kelly do be saying things. Uh the fat accusation
>> I Kelly also
okay Kelly be safe >> come from um to try to cover for
justicical I guess insecurity around it
>> I I run 5ks in the time I run them okay pretty hard
to fake it was like yes we will do that from now on
it was live okay I was like oh that sounds like cabal in the
background but we did it live okay it's very funny to me uh and
then des started call a communist so like who's really winning
who's really winning okay >> I don't think I've ever called
pisco Pisco I don't think Pisco is a communist. I just don't
think that they give cover to those people. But I mean obviously
I know it was not trying to cover anything in good faith or whatever.
So >> I just took Pisco saying that you called him a communist
as like I don't I don't think Pisco makes assertions very often.
I didn't look into that. Um
I know you said he was like mind by socialist girlfriend. I know
you said that. I know you've implied that like straight is changing
his mind. So maybe you kind of got around this somehow by like
sort of webbing them together and not making the allegation directly
because you are a disingenuous loser. Can't even speak with your
chest, >> but you've definitely intimated it. You've definitely
implied it, right? 100%. So you're just being a you're just
>> I mean, oh, wait, wait. I have a thing for this. I just
think it's funny. No, not that one. Wait.
>> Okay. It us all the time.
Ah, I got to get that other Han laugh. Damn. What was that? What
was that? What was that? Oh, I also don't have my time on the
stream. What the Whoops. I didn't have the time. Oops.
Hold on. I'm getting a message. I'm getting a message. I'm getting
a
>> Sorry. He also sent this one. I believe they're they're
like a pair.
I believe they're like a pair. Like the the with the
Oh, we love it. We love it. We love it. We love to see it. Good
times. Good times. Okay. So, even Destiny sub shares that preference
with me. So now if you express a preference for Assan for Donald
Trump you endorse Assassan want to be friends with Assan want
to build bridges with Assan. Absolute derangement sorry to say
yes it's like Han is like the fourth worst worst person in America
is what you're saying and DJs are like no you don't say he's
the worst. You love him. It's like no he's like the fourth worst
actually. You're like the fourth worst. He's like the fourth
worst. No stop. He's the worst. >> I wonder how long they
cover you covered this for. When was this? This is 2 days ago.
An 8 and a half hour stream. >> I covered the Pisco I covered
the Pisco show for a long time. Pisco I actually dude I it's
so cool having Pisco like covering this stuff because I can actually
engage with politics and not feel like disgusted by hearing your
>> I'll I'll soldier through that that stream from tomorrow
or for tomorrow. But you love it. Thank you very much. Appreciate
it, buddy.
>> What is this? >> Not
like that. Get back. Get on to the browser.
Let me Oh. Oh, cool. I love that you can see all the links. Damn.
Thank you for whoever linked that post.
>> Yeah, somebody said, "Oh, look, somebody did a good
post on on this." Why Why are we pretending like this is proof
of a conspiracy of some kind? Why Why would I wouldn't doubt
that the person who posted this actually linked it to people
or linked it in different communities saying like, "Hey, check
this out." I know Azel linked it to me. He probably saw somebody
else covered on stream. Dude, streamers and their audiences moving
between uh different streams and being like, "Oh, here's another
piece of content somebody else pulled up." That's the most natural
thing in the world. That's how Desi gets half of his links.
Are we talking about? Yeah, I also saw Queen cover it. So, like
this just getting linked around. If you have criticism, if you
think this is like people lying, actually engage with the clip.
Don't just engage with part of the clips and then say, "Oh, actually,
I'm going to mind read Hassan. He's lying."
>> so this is just to go on stream, right? We just heard
him talk about Quean and bring up Arerudite and now he's going
over the poster here who's posting a Pisco subreddit who is also
a this
sorry I got to chill. Um
this idiot I believe is this the morning he was like trying to
dox me? I they run together now. He's trying to dox like multiple
different people. They run together. Was this one of the mornings
he was trying to dox me? I wonder why I cover like basically
anti- Destiny content on a day where he was like trying to harass
me.
Right. Is that confusing to anybody? Or even this stuff? This
stuff we've just been following for a long time. I think one,
okay, hold on, hold on. Let me let me state something because
it sounds like I'm maybe concerned. One, if I wanted to cover
Destiny all day, every day for the rest of time, I would do that
cuz I'm fine being called obsessed and I would I would just make
my criticisms as they come, right? So, I would say it I I am
obsessed. I do I do hate this guy, okay? I would cover him as
much as I feel like I want to cover him. But in this case, the
the Hassan is bad arc has been like a three to four month arc
on this stream, right? Where I'm telling people like Hassan is
bad to like soothe them so they understand that I'm not saying
Hassan is good. I'm just pointing out that the criticism of him
is currently unhinged, right? That's been like a three or four
month arc on this stream.
And this is like the arc coming to a head because a lot of the
people watch my stream are former DGers. And I do have to do
the Hassan is bad to get them like to understand that I'm not,
you know, just trying to glaze Hassan. I'm just trying to point
out that like, hey, some of these criticisms are wrong. So, this
is this whole arc coming to like an absolute head, a crescendo
for me, so of course I'm going to cover all of this stuff. How
could I not? That's like what I've been getting my stream invested
in is like this this core argument that like you and your community
maliciously lie about people. You damage their reputations and
that perhaps they're just slightly off of what we thought, right?
So Hassan, it's like, yeah, Hassan's not the worst person in
America. He's like the fourth worst or something, right? He's
like not he's not the absolute worst. And painting him that way
is kind of insane. So is Hassan good now? Yeah, that's like that's
what happens every time. It's happening to Pisco right now. And
it happened to Pisco and you'll actually engage with Pisco. Yeah,
it's it's fun to watch in real time. >> DG Snarker um and
a Hassan defender and a loner box poster. And now we see just
going over his post on stream relating to the Yeah. Jesus. I
just got linked this post by Chatter
tweets. Does he do this for all six and a half hours today? >> I
might. I am obsessed. I am unhinged.
I'm crazy.
I'm a deranged stalker.
>> Oh, okay. He's going >> I didn't say he can stay
engaged with an argument. Okay.
>> In his like in his like girl in the in the ceno US war.
Okay. He's obviously like no I actually argue with Supreme. I
let Supreme come in and I I make my arguments back to him China.
He obviously has a lot of sympathies for China. It's obvious
just in his like in his like throwaway commentary. Oh, this is
this is some Hassan is not as good things. Yeah, I'll get I'll
get credit for that. Right. I'm basically explaining why like
what I think Hassan's beliefs are in China. Like I don't think
anybody's Meowi's left. What? Wait, what? Where did Meowies didn't
leave the Discord, did she? She's on like vacation or something.
What do you mean left?
Wasn't Meowi's just on vacation? Hold on. Let me see here.
>> Oh, okay. I me in the app. God damn it.
>> I know. I know. Never mind. Confused about how Hassan
likes China. Continuing a lot of We'll go a little deeper than
that to probably sus out exactly what he believes or what he
>> Okay, it's only for like two and a half hours of this
stream. >> Like ideologically commits to >> X consented
to anonymous. >> What? That's totally good faith right
there. By the way, share their experience with Thor. Oh, I did.
I stopped covering Destiny on this stream. Why did I just keep
covering him the whole time? This is one of those very rare maybe
unique >> improved whatsoever. The way he pathetical response.
No one wants to be in the position I'm in. It's a lose-lose situation.
It's hard for me to talk about it. And nowhere did I request
for you to make a specific statement. Why? >> What even
what is this about? I don't even know. Oh, this is over the over
pirate software. Oh, then some more Destiny at the end. Nice.
>> Oh, look. It's the guy. He's in the chat. Oh, this was
literally me going like, "Hey, Clement, I don't know if you saw
this. Like, what did you think about this at the end of a stream?"
Cuz it was about to be done. >> Crazy. what's going to
happen to the brains of these people if you win your court case.
Um the talks on all the >> I literally I literally have
said from the very beginning I have no idea like they it's basically
all coming down to discovery and I don't know how that's going
to go >> has been slowly evolving over time. Um where Kiwi
Farms and justical community is now is the outcome of the court
case actually doesn't matter at all. They've all decided that
enough evidence has been released on Pixie Substack that I'm
guilty of every single thing that they accuse me of and the court
case. >> No, it's not Pixie Substack. is like overall right
we have multiple allegations like if you say if you say yeah
I didn't transmit this without somebody's consent in a court
case we can't use contextual evidence we can't use like uh what
would you call it we can't use evidence that would bias a jury
so we can't refer to all the other women who've said you sent
their without consent that you actually did send in the same
way we can't refer to your Bob 7 stuff where Molina said hey
could you please stop Molina said could you please stop sending
my stuff to people without my consent You're like, "Oh, oopsie.
Little consent. Oopsie."
Right.
Uh, but there is. Yeah, there's like six, seven women. We don't
believe you got consent for this stuff. It's like pretty obvious
to anybody who looks at it, but it was fine. >> This is
literally just a formality matter. It doesn't actually matter.
>> Literally, his excuse was the Dave Chappelle. I didn't
know I couldn't do that. Sorry, officer.
Hold on. Hold on. Where is it? I It's not going to be worth it
for the payoff, but
What? Oh, this isn't the right one. Oh, well. It's like I didn't
know I couldn't do that. >> Um, if I'm guilty or not. So,
that So, we're at right now is basically the outcome doesn't
matter. >> Uh, Mark Carney, if you're just going to start
naming like other people. I just You just keep things in the
lines right now. You got to go for a day.
Okay. No, none of that. None of that. None of that. None of that
garbage. Okay. It's total garbage. Don't be a
Don't come in and start throwing other names for people to go
you stop. Anyway, so literally none of the logs prove anything
at all. He's basically taking the memes that started on this
stream or Queen's stream, right? And he's attributing those to
Kiwi Farms because Kiwi Farm started saying them after they realized
we're funny and awesome. Yes. And so he's taking memes from our
streams and saying, "Hey, uh, this is actually Kiwi Farm stuff."
It's like me going and saying like Uh-huh. Riperino Cappuccino.
That's actually like a deranged Vos style meme or a Kiwi Farms
meme. Don't say it anymore, right? Not I don't know if he says
that anymore, but it would be like that. Like taking something
that's been on his stream forever and then just attributing it
to somebody else and being like, "Oh, that's proof." >> He's
literally using Ethan Klein's tactic against Snark. Just say
they did CPS. Say they sent Skulls and the We'll believe it.
So the >> This is unironically true. You could you could
hate it because of the comparison because it's like an Ethan
Klein. It's like implying Ethan Klein is uh on the wrong side
of it, right? But that's literally the tactic is just keep saying
the bad things that happened to you and then your audience will
feel bad for >> They think that didn't happen or bro, how
did these people not get bored talking about Destiny all the
time? Half the time I'll leave stream and come back because I
need attention. Yeah, I have no idea. I have no clue. I don't
know how they can but I but I'm never um >> Didn't he just
spend like 4 hours talking about this stuff? This whole this
whole Hassan is bad thing has been like the arc. The whole Ethan
Hassan Destiny thing. Hassan is bad. This has been our part of
the arc. >> I haven't been part of these communities ever,
so it's hard to say. It's just not the type of content I can
say. I guess is that is this my friend turned also co-accus or
whatever. Best way to just ignore him and don't watch him. Damn.
I don't know if Stacy's
or Stacey or whatever. >> No, Stazzy is not Stasia. No,
>> it's a conspiracy when they do it. It being whenever
he makes up and won't provide proof of or hurls loose associations
that aren't connected when his community does full send open
campaigns and astroturfing doing actual organized harassment.
It's fake news and or they are just criticizing people who deserve
it. This man is a whole website hosting embeds for anyone they
hate or random girls they bombard and harass trying to get destiny
to where's the you can't just read in an incredulous tone and
say it doesn't happen. Now, the the girls thing is a little more
rare, and I've seen at least RTBA try to clean that up before,
but
absolutely, Queen and Raid. Let's go. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Uh we're just going over this uh Destiny.
Destiny reviews my Discord. I review Destiny reviewing my Discord.
Okay. And we're watching him currently try to look at all of
these chatters saying Destiny provides no evidence. And he's
going, "Huh?" So like you just say I have like a website that
like organizes harassment. You say like we're doing open full
send harassment campaigns against people like uh okay whatever
you say whatever you say it's like yeah the whole Twitch anti-semitism
thing is you weaponizing your community. Yeah. All this is weapon.
Yeah. When you you post like what you think is a doc picture
of me in your community and then retweet that. Yeah. Or somebody
does organized harassment campaigns, right? Yeah. That's what
it all is >> over them. There was some um Twitch streamer
I think that was that my chat was watching like two months ago
and Blav decided that it was like a Gain Maxwell situation where
they were secretly trying to get this person to be like a new
buddy of mine like I don't have anybody else I guess in my life
to have sex with right now. Um and then they started pushing
the conspiracy and then they were like oh my god we have to email
her stuff and set her to make her know how horrible. I don't
even know who this is. I've never talked to this person never
DM' this person. He doesn't know the timeline here. Again, this
is cereal for every meal. And she basically did a talk with Arerodite.
Kind of humiliated Arerodite. And me and Queen both laughed at
it. And then she deleted her videos and asked Ardite not to associate
with her anymore or some. Yeah. So, GG >> in my entire
life. But they were convinced that there was like some huge >> But
that was way before the Kiwi Farms narrative stuff, I think,
like trafficking attempt there. And that's what he's referencing
here is that one person that was hosted. Um Oh, somebody told
me that this person is Oh, no wait. The pink name is a demoted
mod. Zezy.
Zezy's. It's over for Zezy. Zezy's about to commit sukoku. Zezy's
totally owned. Destiny just destroyed you live on stream. It's
over.
It's more over than your your time as an admin. Zezy. It's It's
all done. That'll teach you to call me a peer in the Discord.
Okay. That'll teach you
get owned.
>> Okay. Why would that detail be relevant for his stream?
Somebody somebody like pointed that out to him. I can't imagine
what kind of loser would keep track of that and point that out
to him. Like just think of the absolute disaster of a human being
that would be following promotions and demotions of mods in my
Discord and DMing or messaging Destiny in DGG chat. Like just
an absolute
Jessica forced to be a stupid condescending. Now Jessica gave
her the brain damage. Nice, >> dude. These are Bro,
this is the softest
in the world,
dude. When when I was like, "Hey, Destiny, it's really concerning
that your community is like trying to paint me as some kind of
anti-semite." When you know that's not true. When you know that
I like DM you clips in the moment during your Fentes debate to
help you like not get your so hard, right? You know that I'm
not an anti-semite. You know I don't actually support those ideologies
at all. And his response was, "Hey man, just try not to focus
on it. Just give it like 3 days and it'll go away."
And now these guys are like, "Dude, JTO, I guess, gave Aerodite
the brain damage." And he's like, "Oh, this is so disgusting.
This is so unhinged." Really? Oh, we are now the reason for some
random Reddit post on the Pisco subreddit. Holy sh, bro.
Dude, his community says the insane is a thousand times worse
about you towards me. Yeah. Yeah. Like he dude, how can none
of these criticisms? He doesn't like hold the mirror up for any
of these criticisms, right? He's just totally he makes these
criticisms and he doesn't think about how they'd apply back at
him at all. Not even a tiny amount. And I would just be I'd be
like embarrassed to be around him if he if he's going and trying
to fight with like a Discord and be like these are the worst
these are the worst messages,
right? And it's like the softest
in the whole world.
Oh, JTO give her the brain damage. Oh my god, he's still crying
about the Dr. K. Nothing burger lol already blocked again. I'm
not the manipulator you all >> He's still crying about
the Dr. K nothing burger.
the remember when it came out that Jess had to commit Cherry
because she was going to herself for 3 days to an insane asylum
and they're still dating and he still has her on stream and in
Discord spamming stuff about online drama which is definitely
the most mentally healthy thing you can do for somebody that
had to be committed because they were um but uh I would assume
that not totally disassociating from the person if they were
feeling like bad I assume that's probably the way I'd go that
I would you know have a dialogue with that being in a relationship
and we would talk about like, hey, what's what's like best here?
And we figure that out. It would be like a joint plan. I don't
know. He's like, he thinks that this is going to like somehow
turn me against Cherry or somehow I don't know. Like the general
theory I have is that he wants to try to isolate Cherry. He wants
to make it so other people don't interact with her, right? It's
it's broadly just stupid. It's not going to work. I'm not going
to let it work. She's not going to let it work. I don't know
why he's acting. And again the weaponized just the weaponized.
Oh, what is it? It's uh it's not virtue signaling. It is concern
trolling.
My you recorder without her consent. You distributed to multiple
people without her consent. You are a sick. Stop concern trolling.
Stop pretending you care. He is unironically the person who's
harmed her ability to trust the most and he sits here virtue
signaling as if he gives a
disgusting. It's inhuman. But this is definitely just a big nothing
burger, >> This is, by the way, the best logs he's found.
The only ones he's really wanted to read are about that. He's
not reading. He's scrolling this. Is nobody in his chat going
like, "Hey, wait. Like, aren't most of these people just like
mocking you? Isn't this like fairly tame? Isn't this like way
more tame than DG chat? Wait, Destiny, you should compare this.
Why don't you pull up mentions of JTO or in your chat and see
what the mentions are like in comparison? Could we check that?
I don't want to. I don't want my feelings hurt. But I'm guessing
they'd be unhinged, which by the way is fine. They're jokes.
They're people messing around in a chat, right? They're people
that hate me that are talking.
>> Why the would I try to police that? They'd be way worse
than this, though. Jay Gord got Abby committed after that. Wait,
did they really?
>> Sorry, I'll respond to this one more time. But Destiny,
you trying to defend yourself against spaces exactly what they
want? Do one day of recaps every month if you have to, but opening
the stream with it every time just so I don't know where you're
getting. opening stream with it every time. >> Destiny,
you seem kind of obsessed with this actually. Destiny, don't
you feel like maybe you're a little obsessed with this? Actually,
>> I'm not. But I do I have to point this out because these
people are constantly and actively working like in all of these
little other >> If I don't point out that they keep saying
that I don't have evidence, then people will start to believe
that I don't have evidence.
Why don't I just post the evidence? Um, it's secret. >> Side
communities that all these other people are actively a part of.
Um, like they've doxed and harassed like Willie Mack. They've
doxed Hutch. They've doxed Josiah. Um they've >> again
he has admitted that this doesn't happen in my community. That
he has no proof of my community participating. There's no proof
of me participating. And he is just associating these things
for no reason. His proof, some of his proof here is that these
people talk about Destiny while he does a segment on this Discord.
He is actively streaming about this Discord in this exact moment
in time. And that is his proof apparently that they're connected
to something. Again, I'll just say the connection is we don't
like you. We don't like you.
>> Stop seething about us not liking you. We're never going
to like you. You can't debate us into liking you.
Go somewhere else. Dox Aerodite. U they're trying to go after
like people like food shops, who's a person I also like don't
talk to. I'm not even friends with them on Discord. Um these
people are constantly conniving and working. Uh and it's worth
calling out. Yeah. Like I have to say something. Um, it wouldn't
be a big deal if people like all the way up to Hassan weren't
actively catapulting these people or their messages or their
rhetoric out to everybody else. Usually these people just kind
of like stay in their own. I literally have no idea. He just
makes these leaps. See you later, Kico. Food chops. Yeah, apparently
I think I think people talk about food shops on Kiwi Farms.
Hold on a second.
um side communities, but the um but now that there are other
larger creators that are kind of amplifying everything coming
from them, I I have to kind of spotlight it. >> Uh Jacob,
I pointed this out on stream already that like the that stuff
happened before. Now, it was rebrought up and doxing, you know,
would be like drawing attention to it and stuff. You could say
that's doxing, but the the original times they were they had
their privacy like exposed was yes. Before I started um
was way before I left the orbit. Yes, that is true. Same with
Arerodite. But he's trying to paint it as like me and Quimman
doing this and getting them docked. It's just not true. Right.
It's not true at all. What am I looking for here? Hold on a second.
One second. Sorry. Sending a message >> at least a little
bit. Um I'm new to all this. Why are they Oh,
hold on. Uh-oh. pulling up a Gat Fumodor clip on stream. Not
good.
Hard to imagine a more imperfect V victim in this instance. It's
genuinely bizarre how much of this guy's content really does
just seem to be him harassing people. Random techone clip. What
could it be? Gate. Gay.
Nah. Gate. Gate. A. >> Guys, I'll be real. I think somebody
needs to jerk Destiny off. I do. I do. I think I >> What
an odd thing to say. What? What? What an odd thing to say. >> I
think somebody needs to trigger Destiny's prostate and finally
let this man come. Somebody give this guy an orgasm.
Somebody trigger this man's
this is some unhinged Is this guy implying that Destiny's not
getting laid? Is this guy an unhinged Kiwi farmer promoting anti-fan
snark narratives to his thousands of viewers? Also, I'll never
ever ever believe that Teto's not gay. I'm sorry. I'm sorry,
Techie. Sorry, Techie.
I'm sorry. That was That went to a weird place. Okay, buddy.
Why do you Why does he have to do that through stimulation to
the prostic? Are you Very odd. Very odd. Okay. All right. >> Obsessed
hate you so much. Um,
when Food Chops put out her first JTO video, I went into her
Discord and told her to keep it up.
If she's following extreme dad advice, I that's probably not
good. >> I don't I'm not 100% sure. I don't know. I actually
can't answer that question. Jessica used to be kind of like a
container, but now that there are other larger creators that
are kind of amplifying everything coming from them, I I have
to kind of spotlight it at least a little. >> Does somebody
ask why like what's changed in that discord behind beside them
not liking Destiny?
>> Cuz I definitely covered Hassan like this much, right?
Like I I definitely covered Hassan this exact much and everybody
in DG loved that and it wasn't unhinged or insane >> a
little bit. Um I'm new to all this. Why are they obsessed and
hate you so much? Um I don't I'm not 100% sure. I don't know.
I actually can't answer that question. Just >> really you
can't think of anything that you might have done between like
when they liked you in December and when they hated you in January?
Can't think of something that might have come out some new information.
Guys, I just have no idea what could have possibly happened.
I just don't Man, I don't know. I don't know. Why do they hate
me?
What larger creators are boosting you? Apparently, Hassan and
Bad Empanada.
Very interesting. Mexico used to be kind of like a containment
center for all of the weird anti-fanning and now or for all of
the like drama and now it just become like a massive anti-fanning
server. But like all of these people also filter over into spicy
chat from Chudlo Logic server. Um and then they filter into the
commentary community through Que and kind of like Dioro Nicholas
Dioro. That's one of the reasons why he's so like unhinged against
me on Twitter is because they kind of have him a little bit and
then from there >> dude can you at least Destiny I need
to tell you whatever chatter is feeding you this information.
They're about as good at their job and smart and doing really
good as not so erodite is. Okay. So you need to double check
some of the things they tell you cuz you look like a completely
[__] I can't use the word. You look like a complete
on your stream when you say these things not knowing that we
have like a Nick hates us.
What the else can we say?
GG brain train is real. It's like so sad. Like he doesn't get
this checked by anybody. Post the cake gift. Not right >> There.
They also try to like spread out to people like um you've seen
them like dox and harass Willie Mack and go on this weird like
Israeli wife attack thing. Um yeah. >> I don't even know
if I made the Israeli joke about uh Willie Mack. I made it about
other content YouTubers or commentary YouTubers, right? I think
I said it about Dioro. was like, "Do we know do we know if Daro
has been approached by any Israeli
women?" Which, trust me, I totally denounce the stuff that I
disavow the stuff that happened to Willie. I don't think anybody
should have their with on like a special day like that. I actually
don't even if I I and I do hate that guy, but like it's it's
like what? Yeah.
I don't know. I I'm pretty sure it's over now, so it's maybe
okay. Yeah. Like if you if you didn't know it was like his his
wedding was like uh something that was exposed but it's like
it's passed now. >> It's like that's up. Like I don't dude
you don't have to up somebody's wedding day. I don't know. It
feels so inhuman to me to do that. And I hate this guy.
No. People posted like their wedding announcement or something
and it said a date and I it might have said more, right? But
it's it was in the past now. And it's just like gross. Like I
Dude, it's like one day you can leave people alone, you know?
you just leave them alone. Like it's Yeah, he's like a he's like
a piece of who makes like bad YouTube videos, but like it's that's
crazy to do in my opinion. Anyway, what was this saying? Oh,
he was just talking about how me and Nicholas Dioro and Queenman
Oh, god damn it. This just my trackpad just clicked. God damn
it. Hold on. Wait, there'll be a there'll be a transcript here
now. >> I think Hutch, Josiah, and Kyla so far. >> Okay,
shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up. Shut up.
to find. Where were we? We were somewhere. I'll just I'll just
click through. We'll find it.
>> Fascist piece of that's doing >> video. We'll
just find it. Where were we? Not on accountable yet. Somewhere
around here. We're getting there. We're getting there. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. Oh >> But and then from there they also try to
like spread out to people like um you see them like dox and harass
Willie Mack and go on this like Israeli wife attack thing. Yeah.
It's all just all part of the all part of the group. >> Over
under on him watching right now. Uh, probably not watching right
now. I don't know. Maybe he is. Your beard's gross. Your beard
won't fill in. Pisco's beard is better. Just >> I guess
a lot of them are jobless or they spent all day online, so they
have nothing else to do besides constantly
talk about >> Bro, I can't I actually can't believe I actually
can't believe that
somebody was like, "Oh, that's that's disgraced admin zezy, former
adminzy.
That had to be, dude, the wretched existence of that person to
be like that familiar with the Discord that they would be tracking
the roles and then they could see that it was like gone today
and but they hate us. That must be >> This, you know, he's
really pointing to people correcting narratives to his crimes
and spin that as narrative driving being unfair. Lol. Don't hold
me accountable for my actions. This is a classic Kiwi Farms line
is um all we do is we just record what happened and hold people.
The one time Destiny had any evidence of me like slightly misspeaking,
he pulled the clip up immediately and played it, right? And that
was that I said he signed an affidavit in response to Josiah
saying non-consensual uh sent non-consensual.
He did send the he signed an affidavit saying he sent the right,
but it was uh it was not in the affidavit. It does not say without
consent, but I'm accurate. He not accurate. And he can't pull
clips on any of the other stuff that he says I >> But this
obviously they're they have their own spin and everything. But
anyway, good memes, good times. >> Phil Steve so gone.
This is going to come up cuz I think I have a thing scheduled
tomorrow.
>> Is it tomorrow? >> Okay. I don't know if I'm I
don't know if I want to go all the way into the economy stuff.
What do we do here? There's the econo boy stuff that we could
go into
or econo boy stuff cuz I could watch like Pisco's I might watch
Pisco's debate with Zip Zip. That was really embarrassing. You
filing in Pixie's case? Yeah, but I So, I'm just waiting for
them to finish with the rulings on this stuff.
And like I'm waiting for the rulings to come out to start covering
stuff. What is the econo boy stuff? So I got a tweet somewhere
here. Where's the econo boy tweet? I'll find it in just a second.
Give me a sec. But a boy tweeted and it
I think Destiny like called him a socialist or something. Or
sorry, not called him a socialist. Said he was maybe hiding his
beliefs. I can't even remember anymore. The Connell boy. Dude,
the zip zip thing is just so funny. He cries a lot about you
during the the Pisco debate. Oh, right. Wait, is the is the zip
zip thing here? Bro, I actually I just point out the whole time.
I just dude, my comments are just pointing out what's happening
in the debate is very very funny. Oh, if he actually engages
with what I'm saying, >> nothing to do with capitalist
versus socialist, right? White terror has nothing. He's definitely
just hunting us on like holy
like it is the for one second. I'm not I'm not that type of person
who says like we don't need an organization that is going to
solve be parietas in our society government like law or whatever.
moving on a pre-approved Israeli Israel supports all the radicalization
pipeline in order to reach you know the the >> is there
not does he not do the zip >> I don't know I I think the
furthest I was willing to go would >> dude where's the
does he not do the zip zip debate >> you've already like
conceded that like unclear is not acceptable when you're being
asked about this here right well then there
people's arguments but we have to remember okay and this is why
>> this isn't this isn't zip zip right I don't think So
I think he's a different voice. He does. Is this It's before
this guy. Well, hold on.
How >> agree? Well, in prison or
he you took with me saying and I think he's more apt to be a
liberal than Ken. Like he's not just apt to be a liberal. He's
a He's a Marxist Leninist. And I'm just like >> I said
he's explicitly a liberal. Maybe he doesn't fall under that specific
title of Marxist Leninist. I don't >> This isn't this isn't
zip zip. Where's the zip zip thing? Come on. Zip zip.
I don't even see it here. Does he stream more or something? Zip.
Oh, it's Zip Zip. It's Zip. Space Zip with Donald
>> Part one, reeducation and Hassan's ideological beliefs.
On yesterday's stream, someone named Zip Zip called in and claimed
that Assan wants reucation camps and referred to his conversation
with Ethan Klein about them. Assan does not believe in having
reeducation camps and this interpretation that he does is clearly
bad faith. When you listen to Hassan's watch,
Destiny, Nope, not that. Hold on. I'm just looking for what we're
going to next because I'll go switch over to
Queen and stuff, too. Let me get a time stamp. Please do get
a time stamp and I'll cover it, but I can't find zip zip stuff
in there. Okay,
interesting allegations. So, there's some econom boy thing here.
We can watch this for a quick second.
>> Maybe a stupid condescending. No. Anyway, good memes,
good times. Throw over into spicy chat from Chudlo Logic server.
Um, and they filter into the commentary community through Quean
and kind of like Dioro Nicholas Dioro. That's one of the reasons
why he's so like unhinged against me on Twitter is because they
>> do we I think we just go to the zip zip thing with with
Pisco. I think that's very funny.
Isn't Zip Zip some known DJ? Why do they call someone say someone
called Zip Zip? I don't know. I don't know why they said that,
but I want to go to the Zip Zip conversation because it was just
very very very
funny to me.